Also, ich weiß ja nicht, was wäre, wenn Microsoft einfach jetzt Nokia kauft. Da haben wir schon häufig drüber geredet. Was ist, wenn die die einfach kaufen?
Funktional kaputt.
Meine Meinfahrt sind ja auch eher slow.
Wenn Daten gesammelt werden, werden sie auch missbraucht.
Also, was wäre eigentlich, wenn sie Nokia kaufen würden?
Also, so eine TD ist ja auch eher so ein Token für ein Konzert.
Wir sollten mal mehr über Macs reden.
Macs reden, ich sag's hier, über Macs reden.
Ich träume ja irgendwann mal davon, dass ich vielleicht mal einen Clean Install machen könnte hier von meiner Kisse.
Zeit wird es auf jeden Fall.
Ja, willkommen bei der Freak Show.
Hier, wo die echten Freaks leben.
Verrückte Delic.
Wer ist jetzt so freaky, das glaubt ihr gar nicht. Fremdschirm für Fortgeschrittenes. Das sind die Dinge, die die Welt bewegen, das ist das, was diese Sendung ist. Hallo da draußen, wir sind's wieder.
An den Empfangsgeräten.
Genau, an den Hörgeräten und wir haben gute Laune, wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt, bei den Voraussagen. Ich meine, das war doch ein Schwarze getroffen, oder?
Alles wird besser.
Also, ja, du hast da echt den richtigen Riecher gehabt. Muss man ja neidlos anerkennen.
Ja, wo ist eigentlich Dennis?
Der ist, glaube ich, auf irgendeiner karibischen Insel und lebt von seinen Bitcoin-Millionen.
Jetzt hast du es verraten.
Ich hab nicht gesagt, welche.
Ach so, ja.
Also, Dennis hat noch die Sonne auf dem Bauch irgendwie und vermehrt seine Daten. Ja, ist irgendwas passiert?
Ja, also, ich hab mir jetzt Papierschredder angeschaut.
Ja, das war zu lesen, das hatte mich so ein bisschen...
Da müssen wir unbedingt noch mindestens jetzt erst mal eine Stunde über... Also ich meine, wir reden hier über das Gegenteil und das Papierlose Büro. Ohne Scheiß, ja, ihr mit euren Snapscans oder wie die heißen zum Papierlosen Büro.
Ja, ich hab jetzt auch einen.
Genau, und zum Papierlosen Büro gehört ja auch der Umkehrschluss, nämlich wenn es dann gescannt ist, direkt das Papier auch zu schreddern.
Man muss direkt runterfallen.
Ja, genau, also das wäre ja eigentlich eine Toolchain und deswegen... Und bei Tim natürlich ist auch der Schredder direkt neben dem Snapscan.
Das ist ein wichtiges Thema. Ein neuer Gerät. Ja, ein neuer Scansnap. Und zwar ein, der von oben mit so einer Kamera drauf guckt. Also nicht so ein Durch-Schnuffelscanner wie die anderen, sondern so ein Draufguckscanner, wo du halt so ein Buch aufgeschlagen hinschmeißen kannst.
Ah, so ein richtiger Buchscanner.
So ein alles mögliche, was nicht durch so ein Durch-Schnuffelscanner durchpasst. Habe ich ja auch.
Hab ich ja übrigens gerade vor kurzem gemacht. Kann ich mal kurz hier herumreichen? Genau, ich wollte das Buch einfach gescant haben und hab's dann einfach in den Copyshop gebracht, wo sie ja immer diese geilen Cutter haben, diese Papierschnar, diese richtigen Oschis, diese Maschinen.
Und da hast du hinten die Bindung weggecuttet.
Genau, dann cuttest du einfach hinten die Bindung weg und dann kannst du die in diesen iX500 einfach so reinstecken und schwuppschwuppschwuppschwuppschwupp. Hast ein gescanntes Buch komplett durchdurchsuchbar. Ich hab's getestet, alles perfekt. Buchscanner umblättern und so weiter, das dauert ja Tage.
Distributed.
Geht natürlich nur mit Taschenbüchern, aber mit Taschenbüchern geht's super.
Wieso? Mit anderen Büchern geht's auch.
Aber das ist natürlich noch schader um die Bindung.
Weiß ich nicht, ob du die so sauber gekuttet bekommst.
Warum denn? Du musst nur das Hardcover abmachen und der Rest ist vielleicht eine Fadenbindung, aber im Bronschi hast du dann nur die Seiten.
Genau, richtig, das sind die ja auch gerade.
Und die Dinger können was. Wir haben in der Drucke reinpotzt, dann haben wir so ein Teil, auch damit kannst du zwei Telefonbücher übereinanderlegen. Das schneidet der durch wie Butter.
Diese Telefonbücher?
Sind das die hydraulischen?
Die müsste man mal scannen.
Ja, das ist sehr interessant.
Ich hab's mal probiert mit dem iX500.
Telefonbücher?
Telefonbuch? Nein, diese dünnen Seiten auf jeden Fall.
Und war aber nicht so gut.
Nee, mag er nicht. Das frisst er einfach weg und dann ist bekloppt.
Aber so Batchscanner und so von oben und so, super. Bei den Schreddern, hab ich gesehen, gibt's nämlich auch welche, da machst du so eine Luke auf und steckst einfach deinen Stapel Papier rein, machst dir Luke zu und der macht das dann automatisch nicht mit diesem bzzz bzzz alles von Hand machen, sondern Luke auf, Zeug rein und bzzz. Und danach ist es weg.
Aber die sind dann auch nicht mehr so für ein Taschengeld zu haben.
Nee, die sind nicht mehr für ein Taschengeld zu haben.
Wir haben in der Firma diese Tonnen rumstehen, diese Alutonnen, wo du dann das Zeug reinschmeißen sollst und dann werden sie abgeholt und ich weiß nicht, wohin die dann schreddern, ob die direkt an die NSA schreddern oder ich weiß es nicht.
Ich hatte übrigens was gelesen, nur so, keinen Witz jetzt, kann natürlich auch einer von diesen 5-Milliarden Verschwörungstheorien sein, die jetzt auch gesprossen sind seit dem NSA-Ding. Das halte ich aber für eine relativ geniale Idee, nämlich so einen Zeilen-Scanner zu nehmen, wie so in so einem Scan-Snap drin ist und den einfach bei irgendwelchen Firmen in den Schredder mit einzubauen.
Klar.
Da kommen die Dinge alle dran vorbei, die du eigentlich nicht sehen sollst. Das ist eigentlich eine ziemlich geile Idee, finde ich.
Na, ich schredder gerne mal auch Blindmaterial. Um dann hinterher auch das Zusammensetzen wieder ein bisschen schwieriger zu machen.
Aber wie gesagt, wenn du in so einem Sign-Scanner denkst, das ist ja nur sehr klein, dieses Bauteil, wenn du das da einbaust, dann kannst du gerne schreddern, was du willst.
Vorwiegend sieht es vorher.
Diese Service irgendwie, ich fände das auch, irgendwie so suspekt. Da hast du einfach null Ahnung, was da mittelang passiert.
Gibt's zumindest auch für Festplatten, ne? Solche Buden, die auch Datenträger, früher Magnetbänder, Lochkarten fingen sie an, dann Magnetbänder, und jetzt kannst du deine alten Festplatten auch in diesen Container reinschmeißen.
Ich schraub meine alten Festplatten immer auseinander, weil da sind so schöne Magneten drin. Das Einzige, was am Kühlschrank wirklich hält, sind diese Magneten aus der Festplatte.
Die sind wirklich gut.
Naja, und dann die Scheiben, ich meine, wenn man die ein bisschen biegt und tut und macht und nochmal mit dem Magnet rübergeht, dann...
Aber das Absurde ist ja eigentlich, du sagst, ich hab hier ein wichtiges Dokument. Du machst auch schon die Auswahl für den Dienst, der dann einfach diese Tonne abholt oder durch so einen Scanner jagt.
Hier ist mein Kompromat.
Genau, pass drauf auf. Genau, mit den Festplatten. Wenn du halt eine Festplatte zu einem Service bringst und so weiter und so fort, dann sagst du ja auch schon Handle with Care.
So, jetzt hab ich dich auch glaube ich auf die richtige Lautstärke gekriegt.
In der Tat. Du hast diesen Fünfer-Anschluss hier benutzt.
Doch, aber da ich den so selten benutze, ist mir nicht aufgefallen, dass da noch ein Limiter draufgeschaltet war und das klang die ganze Zeit komisch.
Vielleicht braucht man den aber nachher noch, wenn er sich in der Arsch redet.
Da sind noch genug Limiter dahinter, da sollte bloß keiner sein. Wie auch immer, haben wir eigentlich schon irgendwas noch nicht so richtig verkündet, was wir hätten verkünden sollen. Also wir können ja noch mal kurz zusammenfassen.
Weihnachten haben wir wieder überraschend.
Große News, Europa hat jetzt keinen Handyhersteller mehr. Damit können wir doch mal einsteigen, oder?
Ja, Finland hat keinen Sinn mehr.
Wolltet ihr denn noch über Scanner reden?
Nee, über Scanner. Du hast den Scan-Snap wieder mal hervorgehoben, da dachte ich, mach ich mal einen auf Oberschlau.
Ich weiß jetzt übrigens auch, wie bekloppt diese Software ist, wo man immer irgendwie drücken muss.
Ja, also wenn man drücken muss, ist es schlimm. Man muss alles so konfigurieren, dass man möglichst wenig drücken muss.
Das hab ich noch nicht herausgefunden, wie das geht.
Da hilft mir der gerne bei.
Ja, Yes-No-Buttons und so weiter, das ist alles ganz furchtbar. Übrigens, ach so, das hast du mir doch gesagt, da gibt's eine neue Software-Release für den iX500.
Mit ohne Schnur.
Ja, und der kann halt jetzt auch W-Lan.
Moment, das Gerät konnte schon immer W-Lan, die erste Form wäre auch, aber du konntest nur mit dem iPhone, meinte ich.
Ach so, erwähnt gehabt, das stimmt auch, aber ich hatte das glaube ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Wir haben sogar die Links zu den Downloads.
Was du nicht erwähnt hattest, ist, dass dieses Update nicht umsonst unter den Updates steht, weil du kannst es nicht einfach runterladen und auf einem frischen System installieren, sondern du musst die Vorgänger-Version installieren, um dann auf die Version updaten zu können.
Wieso gibt es so viel schlechte Software da draußen, die einen so wirklich quälen? Sie gibt es immer noch.
Quälen im Magen liegt.
Also, da müssen wir auch nochmal drüber reden, aber Audio-Software steht nicht gut da.
Audio-Software?
Nicht wieder Audio-Software.
Ich glaube, das liegt vor allen Dingen.
Wie geht es in deinem Kalender eigentlich so? Besser, besser, danke.
Nur, dass wir vorhin, wir hatten...
Kalender sind auf dem Weg der Besserung.
Wir hatten vorhin Spam im Kalender. Ich hab noch keine Ahnung, wie das Scheißteil dahingekommen ist, aber irgendwie ist da irgendeine E-Mail Attachments, dritten Kalender als Vorschlag direkt einblenden. So Business-Leute, die sich so per E-Mail Termine zum Annehmen vorschicken, das landet ja dann gleich im Outlook. Und irgendwie landet es auch in unserem Google-Kalender. Das war allerdings heute Nachmittag und ich hab keine Ahnung, wie das Ding da reingekommen ist.
In Mail gibt es ja eine Einstellung, die dir sagt, dass man Kalendereinladungen bitte schön automatisch irgendwohin donnern soll.
Ja, und das kann halt hier alles mit meinem Clean Install machen. Das ist auch nochmal ein ganz interessanter Punkt. Was ist denn da der Default?
Add Invitations to Kalender, Automatically oder Never?
Wo steht denn das?
Bei den generellen Einstellungen von Mail.
Ach von Mail?
Mail, ja.
Ach ja, natürlich von Mail. General?
General, denn bei mir ist das in der Mitte ziemlich so.
Add Invitations to Kalender, Never?
Ja, dann war der es nicht, aber vielleicht einer deiner anderen 20 Rechner, die du auch clean installt hast.
Oder Telefone.
Oder Telefone. Machen die das auch? Nee, das wäre dein Alban, glaube ich.
Also, das müsste ja dann schon häufiger passiert sein. Das ist mir noch nie passiert.
Spam im Kalender. Aber sonst geht es deinen Kalendern gut.
Danke, danke der Nachfrage.
Freut alles.
Vor allem so, was die Zukunft für dich ist.
Ich wollte doch nur von der Audio-Soft verablenken. Ich will jetzt nicht wirklich wissen, wie dein Kalender geht.
Ich glaube, Audio-Softer schreiben ist einfach so schwer, dass, wenn du eine funktionierende Audio-Software fertig gekriegt hast, schon mal zufrieden bist.
Ich erst mal zurücklehne, dass du deinen Kalender aufmachst.
Ich habe sogar GPG-Mail mal wieder installiert.
Du Teufelskerl.
Apropos GPG, ich weiß, wir schweifen völlig ab.
Von welchem Pfad sollen wir denn abschweifen?
Hinaus mit der Erratik oder wie war das?
Hinein mit der Erratik.
Du hast doch letzte Sendung diese Radioshow 2600 empfohlen mit der Episode, wo sie diesen Phil Zimmermann von GPG interviewen, wo er dann auch erklärt, warum er mit seinem Service jetzt keine E-Mail mehr anbietet. Und das war dermaßen merkwürdig. Also ich weiß nicht, vielleicht ist das nur mir aufgefallen, aber erstens hat halt einer der Hosts ganz klar gesagt, ja Moment mal, GPG, also er hat ja gesagt, sie machen, sie haben den Service eingestellt, weil sie auf dem Client keine GPG-verschlüsselte E-Mail entschlüsseln können. So und dann sagte Phil noch dazu, ja die Client-Geräte, die Telefone, sind nicht leistungsfähig genug. Und dann meinte einer der Hosts, ja aber GPG gibt es doch schon seit 20 Jahren und die Rechner damals waren doch viel langsamer als das, was wir heute in der Tasche haben. Hat er nicht so recht darauf geantwortet. Und später dann sagt er, ja und unser Service, der wird außerdem von den Marine Seals und von irgendwelchen britischen Geheimtruppen und sonst wo und so weiter benutzt. Und mal ganz ehrlich, das amerikanische Militär würde unseren Service doch gar nicht benutzen, wenn sie ihn entschlüsseln könnten.
Und da dachte ich so, hä?
Also irgendwie war das strange.
Der Typ hat sich so ein bisschen im Kopf vom Kragen gefühlt.
Setz dich doch mal da vor, so eine Kamera, wenn hinter der Kamera deine 20 Lawyer stehen und die ganze Zeit irgendwie einen Ausraster kriegen.
Das war jetzt keine Kamera.
Das war ein Telefon-Interview. Aber irgendwie war das echt strange, an was der sich da verheddert hat.
Das mir jetzt nicht so bewusst aufgefallen. Ich hab das leider irgendwie in zwei Teilen gehört. Was liest du da raus?
Irgendwie kam der Typ nicht glaubwürdig rüber. Das lese ich da raus. Gerade so das als stärkstes Argument anzuführen, dass die Amerikaner das ja wohl nicht benutzen würden, wenn die NSA es entschlüsseln könnte, finde ich total absurd, dieses Argument. Es muss ihm doch klar sein, dass es ein absurdes Argument ist. Oder?
Ja, klingt jetzt nicht so souverän alles.
Ich muss mir das nochmal anhören.
Das ist ein interessanter Punkt. Klammer zu. Ja, gleich so ein schweres Thema am Anfang. Wir sollten mehr über Nokia reden.
Jetzt werden wahrscheinlich alle über Nokia reden.
Oder schon geredet haben.
Ja, oder haben schon alles durch. Wahrscheinlich schon auf dem Server, alles schon veröffentlicht. Da sitzen wir jetzt und sagen...
Eigentlich hätten wir jetzt dieses Previously über Nokia gebraucht. Über die ganzen Vorhersagen, wie Nokia sterben wird und dann verkauft wird und überhaupt und sowieso keine Chance mehr hat.
Darüber geredet haben wir auf jeden Fall ordentlich.
Sie haben immer noch die Abteilung mit der Fascho-Software und die kaputten Vermittlungsstellen am Arsch.
Also ein bisschen mehr Zug da noch. Das Zeug, was sie von Siemens übernommen haben.
Man muss glaube ich zwei Sachen unterscheiden. Man muss zwischen Nokia, die Telefon-Company und Nokia...
Der Gummistiefelhersteller.
Der das Enterprise, was halt auch noch andere Sachen macht.
Die hießen wir jetzt auch intern immer anders. Das eine Ding hieß NMP, Nokia-Mobile-Form. Und das andere Ding hieß Nokia-Network.
Ja, aber ich glaube, es ist schon klar, dass wir jetzt nicht über den Netzwerk sparen. Auch nicht über die Gummistiefel.
Aber ein finnischer Kollege von mir hat gemeint, die hätten tatsächlich auch ein eigenes Telefon-Netzwerk, also einen richtigen Provider.
Ja, es gibt ja in Finnland zwei Netze, zwei Netzbetreiber. Und der eine ist ein Nokia-Shop, ob die jetzt auch daran beteiligt waren oder nicht, ist jetzt nicht so klar. Es gibt etliche Netze in Europa, die mal so gestartet haben, zum Beispiel in Italien auch Omnitel, oder in Deutschland E+, die haben auch so angefangen. Das heißt, damals war so der Goldrausch, jetzt hier Handynetze, aah. Und dann gab es ein paar Leute, die kamen ein bisschen später, wie zum Beispiel E+, oder Omnitel, die hatten zum Beispiel keinen Bock, einfach hinzugehen und sich jetzt jahrelang mit Ausschreibungen rumzuplagen und lauter Herstellern, die sind einfach hingegangen und gesagt, hallo, wer kann uns hier mal ein Turnkey-System liefern? Hier hast du ein Geld, davon kriege ich von dir ein Netz und eine Kiste voller Handys, damit ich loslegen kann. Wenn du dich erinnerst, als E+, gestartet hat, waren ja auch diese grünen Dinger, das waren Nokia-Geräte.
Also ich hätte sie jetzt blau bezeichnet, aber es war diese Farbe.
Diese komische, dieses, ja. Wie es bei E+, weiß ich nicht genau, aber ich hatte mit Omnitel mal einen Kunden von mir, da hatte ich mit denen mal ein bisschen zu tun. Das war auch in deren Netzkontrollzentrum, auch da in Mailand. Und das war echt krass. Da waren sogar die Monitore der PCs an den Arbeitsplätzen von Nokia. Die haben einfach dieses ganze Scheiß-Ding gekauft. Das wurde dann auch von Nokia Leuten so die ersten zwei Jahre betrieben. Und dann hat das Omnitel irgendwann selber gemacht. Und dann sich Sachen dazugesteckt oder so. Aber das gab es häufiger damals. Das hat halt Ericsson auch mal gemacht. Oder Siemens hat das bestimmt auch mal irgendwo gemacht. Und von daher gibt es da ein paar, die so entstanden sind. Aber meines Wissens nach hat Nokia bis auf ihr Testnetz, was jeder Hersteller hat, in Espo. Oder wo auch immer die Fuzis da überall rumgebastelt haben. Aber Espo, Netz waren Espo. Da haben die natürlich ihr eigenes Netz. Genauso wie Siemens in München und so. Oder hatte. Oder haben NSN nicht so genau, was sie da noch aus.
Ja, wir sollten vielleicht eigentlich mal so ein bisschen kurz erläutern, was eigentlich passiert ist. Somebody set up us the bomb. Naja, so war es doch irgendwie. Also erst kam, ich grübel gerade, wir hatten das in der letzten Sendung, war das noch nicht, ne? Das ist von Ballmer nicht die Rede. Ich glaube, das war das gerade einen Tag danach.
Wann ist denn der zurückgegangen?
Wann hat der seinen Rücktritt angegeben?
Weiß nicht, vor einer Woche oder... Also muss eigentlich vor einer Woche gewesen sein.
Vor einer Woche. Wie es Lisset heise in seinem News-Archiv auch Daten in der Zukunft.
Die wissen halt vorher was passiert.
Sag mal, bist du bekifft oder was?
Da kann ich nur nicht drauf klicken, aber sie zeigen es halt trotzdem an, die Penner.
Ich suche Lotto-Zahlen.
War jetzt überhaupt nicht weit hergeholt.
Genau, 23.8. 22.8. Genau, es war genau ein Tag danach. Also Ballmer tritt zurück oder wird zurückgetreten? Das ist schonmal so die Frage Nummer 1, die ich mir so stelle. Der ist gefeuert worden. Dem haben sie jetzt gesagt, sorry. Jetzt geht nichts mehr. Es geht jetzt einfach. Wir haben es jetzt länger, können wir es nicht rauszögern. Der Peak Ballmer ist ja nun wirklich schon lange her. Wenn es das überhaupt mal gab. Ich meine, was bitte ist das?
Wie du meinst, Ballmer war schon immer eine Flatrate?
Was ist denn bitte das Vermächtnis von Steve Ballmer?
Wahrscheinlich noch die Early-Windows-Zeit, wo er noch ein toller Salesman-Hecht war.
Also ich kann mir vorstellen, dass er so etwas wie NT eingetütet hat und diese ganze Windows-Schiene in ihr Unternehmen geboxt hat. Also kann ich mir vorstellen, dass er da relativ weit vorne war.
Seit er CEO ist, seitdem er Chef ist.
Wir würden doch nicht anfangen darüber zu sprechen, wenn wir irgendwas wüssten, was er als CEO geleistet hätte. Es war jetzt ja schon so unser... Was hat er denn eigentlich gemacht?
Das einzige, was er gemacht hat, ist, dass dieser Laden nach wie vor profitabel ist. Also auf dem Papier. Also so von den Quartalzahlen. Es ist ja nicht so, dass... Also Apple hat erst vor ein paar Jahren Microsoft überholt. Da war echt viel dazwischen.
Jaja, die waren mal richtig fucking rich.
Die machen immer noch Gewinn. Ich glaube, die hatten überhaupt bisher in ihrem ganzen... Seit es sie gibt, nur ein Quartal, wo es mal ein Minus war. Und das war jetzt gerade erst vor kurzem. Weil sie diese komische Abschrift hatten. Wie auch immer. Ballmer hat halt irgendwie nichts erfunden lassen. Also irgendwie hat das nicht geschafft, Microsoft daran zu hindern, innovativ zu sein.
Ich guck grad hier bei Wolfram Alfa nochmal Microsoft vs. Du bist aber auch gemein. Fast doppelt so viel Market Cap und doppelt so viel Revenue. Revenue per Employee ist ja auch eine schöne Metrik. Microsoft 786.000, Apple 2,3 Millionen. Microsoft hat 99.000, Apple hat 72.800.
Hast du das so eingegeben hier?
Ja, also ich hab Microsoft versus Apple, aber es sollte ja das gleiche liefern.
Ja, das benutze ich in letzter Zeit auch immer häufiger. Ich mag das sehr.
On screen.
Ja, Wolfram Alpha ist super. Er kann auch so Subnet oder so IP-Masken und so Kram. Ist geil. So, da oben war dieses Chart mit dem... Oben bei der Hoch-Hoch-Stop. Da, diese Tabelle.
Revenue per Employee, das ist natürlich schon krass überhaupt. Aber die haben fast genau gleich viele Employees, also ich meine...
Trotzdem macht sie dreimal so viel Kohle pro Nase.
Aber vielleicht zählt zum Beispiel halt bei Employee auch die ganzen Apple Store-Mitarbeiter und so, ne?
Die allermeisten Mitarbeiter sind Apple Store-Mitarbeiter. Ja, weil ich meine ansonsten haben sie halt nicht so viel. Da laufen schon ein paar Leute rum auf so einem Campus, aber es ist auch nicht so, dass sie da 50.000 Leute beschäftigen. Aber Microsoft ist halt so ein aufgeblasener Laden und das auch so intern so aufgeblasen mit diesen ganzen Divisions, die sich gegenseitig in die Parade fahren und dafür sorgen, dass überhaupt kein Produkt irgendwas wird.
Annual earnings per share, das hat Ballmer gefeuert. Apple 40 Dollar, Microsoft 2 Dollar 60.
Also, es ist nicht so, dass jetzt Microsoft den Eindruck macht, als würden sie demnächst von irgendjemand gekauft werden. Aber zumindest ist ihnen halt jetzt so lange nichts eingefallen und haben sie auf nichts reagiert, was von außen kam richtig. Einzige, wo sie sich so ein bisschen bewähren können, ist im Konsolenmarkt.
Ja, aber auch nicht. Das ist doch ein Zuschussgeschäft ohne Ende. Gestern mal wieder verkündet worden, dass irgendwie Windows 8 jetzt oder der scheiß Internet Explorer 25, welche Version aktuell ist, oder so jetzt gerade wieder mal alles überfahren hat, was es jemals gegeben hat von Apple. Ich such's nochmal. Also nee, von der, gab's ja gestern gerade wieder große Verkündigung, dass jetzt viel mehr Leute Windows 8 benutzen und erst recht den tollen Internet Explorer, der da drin ist.
Als was?
Als, als witzigerweise, als alles, was Apple jemals produziert hat. Alle Safaris, die es jemals gegeben hätte bei, wo ich immer...
Ja, aber das sind doch trotzdem Rückzugsgefechte.
Ich guck gleich nochmal, ob ich das gefunden hab.
Das würde man ja auch erwarten von irgendwie ein Laden, der angeblich 90 Prozent des Marktes hält.
Also wenn da 10 Prozent der Leute irgendwie den gleichen Browser benutzen, dann ist das halt ein Marktanteil.
Ja, dieser Desktop-Fetischismus. Auf Tablets sieht das bestimmt ganz anders aus. Naja, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall Ballmer hat dann eingesehen, dass es irgendwie alles ein Ende haben muss. Und kündigt an, dass er jetzt eigentlich keine Lust mehr hat. Könnte aber auch noch ein Jahr dauern, bis er dann geht, weil er geht halt dann, wenn ein Nachfolger gefunden ist. Und dann geht er irgendwie. Das heißt, so auf dem Papier ist er jetzt immer noch der Chef, oder ist halt auch noch der Chef, weil es gibt ja sonst keinen da. Und eine Woche später kommen sie dann mit dem Ding, dass sie nicht Nokia kaufen, sondern dass sie Nokias Smartphone-Geschäft kaufen.
Alle was dort telefoniert.
Ja, Mobile Phones, richtig. Also oder ich weiß gar nicht, wie das... Wie heißt das intern nochmal?
NMP hieß es früher mal.
Nokia Mobile Phones. Ja gut.
Also nicht die Gummistiefel und nicht die Netzwerkleute.
Genau, also sie bleiben nach wie vor natürlich in diesem Bereich Netzwerkinfrastruktur. Da sind sie glaube ich die Nummer 3 nach Ericsson und wie heißt das correct? In Deutsch-Chinesisch heißt das Huawei. Irgendwie, ja ich meine es hat doch keiner Huawei, oder?
Das kann man sich wenigstens merken.
Hui Bu ist halt so der größte Anbieter. China macht so irgendwie Mobile Phone Equipment.
Es gibt ja noch ZTE.
Und was ist der dritte Teil nochmal von Nokia?
Gummistiefel.
Nein, hier. Also hier die...
Das haben sie auch mitgekauft.
Die Kartendienste, die so eine Melange sind aus den Geschichten, die hier in Berlin gelaufen sind.
Stimmt, habe ich mit denen.
Gate 5 ist jetzt im Prinzip... Also, Gate 5 war hier mal so ein Start-up, das uns gut bekannt ist. Und das wurde irgendwann mal von Nokia gekauft.
Von Praktikanten.
Und dann wurden irgendwie... Da wurde halt diese Kartensoftware entwickelt. Nicht die Kartensoftware, sondern eine Kartensoftware.
Und die haben sich dann auch jemanden gekauft. Die haben sich dann auch irgendwie so einen fetten Karten-Provider gekauft.
Navtech haben sie sich gekauft.
Und das haben sie letztes Jahr, vorletztes Jahr, vor zwei Jahren war das vielleicht so geführt. So, und damit hatten sie auf einmal diese ganzen Daten. Und sie sind halt mit ihren Systemen, dadurch, dass es eben Navtech war. Das andere ist ja dann TomTom. Ja, TomTom ist nochmal.
Gibt noch Navigon?
Also Navigon ist das Produkt von Navtech.
Und das, was wollte ich jetzt sagen? Jetzt bin ich schon wieder aus der Spur. Wie auch immer.
Das hat er bei Microsoft mitgekauft.
Hier heißt das jetzt, glaube ich, als Organisationsteil. Hier. Heißt nicht auch diese Maps irgendwie hier, Nokia hier oder so?
Es gab da mal so eine Abwehr.
Die Nokia-Map, die heißt das so, oder?
Ich geh mal auf Maps, Nokia hier.
Hier Maps, die hier. Ich weiß, dass ich das immer runtergeladen hab und nicht schlecht gestaunt hab.
Wie schlecht das war.
Also die erste Version war echt unter aller Sau. Wie auch in Mobile Max bereits besprochen. Hier heißt die ja tatsächlich.
Ja, und jetzt soll also dieser Telefon-Teil gekauft werden von Microsoft. Und was übrig bleibt, ist halt so eine Mobilfunk-Netzwerk-Technologie- und Kartendienst-Firma.
Und abschneuchle Software.
Aber Nokia ist nicht mehr die Telefone. Und ich glaube, da geht ihnen ganz schön was bei ab.
Aber wenn ich das richtig gelesen habe, dann haben sie den hier Teil aber auch gekauft. Oder wollen den auch kaufen.
Vielleicht wollen sie das, aber tun sie es nicht.
Hä?
Die gehören nicht zu der Gummistiefeltruppe.
Ja, dann ist es halt anders aufgeteilt worden. Also auf jeden Fall haben sie diesen Kartenteil hier. Laut meinen Informationen, wie ich das bisher alles nachgelesen habe, kaufen sie nicht. Hier diese Software-Entwicklung. Sie erwerben aber eine mehrjährige Lizenz an diesem ganzen Climbim, weil sie ja über Bing, Maps und so weiter.
Die Lizenz erwerben sie an eine Markennamen Nokia.
Ja, auch. Ich rede jetzt nur von den Karten.
Ich finde jetzt einfach mal, dass die Gate 5-Mitarbeiter unter unseren Zuhörern kündigt, jetzt einfach mal leaken bitte hier über den Chat oder Direct Message oder wie auch immer.
Naja, ich kenne auch noch einige, die da arbeiten. Das sind alles nette Kollegen und gute Freunde. Mir ist noch nicht so ganz klar, was das jetzt hier in Berlin konkret ändern wird für die. Ob das sozusagen bedeutet, dass sie weiter hier sind, oder ob sie irgendwie Nokia sind und damit dann Microsoft sind oder so. Keine Ahnung. Müssen wir mal sehen. Das wissen wir nicht. Auf jeden Fall, Finnland verliert sein Staatsunternehmen. Also nicht Staatsunternehmen, wie nennt man das?
Ihren Stolz. Ihr VW.
Ihr VW, genau.
Na, ihr Opel.
Oder auch ihr Mercedes.
Was gibt es sonst noch an großen finnischen Companies? Ist Nokia nicht mit Abstand die größte Company?
Ja, aber sie halbieren sie ja nur. Sie kaufen ja nur einen Teil davon.
Ja, aber sie kaufen den Teil, mit dem die Leute die ganze Zeit rumrennen. Jeder hat so ein Nokia-Phone in der Hand. Nokia ist einfach durch die tägliche Kommunikation auch einfach eine ganz starke Marke über das Unternehmen hinaus. Also die Sorge darum, wie viele Arbeitsplätze da jetzt unter Umständen draufgehen, oder wer jetzt in die USA ziehen muss, oder wie viele Amerikaner jetzt noch zusätzlich nach Finnland kommen, was auch immer man so für Befürchtungen hat, das ist das eine. Das andere ist so dieses, oh ein Herz-Rupf, ich meine es war absehbar, aber jetzt findet es statt und ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass die Finner da irgendwie nicht so einen Spaß dran haben.
Was man so hört und liest, ja, findet ihr das nicht lustig?
Genau, und sie haben sich selber eingebrockt, jahrelang stand das irgendwie groß, in großen Lettern an der Wand fand ich.
Ja, wer zu spät kommt, den bestraft das Leben.
Genau.
Und es ist nicht so, dass sie nicht früher gewusst hätten, wie man eine ordentliche Hardware baut. Aber sich dann sozusagen mit einem derartigen Anlauf und so und auch auf die Art und Weise von Apple überrollen zu lassen und dann noch nicht mal wieder aufzustehen, sondern einfach zu sagen, ach, das braucht ja keiner.
Ja.
Aber die anderen europäischen Länder sind ja ihre Mobilfunk. Handy, Mobil, Teilhersteller, auch alle losgeworden.
Ja gut, aber in Deutschland, ich meine, dass Siemens jetzt keine Handys mehr baut, das interessiert hier eigentlich keinen. Also ich meine, das war jetzt nicht so der Knaller. Oh, es gibt keine Siemens-Handys mehr. Schade.
Naja, die waren ja auch scheiße from the beginning.
Ich meine, das war jetzt nichts, was man unbedingt haben wollte. Gut, die haben die halt so gebaut. Ich meine, Deutschland hat auch mal Computer gebaut. Der Hinzuse. Ja, nicht nur den Computer gebaut, es gab ja so richtig, als ich irgendwie jung war, gab es halt noch so deutsche Computerhersteller.
Ja, Nixdorf.
Ja, Siemens Nixdorf.
Nixdorf vor allem. Siemens ist durch Nixdorf eigentlich erst das geworden.
Gerade gestern noch ein Fahrzeug gesehen von Nixdorf. Irgendwie fahren die immer noch rum, stehen immer drauf, so wie für Handel und Banken und bla und z.B.
Die haben sich ja so stark auf Geldautomaten irgendwann mal spezialisiert.
Benutzen die bestimmt als Brand oder so. Aber Nokia ist halt, wie du schon sagst, der Stolz. Das ist sozusagen die wirtschaftliche Präsenz der Finnen weltweit. Deswegen kennt jeder Finnland.
Das ist einfach scheiße reich gemacht.
Und wir haben hier mal schon parallel die Liste der Companies of Finnland. Und ich hab da mal gerade durchgescrollt, es sind nicht so viele, die sie da erwähnenswert finden. Und da ist Nix dabei, außer Nokia, was man sonst noch kennt. Doch, die Papierfirma Mülü Koski.
Und die Firma Rovio Mobile, die kennt man auch.
F-Secure?
Meine Rovio Mobile ist jetzt, wie ich mal sagen soll, ist jetzt der Contender, das ist jetzt der nächste Stolz.
Was kenn ich denn noch? Telia Asunera.
Den kauft Microsoft als nächstes.
Telia Asunera sind immer noch ganz Menge unterwegs. Die waren nämlich schlau genug, mal zu gucken, was sonst noch. Das ist eine Telekommunikationsbude. Das ist sozusagen, wenn du so willst, Finnish Telekom, die sich mit den Schweden so ein bisschen zusammengehauen haben. Und international Zeugs anbieten, Backbone-Zeugs und so. Also die sind noch im Spiel ein bisschen, aber die kennt keine Sau außerhalb der Industrie. Ist das nicht so spannend?
Auf jeden Fall ist Nokia auch the largest company of them all.
Aber die habe ich wenigstens schon mal gehört, Telia Asunera. Die anderen Firmen, das habe ich alles noch nicht gehört.
Ist mir auch alles total unklar hier.
Rauta-Rufi?
Lemon-Canon Group? Also ich meine, sie haben lustige Namen, also das muss man ihnen lassen.
Ich weiß nicht, was sie noch mal gesehen haben. Bei Sauna?
Saunalachti? Sauna? Sauna wahrscheinlich, oder? Ich kann kein Finnisch, aber...
Jetzt haben wir auch noch die Firmen.
Yksi Kaksi, Setsumi Taxi, das ist das Einzige, was ich sagen kann.
Das ist bestimmt falsch.
Das ist eine Radiofrequenz von einem Radiosender. Genau, das ist dieses Jingle, was ihr dann so... Yksi Kaksi, Setsumi Taxi, Justin Bieber, blablabla.
Und Posti-Punky.
Das ist doch mein Titel.
Post-Punky, nicht die Panker von der Post.
Posti-Punky.
Posti-Punky?
Ich schlage das mal kurz nach.
Finnisch-Deutsches Lexikon?
Ja, translate.google.com Leo? translategoogle.de, steht ganz oben.
Nicht so was. Leo hat tatsächlich Finnisch-Deutsch. Posti-Punky oder Bunky?
Punky, glaube ich, P-A-K-K-K-I oder so. Nee, nicht so einfach. Die schreiben so etwas immer mit Doppel-K.
Damit es auch richtig sitzt.
Ich gucke nach. Posti-Punky.
Post-Punky?
Wenn du von Deutsch nach Finnisch übersetzt, dann muss man euch Post-Punky...
Es geht in beide Richtungen. P-O-S-T-I-P-A-N-K-K-I.
En wikipedia.org/wiki/posti-punky mit Doppel-K.
Postamt, mach doch mal Postamt.
Posti-Corted und Post...
Hier, Tim, es ist in der Wikipedia. Es ist in der Wikipedia. Posti-Punky war eine finnische Kommerzbank, die von 1887 bis 1997 operierte. Posti-Sesco-Doppel-K-Punky hat mit Zoomen, Vinti, Lutto und dann... War eine echte Bank. Kann man zusammenfassen. Hier, ich pack den Link in den Chat. Kannst du draufklicken.
Ja, ja, Posti-Punky. Ich seh's ja schon, aber... Was war denn mit Posti-Punky? Sagen das nur komisch oder war das was Besonderes?
Das war das, wenn man als Jugendlicher, wie man so seine Sturm- und Drangphase hat, wo man dann in Schweden oder Finnland unbedingt Zelten gehen muss oder so was. Und damals war das eine der Möglichkeiten, da Geld zu transferieren.
Und das heißt auch wirklich Post-Punk.
Das hieß es, du bist dann damals da hingegangen, hast dann da mit deinem Post-Spar-Buch oder was auch immer du in Deutschland hattest, konntest du denn dort Geld abheben?
Das klingt auch wie die finnische Version von Post-Punk.
Das klingt so wie die 80s.
Wir sind so ein bisschen Post-Punk.
Yksi Kaksi, Setsi mit Taxi.
Kannst du das irgendwie buchstabieren?
Yksi Kaksi ist 1, 2.
Also wenn es nur eine AW-Frequenz wäre, dann wundert mich das schon ein bisschen.
Wir haben ja noch alte Mobamex-T-Shirts, wenn wir sowas noch haben wollen, sagen wir uns mal im Chat raus.
Geh mal in deinen Translator, in deinen Dict-CC und schreib einfach 1 rein.
Du kannst das einfach da in dein Google-Translate reinsabbern.
Er will doch jetzt mal... 1 sollst du da reinschreiben.
Ehe euch schon klar, dass wir Hörer haben, theoretisch.
Warte mal, Yksi kann ich auch abspielen?
Yksi ist 2.
Es gibt doch dieses schöne... Er sagt, das ist eine Radifrequenz. Wenn die 1, 2 heißt, es gibt keine Urgave-Frequenzen in Europa, die mit 1, 2 gehen.
Es gibt so ein schönes Disco-Tanz-Video. Das gibt so ein Disco-Tanz-Video. Disco-Tanz in Perus dreht heißt das, wo so ein finnischer Tanzlehrer der 70er erklärt, wie man Disco tanzt. Und der zählt auch immer 1, 2, 3, 4.
Ich glaube, 3 ist Kojmen.
Kann man das runterladen hier, eigentlich diese scheiß Sounds? Warum nicht?
Das kannst du mir auch von Google vorlesen.
Das muss ich mir mal.
Du willst die NSA-Resourcen schonen, aber nimm nochmal das Google Translator. Kannst du auch mit Ungarisch probieren, das ist auch genauso lustig. Das frag mich jetzt nicht, aber die sind ja, wenn überhaupt irgendwas ähnlich ist mit Finnisch oder Ungarisch, dann sind das die beiden. Aber irgendwie.
Ich hätte gerne so einen Ungarisch zu Deutsch Translator oder Soundgenerator, also der Deutsch so spricht, wie es ein Ungar spricht. Also mit ungarischem Dialekt.
Verstehe.
List of Finnish Radio Stations, Wikipedia hat einfach alles.
Ist Yksi Kaksi dabei?
Leider stehen die Frequenzen nicht da.
Das kannst du mal anklicken.
Yksi Kaksi. Das heißt drei?
Hier, das Finland Disco Dance Instruction Video.
Da, du sollst da klicken.
Warum, was ist das? Da?
Wo der Roddy zeigt.
Da, wo der Roddy zeigt.
Finland Disco Dance Instruction Video.
Jüngere Jungs machen Disco, Juta und Beat-Dance, die vor allem ähnliche Schwierigkeiten produzieren.
Sie können nicht Englisch sprechen, aber Mann kann sie tanzen.
Disco Dance. Das ist im öffentlichen Raum eine relativ gute Verschlüsselung, wenn ich zu sprechen bin.
Du musst auf deinen Yx achten, aber auch auf deinen Kax.
Kann ich das abbrechen, oder müssen wir das zu Ende hören?
Geh mal aufs Ende, wenn sie richtig los tanzen.
Ach so, die tanzen auch noch richtig. Leute, nur damit ihr versteht, was wir hier gerade machen. Wir schauen zwei Tänzer an, nämlich ein Mann und eine Frau, dabei zu, wie sie langsam Schritte erklären, wie man Disco tanzt. Und das ganz auf Finish.
Und auch etwas älter.
Na, kann sich schon bewegen, der gute Mann.
So, in einem Studiodesign, wie hieß es früher hier in Deutschland, mit Sia Richter oder so, war es ein bisschen...
Das ist ziemlich 70er, ja.
Guck mal an hier, der ist ganz flott unterwegs.
Vielleicht auch 80er. Der ist 80er.
Guck dir den Schwung mal vor, mach mal Skip, Skip, Skip da.
Jetzt geht's los.
Wenn das mal 80er ist, du bist gut.
Und jetzt in Moskau.
Und jetzt legt der voll los, der Alte.
In Finnland sehen die einfach alle alt aus. Die sehen noch keine Sonne.
Man ist schon sehr gewagt, auch Disco nach vorgegebenen Schritten. Das ist Moskau von Gingis Khan. Hab ich doch gesagt, Moskau.
Das Moskau von Gingis Khan war Mitte 70er.
Das Video ist ja schon 2008 gepublished, aber es sieht deutlich so aus, als wäre es wesentlich älter.
Mach das mal ein bisschen leiser hier.
Heute geben wir jedem Detail in der Wikipedia auf den Grund. Hier bleibt kein Fakt unerforscht. Wir finden sogar raus, es waren Moskau, Moskau.
Weil ich gerade darüber gelästert habe, Disco nach Schritt zu machen. Da sind die Deutschen und die Schweizer auch nicht ganz unschuldig damit. Es gibt nämlich auch einen Tanz, der ist Disco Fox. Das willst du auch nicht sehen und das haben leider Deutsche und Schweizer zusammen.
Ja und das ist total schlimm, weil das ist nämlich ein Dreier-Schritt-Rhythmus, den du auf einem Vierviertel-Takt tanzt. Mich hat das wahnsinnig gemacht.
Ihr seid beide Tänzer, ja?
Ich bin kein Tänzer, ich habe aber mal, weil eine Ex-Freundin von mir das unbedingt wollte, mal einen Disco-Fox-Tanzkurs gemacht.
Das ist auch bitter für einen Anfänger.
Und wie gesagt, das hat mich wahnsinnig gemacht. Was muss man denn da machen? Naja, ein, zwei, Tapp, ein, zwei, Tapp, ein, zwei, Tapp, ein, zwei, Tapp. Und das gemeine ist, wenn du das auf einem Vierviertel-Takt tanzt, dann verschiebt sich der Tapp natürlich immer durch den Takt.
Aber warum sollte man das tun?
Warum sollte man überhaupt tanzen?
Weil in der Disco selten Dreiviertel-Takt-Stücke gespielt werden.
Das meiste, was wir haben, ist Vierviertel-Takt.
Was ich nicht verstehe, ist, ich bin wirklich ein totaler Tanz-Bananase. Warum will man das tanzen? Also warum will man Disco Fox vielleicht, also will man das?
Die Begründung ist, dass das was ist, wo man mal einander anfassen kann. Das ist, ähm...
Ja, gut, Disco Fox geht noch mal weniger, aber...
Nee, pass auf, Disco Fox ist ein Part-Tanz. Und der, nochmal, leider ist eine Retortenkreation. Das haben, wie gesagt, Deutsche und Schweizer Tanzschulen haben sich mal an den 17er oder 16er gedacht, oh fuck, jetzt kommt hier so moderne Musik. Und Walzer hat das nicht mehr geteilt, jetzt müssen wir uns mal was ausdenken. Und haben den sozusagen am grünen Tisch designt. Das ist leider Disco Fox ein bisschen ärgerlich, deswegen sieht er auch ein bisschen albern aus. Der ist geklont, der ist Klontanz.
Nee, der ist in der Retour so, der ist nicht geklont, sondern der ist sozusagen ein Ositanz.
Der ist künstlich hergestellt. Wohingegen viele andere Tänzer, viele andere Paartänzer, die da draußen sind, haben sich ja zunächst erstmal natürlich entwickelt, bevor sie in die Fänge des ADTV und Konsorten gelangten, des Allgemeinen Deutschen Tanzschulverbandes. Bevor sie dann sozusagen normiert wurden. Aber der Disco Fox ist eine echte Retorten-Kreation. Also mag es mal lustig sein.
Du bewegst dich in diesen Szenen außerhalb dieser Normierung?
Ich gebe zu, dass ich mich mal auch in den Szenen innerhalb dieser Normierung bewegt habe, aber nicht im ADTV. Aber so, ich hab auch mal Standard-Latein getanzt, auch mit sehr viel Freude, aber nicht nie im ADTV, weil ich diese Grinsen auch nie abkann und auch die Regeln nicht. Ach, das sind diese Leute, die immer so grinsen, oder auch die Männer, also furchtbare Fressen. Nein, nein, die spreen nicht fest. Die spreen nicht fest, das ist kein Witz. Also nicht mit Grinsen, aber nein. Die spreen sich echt irgendwelche Zeugs ins Gesicht, damit das Make-up nicht verläuft. Weil das ist nämlich ziemlich anstrengend. Tanzen kann nämlich durchaus, ist auch von manchen Leuten als Sport betrieben, und damit das Make-up nicht verläuft, dann haben die auch so sozusagen Haarfästiger für die Fresse. Das ist ganz fürchterlich, das ist wirklich ganz, ganz widerlich. Das, was du als Zivilist siehst, das ist ja das, was sozusagen mal im Fernsehen übertragen wird, da machen sie noch was viel schlimmer, da machen sie mich noch Scheinwerfer an. Das heißt dann Tanzen, die da angepummelt, oder eben nicht so angepummelt, da kannst du ja ein bisschen Latein angucken, da ist ja eigentlich nicht so viel mehr mit Stoff und so. Und das ist wirklich scheiße anstrengend auch. Und damit dann nicht das Make-up verschwimmt oder sowas, haben die das so drauf, ja.
Deswegen laufen sie mit diesen Anonymous-Masken rum. Ich meine, die sehen doch alle aus wie Gestanzen.
Wir kriegen jetzt eh Held-Mail, bis der Arzt kommt, weil das ist eine ganz empfindliche Szene, über so Händler-Tänzer und Turniertänzer zu renten, das ist ein heißer Pflaster.
Wer nichts abkann, soll auch keinen Sport machen. Sport ist tough.
Ich bewege mich außerhalb davon. Ich mache so Sachen, die so für Spaß sind, und nicht so für Turnier. So Jazz-Dances, Lindy Hop zum Beispiel. Hast du das auch schon mal in Finnland betrieben? Ja. Hat man auch dann mit Yksi Kaksi abbezählt? Was in Finnland sehr, sehr beliebt ist, ist Tango. Du wirst es nicht glauben. Es gibt ja diesen Tango, nicht bloß diese deutsche Rampampam, so diese wiege Schritt.
Rückseitplatz, sag ich nur.
Es gibt ja noch andere Varianten von Tango, unter anderem auch den finnischen Tango. Das kannst du mal googeln, das sieht mich mal relativ witzig aus.
Finnischer Tango, das war dann gleich bei der finnischen Polka.
Die gibt es auch noch. Ja, ich weiß, da kann man Spaß haben.
Was soll ich jetzt tun?
Ach finnischer Tango, dann suchst du mal, ob du dafür ein Fideo findest.
Aber ist jetzt nicht gerade das total hippe Salzer zu tanzen?
Es gibt jede Menge Dinge, also paar Tänze, die getanzt werden. Salzer gibt es auch noch.
Der Tango gehört mittlerweile zu Finnland wie die Sauna? Witzen die dann dabei auch so genauso?
Aber sie bewegen sich mehr, ne?
Nein, nein, nein, nicht so, mach mal, ich suche gleich mal was.
20 Jahre später.
Also um auf deine Frage zurückzukommen, es gibt mehrere Szenen, die sich da engagieren.
Meinst du das hier, oder ist das so ein Bericht oder was?
Das ist so ein Deutsche Welle. Mach keine random YouTube-Videos an.
Es gibt diese Standard-Lateintanz-Szene, die gibt es einmal offroad, neben dem, was der ADTV zulässt und vorschreibt, also für einen Spaß. Gerade in Berlin gibt es so ein paar Tanzschulen in Kreuzberg, die ganz verschämt in den 80ern waren, der war total verpönt, Tanzen mit anfassen. Die sich konspirativ getroffen und sich gegenseitig Unterricht verteilt. Sehr lustig. Also hier in Kreuzberg, bei dir um die Ecke, Roddy, da in der Nachbarschaft, in der Oberstraße z.B., ist taktlos eine von diesen Off-ADTV-Tanzbuden hier in Berlin. Dann gibt es noch ein paar davon. Dann gibt es, wie gesagt, die Salsa-Szene.
Was ist denn jetzt an diesem finnischen Tango anders als an dem anderen Tango?
Guckst dir mal an. Ich könnte dir jetzt mal ein Vergleichding dazu zeigen. Du musst auch mal die Musik mal hören dazu, die dir jetzt natürlich auskommt. Ne, ne, eben nicht.
Die durfte ich ja nicht anmachen. Ich mach sie mal ganz leise mal an.
Achtung!
Klingt aber auch nicht gerade besonders finnisch.
Das ist jetzt nicht besonders typisch für finnischen Tango. Ja, lass mal das raus. Die Salsa-Leute, dann gibt es wie gesagt die ganze Swing-Szene. Nicht Swinger, sondern Swing-Szene. Da spielt sich ein bisschen was ab. Das sind also die ganzen alten Jazz-Dances aus den 20er Jahren, die so angefangen haben, also Inclusive Charleston, Lindy Hop, Balboa, Boogie, und so weiter. Und da war es Rock'n'Roll und so den ganzen Spaß. Und dann gibt es die Lindy Hop.
Lindy Hop ist die finnische Antwort.
Nein, das ist nicht die finnische Antwort.
Wessen Antwort ist denn das?
Lindy Hop ist, wenn du guckst, stammt aus den 20er Jahren, als Lindy Lindberg seinen Hop über den Atlantik gemacht hat. Da kommt er hier.
Man hüpft mal eben über den Atlantik.
Und wie gesagt, dann gibt es die Tango-Agentino-Szene, die sich auch nochmal so ein bisschen aufteilt hier. Aber die sind sehr aktiv. Wer auch mal Spaß hat, sowas zu gucken, sieht nämlich auch ganz nett aus, wenn die Hobbyisten das machen und nicht diese Grinseviecher da. Kennt ihr diese Brücke da zum Museum rüber? Da ist ja unten noch so eine Holzfläche. Da ist eigentlich jede Woche irgendwas los, wenn es nicht regnet. Mittwochs hast du da die Tango-Tänzer, freitags hast du die Swing-Tänzer, die Lindy Hopper hast du da unten. Das ist eine sehr lustige Szene.
Wir hatten ja keine Ahnung, dass du so tief mit dem Tanz verbunden bist.
Ich schon, aber da fragten wir es noch nie.
Ja, aber er hat es ignoriert.
Er hat dich schon so oft zum Tanz aufgefordert.
Hätte ich schon. Also zum Beispiel bei den Lindy Hoppern ist es so, dass die traditionellen Geschlechterrollen eigentlich da nicht gelten. Ich hab mich da auf jeden Fall immer... Es gibt zwar immer noch einen, der führt, einen der folgt, aber das ist nicht notwendigerweise der Führer, das ist nicht das Männchen und folgendes nicht das Weibchen, sondern geht so und so. Und manche Leute, ich auch, ich tanze beide Rollen. Also ich tanze eigentlich, wenn da die Stimmung da ist, die Musik da ist, dann, was nicht bei drei auf dem Baum ist.
Wird einfach weggetanzt.
Wird einfach weggetanzt. Na, da steckt noch ein bisschen mehr dahinter. Ich muss dir mal einen Link zuschicken zu dem, was ich jetzt mal meine. Das hat überhaupt nichts mit diesem Standardleiter in Tadala zu tun. Nichts, dass sie trotzdem sind, um jetzt darauf zurückzukommen, sind Parttänze. Das heißt, das sind Sachen, wo man jemand zu zweit tanzt, wo man sich anfasst. Weil der beim normalen Disco-Hoppel nicht so ist.
Das ist immer wieder beim Disco-Fox. Jetzt können wir langsam die Klammer zu.
Genau, deswegen. Du hast ja gefragt, warum will man das tun? Als die Amis in den 20er Jahren angefangen haben, kommt der so aus New York, Lindy Hop aus der Gegend. Damals war der auch dort, die waren ja noch Brüder als heute. Und somit sich gegenseitig anfassen, war ja fast wie heute im Iran. Das ging gar nicht. Aber beim Tanzen ging das. Da musste man sich ordentlich benehmen, aber man konnte sich immerhin ein anderes Geschlecht anfassen. Das wurde natürlich auch noch lustiger. Wenn du dir jetzt mal Charlzensachen anguckst, oder vor allen Dingen einen Tanz, der nennt sich Balboa, der auch hier getanzt wird.
Verstehe, jetzt weiß ich, warum die tanzen. Ehrlich gesagt, das ist einer dieser Themen, über die ich in meinem Leben noch nie ernsthaft nachgedacht habe, weil ich immer nur so gesprühte Masken gesehen habe. Und anderen Quatsch.
Bei Balboa kannst du mal gucken, ob du dafür ein Video findest. Das ist ein ganz, ganz enger Tanz. Das kam noch dazu, dass Anfang letzten Jahrhunderts dort eine riesengroße Einwanderungswelle war in den USA. Das heißt, wenn die vorher noch schön viel Platz hatten auf ihren Tanzböden, und davon gab es reichlich, war das jetzt Balboa. Wie Rocky Balboa bis Unrocky. Nicht Tango. Balboa ist sozusagen eine Variante vom Charleston. Natürlich, wusstest du das nicht. Nimm mal das erste Ding da oben, Rolf, wer ist denn das? Rob Dickerson? Mach doch den mal, ist okay. Aber guck dir einfach nur mal an.
Mit Ton?
Man merkt, wie spannend das Thema Microsoft und Nokia ist. Oh ja, die bewegen sich nicht sehr weit.
Ja, du kannst auf noch viel kleineren Platz tanzen.
Das ist das Konzept tanzen.
Da geht aber noch was. Das ist jetzt mal so eine Demo, die sie da vielleicht mal machen für ein paar Leute, die sie das erste Mal zeigen. Ja, die tanzen da doch.
Also es reicht eigentlich ein Bistro-Tisch, ne?
Ja, oder weniger. Und wie gesagt, jetzt stellt euch das mal in den 20er-Jahren, im letzten Jahrhundert vor. Da, wie gesagt, so eng... In Amerika. So eng mal an jemand anderes ranzukommen. Und eben auch die ganzen anderen Dinge, die hier dranhängen. Blues gehört auch mit dazu, Blues-Tanz. Und man jetzt nicht diese hin und her wackeln auf zwei Füßen, was der in der Schule gemacht hat. So wie Stevie Wonder, so... Sondern...
Also im Prinzip ist das eigentlich so eine Art Annäherungsprotokoll. So, dass wenn man das irgendwie strikt durchfährt, dann gibt es auch keinen Abbruch. Und dann kann man das auch relativ lange betreiben. Und man ist dann halt einfach mal dran, am significant other. Okay, verstehe. Anfassen, Sex, irgendwie klarkommen, entspannt werden und so. Das war überhaupt gar nicht so schlecht die Idee. Warum ist das Marketing so schlecht?
Das ist doch kein Mensch, das so wahr ist.
Weil es ein veraltetes Protokoll ist.
Die Leute, die das erkannt haben, damit einigermaßen klarkommen oder so, lassen das doch nicht wieder sein. Aber das ist eine durchaus sehr entspannte Sache. Vor allen Dingen, ich hab mich ja schon in vielen Szenen bewegt, mit Computer und Trollern und Peep-Up. Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, in der Tanz-Szene, in den über zehn Jahren, die ich jetzt mache, hab ich noch nicht wirklich echte Arschlöcher getroffen. Vielleicht hat das auch was damit zu tun, wie man auch so Musikern nachsagt, dass schlechte Menschen keine Musik machen. Zumindest keine gute. Ja, und dann war da auch Xavier Naidoo und so. Nee, aber da geht was. Wie gesagt, auch da geht sehr viel außerhalb dieser ganzen Grinsenummer. Du musst halt unterscheiden, es gibt Sparstänzer, die machen das für Spaß. Und Leute, die das als Sport betreiben, Leute, die das als Sport betreiben, die wollen es dann auch wirklich wissen, da ist echt Competition und Hass gegenseitig und Arbeiten und Neid und Tralala und Pipapo. Und die Sparstänzer, dadurch, dass sie keine Competition haben, die machen das nicht, denen ist das eher fremd. Wobei es sicherlich auch da mal Leute gibt, die das nicht mehr wissen.
So, aber wir sind der Freak Show.
Wir haben jetzt auch mal das erste Thema schon mal durch. Ich bringe euch jetzt jede Woche mal einen neuen Tanz mit.
Ich finde, wir haben nicht nur das erste, haben wir eigentlich Microsoft schon mal gebraucht?
Micro-Wer?
Ja, im Prinzip haben wir es besprochen. Aber ich meine, was gibt es da zu besprechen?
Keine Ahnung. Man kann jetzt mal versuchen, wieder rumzuglaskugeln.
Dass der Elop jetzt neuer Ballmer wird, wird halt rumgerüchtet. Aber da gibt es ja nichts Greifbares zu.
Es gibt auch eine schöne Verschwörungstheorie übrigens zu dem Thema. Da hat nämlich gestern einer gemeint, dass der Elop jetzt auch nur so ein Agent war, um sozusagen den letzten unabhängigen Phone-Konzern in die Hände der NSA zu transportieren in the long run. Kauft Microsoft und dann zack, jetzt bauen wir da die Backdoors auch.
Und was ist mit Ping Pong?
Der westlichen Welt dann. Auf Hui Bu-Telefonen läuft Android wahrscheinlich, oder? Die Nokia-Telefone hatten ja zum Teil auch noch eigene Software. Die halt nicht.
Die kommt jetzt schon aus den USA, von daher brauchen sie Nokia eigentlich auch gar nicht jetzt die Hinsets, die Software.
Die haben ja auch noch die ganzen Telefone, die non-Smartphones, die Stupidphones. Und da haben sie jetzt so das ganze Ecosystem auch mal. Ich meine, das ist jetzt so eine Verschwörungstheorie, aber passt ja gerade so ganz gut ins aktuelle Bild.
Ja, ich frage mich nur, ob Microsoft, ich meine, die können sich natürlich derzeit immer noch kaufen, was sie wollen. Vor allem, der Deal kostet sie ja fast überhaupt nichts. Habt ihr das überhaupt irgendwie realisiert?
Fünf Mille oder so.
Ja, das Ding ist, da das halt eine europäische Company ist, können sie den Kram komplett aus ihren europäischen Reserven nehmen, die sie dann nicht mehr in die USA transferieren müssen, auf die sie dann Steuern zahlen müssen. Das heißt, es ist quasi extrem steuergünstig, diese Investitionen zu bezahlen.
Da liegt zumindest noch was an, sie haben ja nur 1,4 Milliarden als Cash rausgetan. Der Rest ist ja mal wieder in irgendwelchen Shares, Options, Blah, Blah, Blah bezahlt, was ich gelesen habe. Das ist jetzt nicht alles Cash, die haben nicht mit dem Koffer dahingeflohen, Koffer auf, 5 Milliarden raus oder so.
Ja, es gibt Geld und es gibt aber auch noch mal Kredit und so weiter. Sie finanzieren da auch noch. Auf jeden Fall merkt man das Microsoft. Ich frage mich, warum das jetzt so lange gedauert hat. Ich meine, wann ist der Elop dahingekommen? Das war vor zwei Jahren. Seit zwei Jahren ist er da. Und alle warten so, naja, passiert da jetzt irgendwie was? Vielleicht haben sie zwei Jahre gebraucht, um so leicht zu kochen. Vielleicht wollten sie sich einfach nicht kochen lassen.
Aber du musst es mal anders sehen. Die zahlen jetzt fünf Milliarden für Nokia. Und Google hat aber zwölf Milliarden für Motorola gekauft. Also da weiß ich, was das bessere Geschäft ist.
Und Microsoft hat auch für, haben die nicht verdoppelt so viel, für zwei Nokia Skype gekauft?
Die haben irre viel Kohle ausgegeben für Skype. War das nicht 15?
Ich glaube, es war auf jeden Fall deutlich mehr als für Nokia.
Skype war sehr interessant. Es gab gerade dieser Tage, ich weiß nicht, war es auf Ars Technica oder so was, gab es einen Artikel, der diese Skype-Historie beschrieben hat. Inklusive auch der Übernahme von, durch, durch... eBay. Und dann durch...
eBay dachte ja mal, dass sich die Verkäufer und die Käufer miteinander unterhalten würden und mussten dann aber einsehen, dass die Verkäufer einen Teufel tun, irgendwie in Kontakt mit ihren Käufern treten zu wollen.
Ja und dann eben auch Übernahme durch Microsoft und so.
Also Skype hat sie 8,5 Milliarden US-Dollar.
Also auch 5 Millionen Euro.
Wobei sie interessanterweise waren die ja in Luxemburg und unter Umständen war das aus den gleichen Gründen so günstig. Man weiß es nicht, aber Kohle haben sie auf jeden Fall.
Skype ist auch sehr wichtig. Es sind ja auch Skandinaviere und so. Schwede, Däne und eine Handvoll Esthen. Und die Esthen sind so was wie Finn auf der anderen Seite des Meerbusens. Also sprechen auch genauso komisch und sind sich auch sehr nahe. Wie gesagt, nur zum Thema Nokia. Also offensichtlich hat Microsoft eine Affinität für Skandinavia.
Ja, oder sagen wir mal so, die Skandinavier machen sich irgendwie gut in Kommunikation. Man ist ja nicht so, dass Schweden da auch nicht mitspielen würde. Nur Norwegen hat irgendwie nix oder?
Ich hatte ja mal auch so ein paar Connections mit Nokia, auch mit NMP in der Zeit, als sie den ersten Communicator rausgebracht haben. Weißt du, diese Dinge zum Aufklappen, wo man so ein E-Mail drauf anstampft. Und ich hab die mal gefragt, ihr ist ja eigentlich ganz cool, was ihr hier macht, wie kommt denn das? Und er so ja, pfff, wir haben hier, im Sommer haben wir so ein paar Wochen hier ein bisschen Licht und hell und so, dann macht man richtig Party und fahre dann irgendwie weg und den Rest des Jahres ist Uster, was willst du da machen als sitzen und hacken? Bisschen 20 Minuten weg. Das ist auch sehr lustig, man konnte nämlich damals von Helsinki nach Tampere fliegen. Das war ein Viertelstundenflug, das war echt der Knaller. Dann sind die abgehoben in Helsinki und dann rannte eine Stuhadüse nur durch den Gang, schmiss irgendwie so einen Tetrapack Orangensaft in jeden Sitz, rechts und links rein und dann schnallte sie sich wieder an und sagte, so wer landet jetzt? Das fand ich sehr cool, 15 Minuten mit Flieger.
Der Chat merkt gerade an, dass, wenn auch nicht so was wie Nokia und Ericsson aus Norwegen immerhin Opera kommen und Trolltech, also die, die Kuté gemacht haben, die später Nokia gekauft hatten, haben es wieder verkauft.
Und Kings of Convenience kommen auch aus Norwegen.
War nicht dieser Browser auch von denen?
Opera, der Browser.
Er ist nicht Trolltech, aber schon klar. Es ist ein kleines Land, da spielt sich wohl alles im Wesentlichen.
Da machen halt Stromsky auch.
Und Finnland hat wohl die höchste Anzahl von Metal-Bands pro Einwohner weltweit.
Und seit Jahren die höchste Sechst quadrat. Damit sind sie auch Spitze.
Aber das ist halt auch eine Art in den Winter rumzukriegen.
Da gibt es doch auch dieses eine epische Video von so einer finnischen Metal-Band, was so das einmal zusammenfasst finnische Metal-Bands und dass die da ganz schön viel Langeweile haben, die Jugendlichen, und dann halt Spaß haben, ich suche mal gerade nach.
Achso, auch finnisches Exportprodukt Leningrad Cowboys, wo wir gerade bei Bands sind.
Ja, Leningrad Cowboys und natürlich Elecke Laset, ne?
Das gab auch noch so ein Ding von denen.
Das ist ja in Nordkreisen auch sehr beliebt, der Humpa.
Elecke Laset, die haben so einen geilen Schlagzeuger, der sitzt mit seiner riesen Wampe hinter dem Schlagzeug und hat so die Hände so gefühlt, so brustweit vor sich und macht alles aus dem Handgelenk. Der bewegt die Arme gar nicht und wirbelt darum, dass er sich mit dem Schlagzeug aus dem Handgelenk auf den Schlagzeug und auf den Schlagzeug rastet. Das ist unglaublich. Der eine Keyboarder zerstört immer halb sein Keyboard. Da weiß man aber, was zu Keyboards aushalten. Bei denen kann man das dann sehen. Da spielt er dann im Stehen und zwar eher auf dem Keyboard.
Was ist überhaupt der größte Hit von LAZ.?
Ich glaube, das gibt es nicht. Die ersten covern sie sowieso nur.
Was ist denn am besten?
Und zweitens klingt es sowieso alles gleich.
Also auf jeden Fall, Finnland ist absolut faszinierend. Ich war einmal in Helsinki. Und das war auch ziemlich unvergesslich. Vor allem, was die da auch saufen, ist schon gut. Ich will das jetzt nicht primär unter diesen Punkt stellen. Aber die sind irgendwie, wie soll ich das jetzt ausdrücken?
Die sind pankig drauf, die Kollegen.
Es ist einfach ein krasses Land. Faszinierende Leute. Also Finn, die ich so kennenlerne, ist eigentlich immer irgendwie was Besonderes dran.
Die sind strange drauf, wenn sie keine Alkoholprobleme haben.
Ich hab jetzt mal die prototypische Demonstration einer von Jugendlichen in Finnland, die eine Metalband gründen. Du kannst ja mal die ersten paar Minuten laufen lassen. Es geht auch relativ schnell.
Warte mal, ich muss das mal humpa ausschalten.
Es humpert hier schon wieder.
Es humpert, humpert, humpert.
So, ist das laut? Ich weiß nicht, mal leise. Es fängt auch mit so einem kleinen Intro an. Da kommt erst mal ein bisschen kurz Text.
Mit einer Minorenexplosion an.
Das sind jetzt die krassen Finn.
Das sind halt finnische Jugendliche, die halt in den Wald fallen mit ihrem Auto, mit einer Kamera und irgendwie Spaß haben. Und so richtig mal abgehen. Da gibt es echt ganz epische Szenen in diesen Videos, wo sie irgendwie im Winter im Wald... Ja, hier genau.
Jetzt geht es los auch mal?
Es läuft schon irgendwie die ganze Zeit im Hintergrund. Ja, irgendwie, ich hör da ganz leise was.
Soll ich ein bisschen lauter machen?
Und dann weiß ich nicht, ob die das ernst meinen oder ob die jetzt mit ihrer eigenen Metal-Kultur nochmal so ein bisschen Spaß haben. Also ein Schlagzeug, dieses Mikro-Schlagzeug.
Die sind dann auch im Winter im Wald und machen halt so ganz große Spaß. Das könnte jetzt sein, dass es das Sommer-Video ist und dann haben sie irgendwie noch, ah, das rechts oben, da ist das Winter-Video, genau, das ist auch sehr gut. Dieses Winter-Video ist noch viel besser, weil da sind sie dann so richtig so ganz ernst und mysteriös im Wald und gucken hinter Bäumen vor und so ist das wirklich. Das packe ich auch gleich noch hier in den Chat.
Gut, waren wir jetzt schon durch mit Nokia.
Alles andere in Finnland ist interessant, nein. Von finnischen Tango bis finnischen Metal-Bands.
Also wer wird denn jetzt chefen? Also Elop wird ja mitgekauft und im Prinzip kaufen sie halt eigentlich alle Leute, die irgendwie mit Handybau was zu tun haben. Jetzt geht der Laden, naja, der wird ja da bleiben. Also Microsoft wird da quasi jetzt so eine Dependanz haben. Irgendwie dürfen sie noch Produkte rausbringen über einen Zeitraum von zwei Jahren. Sie auch Nokia.
Hab ich gelesen, zehn Jahre.
Zehn Jahre.
Zehn Jahre lang dürfen sie?
Ja, dass die sich den Marken haben. So hab ich das gelesen, ich kann jetzt keine Quelle zitieren.
Und danach haben sie ein Vorkaufsrecht auch noch für den Spaß, wenn sie das noch weiter haben wollen.
Das heißt eigentlich, also es wird, so wie ich Microsoft kenne, nennen sie das dann halt auch einfach weiter Nokia?
Metronokia.
Oder sie nennt es...
N-Box.
N-Box. Wir haben wieder dasselbe Phänomen wie Lumia, AHA, E+, und O2 schließen sich zusammen. Dass die Leute mal glauben, Minus und Minus macht Plus. Genauso wie bei Microsoft. In so einer Verpackung mit 500 Lausmens draußen drauf und so.
Also wenn der nächste Chef nicht wirklich ein Sanierer ist, der jobsche Qualitäten hat, dann ist der Schiff, der Kahn, so gut wie untergegangen, oder?
Ich weiß auch nicht, ich meine, die bremsen sich so sehr selbst aus, wenn die sich nicht in klarer, voneinander getrennte Teile, die nicht mehr so in so einer zerstörerischen Competition stehen, aufteilen würden, dann wird sie wahrscheinlich besser gehen.
Am Ende wäre diese Kartell-Amts-Zerschlagungs-Dingspunkt vielleicht sogar ein Segen gewesen für sie.
Aber was sie ja eigentlich vorhaben, das hat ja auch Ballmer bekannt gegeben als Zukunft. Die haben gesagt, wir organisieren jetzt irgendwie um nach Capabilities sozusagen. Wir machen nicht mehr diese Product-Divisions, sondern wir sind irgendwie alle das Produkt. Mit anderen Worten, da uns bisher nichts Besseres eingefallen ist, als Apple zu kopieren, kopieren wir jetzt Apple komplett. Jetzt nehmen wir auch noch die Management-Struktur und gucken, wie man damit klarkommt. Das wird doch nicht funktionieren.
Ich finde, das klingt mehr so nach Google-Kopieren.
Google?
Wie Motorola kaufen und so.
Ja, was Nokia betrifft. Aber bevor diese Nokia-Message draußen war, war das ja die Ansage. Also keine Ahnung, ich habe diesen Laden noch nie verstanden und ich will den auch irgendwie gar nicht verstehen. Doch, ich will ihn schon verstehen, aber es ist schwierig.
Also alles, was man so hört, von drin, klingt so, als würde man da eigentlich nicht arbeiten wollen und eigentlich ist es ein Wunder, dass es überhaupt so weit gebracht haben.
Genau, hier Eckert stellt gerade ein paar Sachen klar. Also die zehn Jahre beziehen sich auf die Patente. Ich glaube der Nokia-Brand, das war nur so knapp zwei Jahre. Und dann fällt es da raus. Das heißt, die wollen schon am Ende als Nokia noch das alte finnische Unternehmen bleiben mit ihren anderen Marktsegmenten und zum Wert des Telefon-Sektion-Verkaufs gehört auch noch eine Übergangsphase mit Nokia zu machen. Das heißt, das schreiben sie irgendwie mit dazu und am Ende heißt das dann irgendwie Lumia oder keine Ahnung.
Oder diese Hype-Smartphones, diese Serie 40, Serie 60 Dinger oder so. Nein, nein, diesen ganzen alten Quack gibt es ja auch immer.
Die alten Sachen ja, aber ob sie die nicht ganz schnell sterben lassen.
Und mit den zwei Jahren, ich glaube, die haben auch ein Vorkaufsrecht, um sich das hinterher zu sichern.
Was zu sichern?
Wenn sie da weiterspielen wollen.
Mit dem Brand? Also ich weiß nicht, irgendwie.
Egal.
Nokia powered by Microsoft.
Also erkennt man, Lumia wird der Name und Nokia wird gedroppt. Ich kann mir das auch ganz gut vorstellen, weil sie ewig so heiße Produkte haben wollen, die so heiß wie diese andere Firma, die was ganz anderes macht. Das kann auch im Interesse von dem Ding nicht sein. Ob Elop jetzt der Chef wird, das ist halt die Frage. Sieht halt so aus.
Stimmt, Scott Forstl wäre noch frei.
Ja, der hat da bestimmt in seinem Vertrag irgendwie tausend Dokumente unterschrieben. Du darfst die nächsten 20 Jahre irgendwie...
Dann wird er dann noch gut ausgebildet. Ja, hier wird auch...
Ja, Chet meint, wenn wir Microsoft schon runterreden, sollen wir uns die Gewinne anschauen. Es ist vollkommen unbenommen, dass dieser Laden finanziell erfolgreich war. Aber es ist auch völlig klar, dass die einfach in allen Zukunftsmärkten nicht mehr richtig vertreten sind. Und wenn ihre alten Kernsachen auslaufen, und die laufen nicht morgen aus, und auch nicht übermorgen, aber nächstes Jahr ist es schon schlechter und es wird dann auch nicht mehr besser, sie müssen sich schon was einfallen lassen. Office for the Cloud. Microsoft bleibt unspannend, und jetzt gibt es in Europa keine Handy-Hersteller mehr.
In Afrika gibt es auch keine, was soll das?
Was haben wir noch auf unserer tollen Liste? Ich muss aufpassen, dass ich nicht wieder die Humpa-Musik starte. Nächste Woche ist Keynote. Wollen wir uns dazu äußern?
Wir haben es ja schon mal versucht, aber das war ja nicht so sonderlich ergiebig.
Es hat sich auch keinerlei neuerlei Dinge ergeben.
Es verfestigt sich halt was. Das 5C in verschiedenen Farben und mit so einem durchsichtigen Gehäuse, was danach aussieht, dass sich die Läden viel davon hinstellen sollen.
Durchsichtig, echt?
So wie der iPod, wie ist das Ding? Nano seiner Zeit. Und ansonsten ein goldenes iPhone.
Na toll.
Oder Champagne, wie sie es nennen.
Champos!
So viel Geschmacklosigkeit hätte Apple jetzt nicht zugetraut.
Warten wir mal ab, was der Geier, was wir da gesehen haben. Sah aber ziemlich echt aus. Vielleicht sieht es gar nicht so scheiße aus.
Die sollen es mal so richtig teuer machen. Die sollen es mal so richtig teuer machen, damit man die Leute, die sich den Scheiß nur kaufen, weil sie es sich leisten können, endlich mal wieder besser erkennt. Weißt du, so diese Rolex-Typen.
Ey, du hast ein Messing-iPhone. Das ist ja toll.
Bronze.
Apple's Bronze-Zeitsbericht an.
Wir hören noch ein bisschen auf mit diesem Goldrausch. Was habe ich dieser Tage gelesen? Ubiquiti, dieser Hersteller, von Wireless-Kram und so. Die haben jetzt ihren 1-Millionsten Indoor-Access-Point gemacht, dem haben sie ein Goldnet-Gehäuse verpasst. Ich denke so, ein Access-Point, ein Gerät, das funken soll, vergoldet, Gehäuse, tja.
Naja, stellst du sie ins Regal, kaufst noch einen.
Genau.
Was soll man da groß sagen?
Na, der hat doch Antennen außen dran.
Jetzt ist alles drin in dem Raumschiff. Okay, ja, aber jetzt wollen wir...
So viel zu Kino.
Wir wären heute ein bisschen früher fertig.
Denkt ihr, dass es wirklich nur um iPhones gehen wird?
Naja, iOS 7 werden sie natürlich jetzt auch als Final vorstellen.
Oh Gott.
Wenn wir Glück haben, gibt's noch mal einen Satz neuer...
Fear of an iOS 7 Planet....
gibt's noch mal einen Satz neuer Icons. Mit dem Rest hab ich mich ja inzwischen einigermaßen abgefunden.
Und neue Airpod Express.
Sie haben das jetzt drei Monate auf ihrer scheiß Homepage geklebt. Die werden diese Icons nicht tauschen.
Naja, aber vielleicht fallen sie mal noch ein bisschen dran.
Es wird einfach so sein. Ich hab mich schon abgefunden damit.
Jetzt vermies es mir nicht, oder was?
Ja, mach nicht mich irre.
Ja, und dann sagen sie halt, ja, hier. Die Veloper können jetzt runterladen, oder was weiß ich. Keine Ahnung.
Da ist es jetzt.
Also, vielleicht gibt es dann auch mal.
Was denkt ihr wird dann passieren? iOS 7 kommt raus, download, alle laden das runter. Irgendwie der eine oder andere Appleserver raucht ab.
Dann wird es wieder irgendeinen Mega-Fuck-Up geben. So Maps-mäßig. Daraufhin werden sie vier Wochen später wieder irgendeinen ihrer Manager feuern.
Ja, der Mega-Fuck-Up ist iOS 7.
Ich sag, es wird irgendeinen Mega-Fuck-Up geben.
Okay, das war jetzt ein bisschen sehr negativ. Also ein bisschen sehr.
Später schmeißen wir jemanden raus und die Stimmung kühlt sich wieder ab. Und dann keine Ahnung.
Damit rechne ich nicht.
Mit einem Mega-Fuck-Up?
Ja, das sieht doch gut aus.
Also vielleicht mit einem Erwartungshöhen-Fuck-Up.
Ja, ich glaube, sie werden das Ding schon ganz gut verkauft bekommen. Und Leute werden das vielleicht sogar mögen. Ich bin mir noch nicht so sicher, ob ich es mag. Ich bin da sehr skeptisch. Aber das heißt jetzt auch, es wird nicht stattfinden. Ich hab so ein bisschen Angst davor, dass jetzt so ein iOS 7 Design-Run losgeht. Und alle müssen jetzt so Standard-Look machen, der jetzt noch so shiny und neu ist. Und dann hast du so zehn Apps, die was vollkommen Unterschiedliches machen, aber alle genauso aussehen.
Wieso hast du Angst, dass dieser Run losgeht? Der ist schon in vollem Lauf. Du siehst nur die Ergebnisse noch nicht.
Also ich hab jetzt schon ein paar Apps.
Hast du denn die Instacast-Version für iOS 7 schon gesehen?
Hab ich noch nicht angefasst. Ich hab ja kein iOS 7 installiert. Ich bin komplett nackt. Ich teste das, wenn es fertig ist. Dann weiß ich, wie es ist.
Wie ist die Überraschung mit voller Wucht?
Von 6 auf 7, genau. Ich möchte einfach direkt gegen die Wand laufen.
Ich benutze das ja die ganze Zeit.
Es ist schon klar, dass du bisher noch selten Wege gehabt hast, Dinge wieder zu downgraden. Ich weiß nur darauf hin.
Ich werde das nicht downgraden. Ich werde es einfach nehmen und wie es kommt. Vielleicht ist es ja gar nicht so schlimm.
Ist es nicht. Ich benutze das die ganze Zeit. Das fühlt sich jetzt schon stabil genug an.
Vielleicht sag ich danach...
Was heißt stable? Ich hatte jetzt irgendwie vor zwei Tagen das Problem, dass das iPhone zwei Tage hintereinander innerhalb von kürzester Zeit leer war. Es wurde unglaublich heiß. Es war innerhalb von zwei Tagen leer. Ich dachte schon, ich hätte mir irgendeinen Hardware-Defekt eingefangen.
Oder Skype.
Aber nach zwei, drei Tagen hat es sich wieder beruhigt. Und jetzt läuft das Phone wieder wie vorher.
Ich hatte bisher mit der letzten Version keine Issues.
Machst du denn sowas wie, dass du mit deinem iPhone gegen einen Exchange-Server sprichst?
Nein, weil das hat nicht funktioniert.
Das ist ja auch immer so ein traditioneller Punkt, wo sie gerne mal irgendwie...
Ich hab's versucht, aber es hat nicht funktioniert.
Ich bin so froh, dass ich es bisher vermeiden konnte, in meinem Leben zu Exchange-Servern zu connecten und zweitens Java zu programmieren. Ich hoffe, das bleibt so.
Java hab ich mir mal angeguckt, Java 1.0 oder 1.1, oder was das war, und dachte mir so, ja, ganz nett, könnte was draus werden. Und irgendwie der Rest ist Geschichte.
Für mich sind beide Punkte so irgendwie... Wenn eins der beiden passiert, dann müsste ich, glaube ich, mal über mein Leben nachdenken. Da muss dann irgendwas schiefgelaufen sein unterwegs.
Warum?
Wie bist du auf diese schiefe Bahn geraten?
Wie bin ich auf diese schiefe Exchange-Server Bahn geraten?
Also wir glauben, es kommen Telefone, es kommen ein, zwei neue iPhones raus.
Vielleicht gibt's einen...
Ein iPhone 4 fällt komplett weg, 4S auch. Das ist schon mal die Große. Ich frag's mir in den Raum.
Ein 4 fällt weg, da bin ich mir relativ sicher. Das ist eh klar.
Das wär's eh.
Ach so, 4S auch und nur das 5, 5C und 5S, oder wie es heißt?
Vielleicht nur das 5S, das 5.
Und das 5C.
Das heißt, sie wollen den alten Dock-Connector endgültig loswerden. Dann müssen sie die 4er-Reihe auch gehen. Sondern sie noch verkaufen, müssen immer noch das alte Dock-Kram machen.
Also es sieht einfach danach aus, als ob das 4S nicht überlebt und ersetzt wird durch das 5C. Und ansonsten bleibt ihr Lineup eigentlich gleich. Das neue Telefon, das vom letzten Jahr und noch so ein ganz günstiges Einsteigermodell. Nur, dass sie mit dem Preis von dem Teil so weit runtergehen können, dass sie den iPod Touch gleich sein lassen können. Beziehungsweise einfach deutlich mehr bieten wahrscheinlich auch einfach als so ein 2 Jahre altes Teil. Das ist schon so halbwegs aktuell. Nicht ganz so shiny und fancy. Und wird vielleicht sogar relativ gleichwertig sein mit dem 5er, nur wo sie sich halt vielleicht diesen Alu-Quatsch halt schenken und deswegen einfach billiger bauen können.
Also die iOS Support Matrix sagt ja, dass das iPhone 4, 4S und so weiter ja noch ein iOS 7 bekommen.
Kannst du die iOS Support Matrix mal im Chat spenden?
Das Ding heißt einfach iossupportmatrix.com Also das hatten wir schonmal, oder? Hatten wir letztes Mal schonmal. Ist jetzt irgendwie nicht so schwer.
Entschuldigung. Macht sich trotzdem immer ganz gut, wenn man das hier mal in den Chat wirft.
Dann kannst du direkt draufklicken.
Dann kann das auch verschonotet werden.
Ja Shownotes haben wir heute nicht. Das hat sich irgendwie keiner gefunden.
Oh really?
Alle krank.
Sind wir so unpopulär?
Ja, oder wir reden Unsinn.
Oder sind auch alle krank, es geht ja gerade um.
Okay, dann müssen wir alle auffordern, irgendwie die Shownotes danach mitzuschreiben.
Beinahe hätten wir ja auch kein Previously bekommen.
Nur beinahe. Also gut, das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt eine Voraussage dafür, wer es für Geräte sie jetzt weiter mitnehmen und was nicht. Also das New iPad, wie es da so schön heißt, also dritte Generation, kriegt ja auch noch einen 7. Also es wird aber trotzdem nicht mehr verkauft, weil es ja schon das iPad vierte Generation gibt. Also insofern muss es natürlich nicht heißen, dass sie das iPhone 4 weiterhin verkaufen.
Und was ist mit dem iPad 2? Das iPad 2 läuft auch mit iOS 7.
Das läuft auch mit iOS 7. Das einzige, was halt rausgefallen ist, ist das iPhone 3GS und ich glaube das iPod Touch gleicher Generation wie das 3GS. Also wenn du mal genau hinguckst, dann siehst du, dass alle Geräte rausgeflogen sind, die nur 256 MB RAM haben. Das scheint also 512 MB RAM zu brauchen, damit das ordentlich läuft. Das ist dann halt auch ein logischer Move.
Ok, aber das ist ein zwei Jahre alter iPod Touch. Das ist schon ein relativ schneller Ausschluss für Apple. Das teilt uns auch ein bisschen.
Ok, aber es ist zumindest ein nachvollziehbarer technischer Grund, sag ich mal.
Ja, sicherlich wird es einen geben. Das klingt ganz plausibel mit den 256 MB.
Also nix übrig. Keine Ahnung. Also es ist halt schwer zu sagen, welche Geräte sie raus schmeißen. Das iPhone 4 verkaufen sie das überhaupt noch? Also das werden sie auf jeden Fall rausschmeißen. Ob sie das 4S auch rausschmeißen?
Ich sage, das 4S stirbt.
Ich würde auch sagen, alles ohne Lightning.
Das sieht aus wie das Periodensystem der Elemente.
Dann hast du die hinteren vier Columns, die hinteren vier Spalten sind dann deine Lightning-Spalten. Der schöne Blitz da.
Aber was steht da? Ach so, Force Generation. Was ist denn eigentlich mit dem alten iPad? Wo ist das denn überhaupt?
Welches ist das Alte? Das Dreie ist das New iPad und das iPad 2 heißt halt iPad 2.
Das hier ist doch das, ne.
Das ist das Erste.
Ja genau, das Ur-iPad.
Ja das hat ja schon kein iOS 6 mehr. Das ist drei Jahre her nur?
Ja, 2010, stimmt.
Aber hallo, krass.
Bis auf die beiden Geräte, die nur ein Viertel Gigspeicher haben.
Na gut, so soll es sein.
Also daraus kann man dann erstmal nichts lesen.
Ein Helles bitte.
Gibt's noch irgendwas? Ja, ich hätte auch...
Bayreuther Hell.
Ja, ich nehm auch noch eins.
Ich auch. Volles Programm.
Mal ordentlich uftanken.
Überhaupt keine Sendungsdisziplin mehr.
Wir legen nach.
Hier werden einfach die Getränke-Wünsche noch über den Äther geblasen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir den Keynote schon durch haben. Jetzt könnte es ja noch sein, dass sie noch irgendwas anderes vorstellen.
Naja, sie könnten vielleicht sagen, wann sie denn jetzt den Mac Pro dann mal gedenken, in die Läden zu tun und was er kosten wird.
Oh ja, stimmt.
Das könnte passieren. Darauf wetten würde ich allerdings jetzt nicht unbedingt.
Ich glaube, dass sie das nicht tun werden. Weil nur um zu sagen, dass es irgendwann kommt, machen sie nicht so ein Event.
Ja, aber sie machen ja eh ein Event.
Ja, aber sie verwässern nicht ihre Events mit so einer Nichtigkeit. Hier geht es um das neue fucking iPhone und die komplett neue iPhone kleine Gerätestrategie. Nicht mehr die alten Teile, sondern was topaktuell ist, was einfach günstiger gebaut ist und was mal 200 Dollar billiger ist, als das andere.
Willst du jetzt über die komische iWatch reden?
Du musst trotzdem schon von vorne in das Biko gucken. Das ist ein Nierrad.
Ich hab's jetzt nicht auf. Ich sag, sie werden es wahrscheinlich nicht in der Keynote mit ansagen, aber die Chance, dass es im Umfeld dieser Geschichte mit ansagen, wie zum Beispiel, dass es jetzt auch neue Airpodexpresse gibt, oder so was, werden sie vielleicht schon machen. Aber nicht in der Keynote.
Sie werden... Das wird einfach nicht das Thema sein. Das Thema wird einfach das iPhone sein. Das meine Prediction ist, no Mac Pro News at all. No Mac Pro... No Mac...
Na, Mavericks ist ja zumindest schon sehr nah, auch mit iOS und so.
Also wenn sie keinen eigenen Mavericks Event machen...
Genau, sie bringen ja auch Mavericks raus.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das releasen sie doch gemeinsam, oder?
Die wollen ja das AirDrop haben.
Ja, da würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt drauf bauen.
Aber sehr nah beieinander, weil das AirDrop funktioniert nur mit dem Mavericks auf dem iPhone und dann wäre der...
Also entweder sie machen beides in einem Auffasch, dann kommt, aber werden sie sicherlich auch über neue Mac-Hardware reden, vielleicht nur am Rande. Oder aber sie machen wirklich nur iOS, und dann reden sie halt auch nicht über Mavericks. Zumindest nicht groß. Das ist meine Vorhersage.
Aber dann innerhalb kürzester Zeit nochmal ein Event machen? Das kann auch durchaus sein. Weil jetzt drei Tage später dann nochmal mit der Mac-Sache hinterher zu kommen, funktioniert glaube ich auch nicht. Weil sie wissen, dass sie jetzt maximale Aufmerksamkeit haben. Ich bin da ein bisschen unentfassend.
Aber wenn sie zwei neue iPhones vorstellen...
Okay, machen wir mal andersrum. Unabhängig davon, wann sie das jetzt... Also ob sie das jetzt nächste Mal sagen... Für September steht an, iPhone 5S in Kombination mit dem 5C und das 5 bleibt und 4 und 4S geht weg. iOS 7 kommt raus für all diese Geräte mit den entsprechenden Updates. Dann müssen sie noch Mavericks C9 rausbringen, den Mac Pro und ich weiß nicht, ist nicht auch immer wieder Zeit für neue MacBook Pros?
Da gab es auch so eine Seite über diese Hardware-Produktzeiten.
Die gibt es doch noch nicht mit Haswell, ne? Es gibt doch nur die Airs mit Haswell.
Das weiß ich nicht genau.
Die neuen MacBook Pros haben noch keine Haswell. Die haben noch nicht diese Laufzeiten von den Airs.
Oder?
Komm ich gerade durch an einer Chat?
Ich weiß nicht, die Frage ist nicht, ist das nicht ein bisschen viel in einem Event?
Ja, ja, wie gesagt, ich wollte nur mal aufzählen, was steht jetzt an und was müsste man dann für eine Choreografie wählen, damit da nichts verschüttet geht?
Also ich sag mal so, wenn sie betonen wollen, wie gut iOS und Mavericks zusammenarbeiten und eigentlich nur zwei Seiten der gleichen Medaille sind, dann müssen sie es natürlich im gleichen Event machen.
Aber danach sieht es nicht aus. Die Zielgruppe für iPhone ist nicht konkurrent. Also Leute, die Mac kaufen, sind auch Zielgruppe fürs iPhone, aber nicht umgekehrt. Und sie würden dann die Botschaft irgendwie rüberbringen, hier unsere neuen Telefone mit OSX und mit Macs. Dann glauben sie, das muss ich mir jetzt alles kaufen, damit das funktioniert, dann kaufe ich mir lieber so ein anderes Teil, das geht auch mit meinem Windows-Rechner. Das spreche ich dagegen. Sie wollen einfach, dass die Leute über das iPhone reden. Nur iPhone, iPhone, iPhone, das ist mal wieder so ein Mega-Event. M24 wird wieder den ganzen Tag darüber berichten.
Nein, sie haben mich noch nicht gebucht.
Das wird an den Straßenbahnen haltestellen. In Berlin wird es über die Laufschrift laufen.
Berliner Fenster.
Es wird so ein merkwürdiges World-Event gemacht. Und alle Leute werden gefragt werden, ob sie das toll waren. Die Tagesschau wird darüber berichten. Alle werden darüber berichten. Am Ende werden sogar wir darüber berichten.
Das war noch Zeiten, als in der Tagesschau noch darüber berichtet wurde, wie Windows 7 98 bei der Präsentation abgestürzt ist. Aber nee, über Windows wird nicht mehr berichtet in der Tagesschau. Selbst wenn es abstürzt.
Doch, über Windows 8 haben sie glaube ich berichtet.
Also auf jeden Fall im Mac-Segment, beim Bias-Guide von Mac-Rumors, sind so einige Sachen, die da mal auf Haswell Refresh waren. Zum Beispiel, iMac hat noch keinen Haswell. Und das letzte Update war im November 2012, also ein Jahr her.
Mac Mini, das war schon spät für Weihnachten, dass alles nicht funktioniert.
Mac Mini ist 316 Tage alt. Die Apple TV ist 564 Tage alt.
Ja, aber der hat sowieso keinen Haswell.
Das wird doch keinen kriegen.
Retina MacBook ist 203 Tage alt. Und die letzten Updates waren nach 130 Tagen.
Also meiner Meinung nach, ok, iPhones haben wir jetzt genannt, iPod Touch, keine Ahnung, irgendwas passiert ist. Vielleicht gibt es auch noch so einen iPod Touch im 5C-Design.
Ehrlich gesagt kann ich mir das nicht vorstellen, weil sie haben immer entweder iPhones oder iPod Touches vorgestellt. Aber nie zusammen.
Doch, klar, das ist beim Fünber.
Beim Fünber? Ok, beim Fünber, aber das war extrem selten. Sie kamen immer erst mit dem Phone, das hat dann die ganzen neuen Goodies gehabt und dann haben sie irgendwie zwei Monate später mit einem neuen iPod Touch nachgezogen.
Ja, iPod Touch kamen meistens eben mit den anderen iPods, aber die werden halt immer... Kannst du mal den Link auch nochmal schmeißen? Ich glaube, das wäre mal ganz... Aber eigentlich ist alles fällig. Sie haben ja seit einem Jahr fast nichts gebracht.
Sie haben seit 720 Tagen kein neues Display vorgestellt.
Das Display gibt es erst, wenn es dann auch retina ist.
Ja, und vielleicht haben sie ja wirklich irgendwas in diesem...
iPod Classic wird es keinen neuen mehr geben.
Das sagen wir schon seit fünf Jahren.
Wie, mit Festplatte, den gab es noch?
Die gibt es immer noch.
Die kannst du immer noch kaufen.
Ja, und wenn sie sagen, es gibt keinen mehr, kaufe ich mir einen.
Da musst du mal hier so runterscrollen.
Ich hab noch einen über, den ich eh nicht benutze.
Classic? Also wirklich jetzt so letzte Generation, oder was? Schwarz?
Naja, richtig schwarz ist der nicht. Der ist ja so dunkel, Anthrazit. Den gibt's in hell Anthrazit und in dunkel Anthrazit.
Ja, okay, schwarz. Ja, ich find, das... Bring den mal mit.
Ich hab irgendwann den Kopfhörerausgang von der fünften Generation, die ich auch noch hab, repariert. Und seitdem benutze ich den sechsten Generation gar nicht mehr.
Das war so ein Wurf.
Ja, aber nur der allererste, der noch das mechanische Rollrad hatte. Das war wirklich geil.
Ich sag dir, da ist so 0,6 Sand reingekommen.
Bei mir nicht. Hat bis zum Schluss super funktioniert.
Glück gehabt.
Nichts Glück gehabt. Ich hab das Teil nicht in Sand geworfen.
Schleif, schleif. Also die zweite, also der 5G, find ich, war irgendwie Piekeipod. Das war wittig.
Und ich hab noch ein 5G und den behalte ich auch.
Ja und ich hab meinen verloren.
Aber den gibt's auf Ebay bestimmt. So wie das 6310i.
Da müsste ich auch noch irgendwo eins haben. Gut, also was haben wir da noch?
Also eigentlichs Grün ist nur MacBook Air.
Und iPod Touch. Warum gerade iPod Touch?
Mein iPad Mini ist auch noch relativ frisch. Und alles andere ist auf rot, kann man sagen.
Naja, vom iPad Mini wurde ja, das hat sich die Gerüchtelage ja doch dahin entwickelt, dass es wohl dieses Jahr kein neues iPad Mini mehr gibt.
Was?
Doch, so hat sich die Gerüchtelage entwickelt. Wirklich? Ja, das ist zwar das nächste iPad Mini, sehr wahrscheinlich in Retina sein wird, aber es wird es nicht mehr dieses Jahr geben. So hab ich die Gerüchtelage im Gefühl.
Aber neue iPads sind doch im Rollen. Weißt du, die sind nicht imminent?
Das kann ich mir kaum vorstellen.
Vor Weihnachten soll kein neues iPad mehr rauskommen. Da können sie aber auch nochmal den Mini mit Non-Retina auch nochmal bumpen. So wie sie es mit dem iPad selber auch gemacht haben. Und dann im halben Jahr, wenn sie liefern können, BÄM! Jetzt mit geheimem Display. Aber dass sie auf jeden Fall da kompetitiv bleiben.
Ja, also sie haben 316 Tage kein neues iPad rausgehauen. Kein großes. Und 316 Tage auch kein neues iPad Mini. Und das ist... Die letzten iPads waren auch immer so um 300 Tage, 350 Tage.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Also ich rechne mit einem iOS-Event und vielleicht machen sie eine dicke, fette Nummer daraus und machen auch Macs, aber eher Macs separat.
Kann ich mir auch nicht vorstellen, dass sie Macs im gleichen Aufwasch machen.
Aber sie machen zuerst jetzt iPhone. Und wenn sie dann Mac... Wann bringen sie das? Eine Woche später? Zwei?
Zwei Wochen später.
Und wann bringen sie dann ein iPad raus?
Da haben sie ja keinen Druck. Also ich meine...
Doch, doch, doch, haben sie sehr wohl.
Aber Mavericks bringt ja jetzt nicht so viele, sag ich mal, endnutzerrelevante Features. Ja wir Freaks sehen das anders. Aber weißt du, so...
Aber das AirDrop fürs iPhone, das funktioniert nicht damit.
Ähm, dass ich nicht glaube, dass es jetzt um zwei Wochen ankommt. Also Ende September, um es noch ins Weihnachtsgeschäft kippen zu können, ja.
Exactly. Ja, aber sie müssen alle drei Sachen, alle Produkte in das Laufen kriegen.
Jaja, dass sie das noch ins Weihnachtsgeschäft kippen, davon gehe ich sehr stark aus.
Ja, was kommt dann zuerst? Kommt erst iOS, dann kommt Mac und dann kommt iPad oder kommt erst iPhone?
September, das ist ja der gerüchtete Termin, wird jetzt auf jeden Fall das iOS-Event sein und möglicherweise Ende September nochmal irgendein MacOS-Event. Also so ist meine Einschätzung. Kann natürlich daneben liegen.
Ende September noch?
Ja, was weiß ich, so im gemütlichen zwei Wochen Abstand, so dass irgendwie alle Zeitungen mal ordentlich schreiben konnten und das dann also auch im Föjeton von der Zeit abgehandelt wurde und dann kann man das nächste Event machen. Also ja, weiß ich nicht. Also wenn sie es nicht am gleichen Event machen, dann müssen sie sich so einen Puffer lassen von zwei Wochen oder so.
Die haben auch schon mal Wochenstakato gebracht. Mich würde das nicht überraschen. Die müssen die Scheiße jetzt langsam mal rauskriegen.
Das ist natürlich ein Grund. Hört hin, der Tim kann nicht warten.
Das ist kein Grund, das ist ein Zwingen.
Aber hast du nicht gerade erst frisch installiert?
Oh ja, soll ich mal davon berichten? Ist das jetzt dran? Ja, könnte dran sein. Gibt es denn zu Mavericks selbst irgendwelche Neuigkeiten? Oder ist da eigentlich alles total?
Doch, da gibt es Neuigkeiten. Da muss ich mir hier kurz gucken. Mir sind so ein paar Sachen aufgefallen, als ich jetzt bei dem, also gestern, heute kam ein Update. Und da waren halt wieder Release Notes dabei. Und da waren dann so ein paar Sachen dabei, die fand ich halt irgendwie spannend. Und deswegen, Moment mal kurz gucken, ob ich das nachher noch offen hab. Deswegen wollte ich da nochmal drauf eingehen. Also das eine ist hier, Screen Recordings taken with Developer Preview 7 are not compatible with earlier releases. So, höh, Screen Recordings? Bauen die jetzt einen neuen Codec ein oder was soll das?
Warum redest du jetzt gerade?
Von Mavericks Developer Preview 7. Das ist das, was heute rauskam.
Ja, Screen Recording.
So, dann, was aber schon größer ist, Fusion Drives, die ich mit Developer Preview 7 erzeuge, sind nicht mehr kompatibel mit 10, 8, 4 oder earlier. Das heißt, sie haben da irgendwas am Fusion Drive gedreht, was auch immer, aber es ist jetzt inkompatibel und das finde ich zumindest spannend.
Warte mal, was genau inkompatibel? Wenn du mit dem neuen OS eine Fusion Drive machst, dann kannst du die mit dem 10.8. nicht mehr aufmachen.
Also mit der gestern oder heute erschienenen Preview 7, ein Fusion Drive machst, kannst du es mit älteren Versionen nicht mehr aufmachen, weil es inkompatibel ist.
Aber noch mit den aktuellen, das heißt, sie haben schon mal wieder in 10.8.3 und 10.8.4 ein Spielchen eingebaut, was aber nicht aktiv ist, was sie aber jetzt mit der neuen Mavericks-Version freigeschaltet haben oder benutzen.
Und was ich auch sehr spannend fand, das ist aber schon älter, starting in Developer Preview 4, seit wir Developer Preview Version 4 können nicht-Admin-User Software installieren aus dem Mac App Store. Steht in den Release Notes. Das fand ich interessant. Also du kannst andere Software nicht, aber die aus dem Mac App Store.
Wieso? Kannst du andere Software?
Du hast nicht-Admin, hast du ja keine Zugriff.
Kannst du die nicht in den Applications-Folder ziehen?
Nein, aber nicht nur in deinem eigenen App Store.
Ja, kannst du runterladen.
Ja, aber du kannst ja auch sonst Software runterladen und auch ohne Admin zu sein installieren, vielleicht nicht im Applications-Verzeichnis.
Auf deinen Desktop schmeißen.
Aber du kannst sie benutzen. Denselben Ease of Use willst du natürlich auch haben. Das ist ein echtes Problem, gerade bei so shared Macs und so, wo du nicht jeden zum Admin machen willst. Na ja gut, wie auch immer, das ist jetzt drin. Hast du noch was?
Hattest du nicht noch so ein Audiobonbon?
Nein, ein Audiobonbon hab ich nicht.
Aber Tim?
Also das sind so die Sachen, die hier aus den Release Notes rauskommen, wo ich so dachte, was ist denn jetzt los?
Haut einen auch nicht gerade vom Hocker, ne?
Wir sitzen noch ganz gemütlich drauf.
Wir sitzen noch ganz gemütlich.
Ich glaube, wir hatten schon mal darüber gesprochen, über diese Sache in Mavericks, oder? Ich weiß nicht. Ich hab da irgendwie so einen Tweet bekommen, von jemandem, den ich vor ein paar Tagen noch mal auf der Straße getroffen habe. Schöne Grüße. Was hast du für einen Rechner, Roddy?
Ich hab hier einen MacBook Pro 2011 oder so.
Und das läuft aber mit Mavericks.
Na, ich hab Mavericks jetzt hier in der virtuellen Maschine laufen. Hier, ich hab's in der virtuellen Maschine laufen.
Ja gut, aber das ist ja auch kein aktuelles Gerät. Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall, wenn man Mavericks hat, vielleicht hat das ja jemand, der zuhört, auch schon ausprobiert oder könnte es mal ausprobieren, mit einem topaktuellen Rechner. Also mit The Latest iMac zum Beispiel ging es wohl. Und wenn man in die Netzwerks-Settings geht, in die Ethernet, in die Options, da kann man halt irgendwie AVB einschalten. Es gab auch irgendwo einen Screenshot, den weiß ich aber jetzt nicht, wo ich den habe. Also Audio-Video-Broadcasting. Was das bewirkt, wenn man da draufklickt, was da passiert oder so, ich habe keine Ahnung. Aber man kann es irgendwie anschalten und. Ich wüsste wirklich gerne, was es bedeutet. Aber es könnte halt bedeuten, dass sie AVB vielleicht im Audiosystem unterstützen könnten. Audio-Video-Broadcasting heißt ja im Prinzip Real-Time-Audio und Real-Time-Video über Ethernet. Schön getaktet, so richtig knackerharte, super-low-latency, du wirst auf dem alten Rechner sowieso nichts finden.
Vielleicht hat die VR-Message in der VM schon gleich dreimal nicht.
Vielleicht simuliert die ja genau die richtige Netzwerke.
Hat sicherlich irgendwas mit der...
Du könntest durchaus sagen, dass da noch eine zusätzliche Soundkarte auftaucht. Oder sowas.
Genau, sowas. Das würde ich komplett hinten überfallen, wenn das so ist. Irgendwie rechne ich nicht damit, aber das wäre natürlich der Briller. Dafür ist halt diese Technologie. Man macht halt einfach Audio-Kanäle übers Netz und dann ist es zuverlässig und die Switches spielen mit. Und wenn man das halt einfach in so einem OS einfach so einschaltet und dann nimmt man daran teil und dann muss man keine Ahnung, noch was installieren oder eben auch nicht installieren. Wenn ich das richtig erinnere, in den Netzwerks-Settings für Ethernet gibt es so eine Option, die heißt wie?
Ich gucke jetzt mal in der Hilfe.
Da wird bestimmt nichts stehen. Schau mal.
Ich meine, was der Knaller da haben wäre, ist, wenn so ein Hersteller so etwas gleich in sein Betriebssystem einbaut, dann springt natürlich die Zubehörindustrie noch viel eher drauf, als wenn das wieder so eine, ja, und da laden sie hier den Treiber runter und installieren sie das und so, das ist immer so was anderes. Aber wenn das so was gibt...
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall ein totales Profi-Feature. Das wäre einfach der Knaller. Aber jeden neuen Mac einfach so als real-time Audio-Streaming-Büchse verwenden könnte im Netz, im Lokalen, ist schon geil.
Na, Apple wäre es zuzutrauen.
Ja genau, es wäre ihnen absolut zuzutrauen und es würde auch völlig Sinn machen.
Machst du denn dann auch einen Clean-Install, wenn Mavericks kommt?
Gute Frage. Ja, das Stichwort.
Als ein bisschen gehäupert überleuchtung.
Ich hatte ja hier übrigens genau der richtige Zeitpunkt für den Übergang. Also dieses Dante-Protokoll, von dem ich hier im Prinzip gerade rede. Was heißt gerade? Also was ich jetzt seit zwei Jahren, wie lange benutze ich das jetzt? Wir sind jetzt hier schon drei Jahre.
Also eigentlich alles alte Scheiße.
Na was heißt alte Scheiße? Also Dante ist halt das System von der Firma Ordinate. Die waren halt einfach die ersten Themen. Die waren da ganz früh dran. Für die war das so richtig ein Thema. Die haben ganz früh versucht, in diese Richtung hinzuentwickeln.
Ich hab gerade noch mal gegoogelt nach AVB und Mavericks und hier gibt es von irgendeiner AVB Konferenz. Oder da war so eine Show und eine Easternet AVB-Panel oder Section. Und irgendwie wird hier auch von Apples Announcement, that the upcoming OSX Mavericks Operating System will include native support for AVB gesprochen.
Link, Link, Link, Link, Chat.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht mal, auf welches Announcement sie sich beziehen. Das wird natürlich nicht verlinkt, aber irgendwie.
Das wüsste ich auch gerne.
Zumindest spricht man davon. Auf dem irgendwie...
Ah, das ist alles.
Das ist schon alles.
Na gut, wie gesagt, es gibt diesen Screenshot. Ich hab das selber noch nicht ausprobiert. Vielleicht könnt ihr einfach alle mal schauen. Ich gehe jetzt mal einfach davon aus, dass wenn das hier so steht, dass ich mir das jetzt nicht alles nur einbilde. Vielleicht noch mal kurze Erklärung. Was ist das? Also ich hab ja hier meinen Mischpult. Ich hab so einen Digitalmischpult von Yamaha. Ich hab mir deshalb ein digitales Mischpult, so ein Angebermischpult gekauft, weil ich einfach festgestellt habe, dass ein gutes Mehrkanal Analogmischpult eigentlich sowieso das gleiche kostet. Und dann kann ich es auch gleich einen digital haben. Und dieses 01V96 von Yamaha, was ich ja habe, ist einfach, das ist so der VW Golf unter den Veranstaltermischpulten.
Wie viel hast du dafür jetzt bezahlt?
Also das kostet, glaube ich, normal 2,5. Und diese Dante-Karte, die ich da hinten in den einzigen vorhandenen Modulschacht geschoben habe, hat, glaube ich, nochmal 600 Euro gekostet. Ich habe es aber ein bisschen billiger bekommen, weil ich so ein Rückgabegerät bei so einem Laden geschoppt habe. Einmal noch ein paar hunderter gespart.
Reservished.
Genau. Ja, so eine Rückgabe. Repackaged. Da war es halt ein bisschen billiger, aber so ist natürlich eine Menge Holz. Aber ich habe auch mal verglichen mit dem, was ich für Mischpulte sonst so ausgegeben hätte. Und wenn du so ein richtiges Mäcki-Mischpult, weil dieser Rest, wie heißen die alle? Phonik und Behringer. Behringer kann man bei so großen Mischpulten gar nicht so richtig ernst nehmen. Klar, das funktioniert alles irgendwie. Aber das hast du einfach Kanal übersprechen. Und am Ende hast du tausend Knöpfe. Aber du musst die auch alle die ganze Zeit einstellen. Und wenn einer mal was verdreht, dann ist das irgendwie weg. Und dafür war mir das dann auch zu teuer. Während ich hier weiß, wenn hier einer reinkommt und alles verdreht, drücke ich auf Restore und BÄM, alles ist wieder da. Das ist einfach so segensreich bei solchen Sachen. Weil so ein Setup, wenn du das erstmal gefunden hast, dann kriegst du auch den Teppich. Die große Frage bei diesen Mischpulten ist natürlich immer, wie kriegst du diese vielen Kanäle in den Rechner rein und raus? Und mittlerweile gibt es auch einen Nachfolger von diesem 01V96, das ist das 01V96i. Und das hat jetzt nicht nur USB, um darüber MIDI zu machen, wie das jetzt bei diesem Gerät ist, sondern die machen halt auch 16... I wie intelligent. Wie auch immer. Über das USB kriegt ihr halt 16 Kanäle rein und raus. Mit den üblichen Nachteilen von USB. Also, State und so weiter steckst. Schaltest dein Mischpult aus, ist dein Audi-Device weg. Nichts macht mich wahnsinniger. Es ist immer dieses, ja, noch mal das Programm starten, damit da...
Aber das hast du noch bei Firewire auch.
Das hast du bei Firewire auch. Aber das hast du nicht bei Dante. Bei mir ist es eher so, wenn ich das Mischpult ausschalte, dann verschwinden die Sound-Devices von meinem Rechner nicht. Alle Kanäle sind nach wie vor da. Sie sind halt nur leise. So wie das halt in einem analogen Mischpult auch ist. Also dieses AVB funktioniert viel mehr wie analoge Stecker. Obwohl es mega digital ist. Das ist einfach stateless. Und es rauscht über dieses Gigabit-Internet.
Es ist digital und es rauscht?
Es rauscht im Sinne von... Es nimmt viel Platz dort ein. Nicht zu viel Platz. Es ist auch, wenn du mal genau hinhörst, es rauscht, oder? Also ein bisschen.
Das ist ein anderes Rauschen. Nein, das ist ein anderes Rauschen.
Das ist ein Glücksrauschen. Ja, wurde endlich gestillt. Das Computer in der Lage ist, das Audio zwischen zwei Computern über ein Netzwerk zu übertragen. Und es sackt nicht. Weil diese Lösung läuft hier, seit ich sie installiert habe, einfach makellos. Makellos. Bis zu dem Tag, wo ich beschlossen hatte, auf 10.8 zu upgraden.
Genau, jetzt sind wir beim Thema.
Dann hab ich das so gemacht und ich war so ein bisschen blöde in dem Moment, weil ich hatte zwar Backups, aber ich hab mir keine Gedanken über den Prozess der Wiederherstellung des Backups gemacht. Also ich hatte keine, eben mal wieder bootbare Platte oder so. Und es dauerte nur wenige Minuten und ich stellte fest, oh Gott, mein ganzes Audio-Ethernet funktioniert nicht mehr. Britzel, Britzel, Britzel, es ging einfach alles in die Hose. Irgendwie hörte man schon was, aber es war im Arsch. Und ich dachte, fuck, was bitte in aller Welt kann sich von 10.7 auf 10.8 so dramatisch geändert haben, dass etwas, was bis dahin jahrelang wirklich auch nur ohne den Funken von Fail unterwegs war, auf einmal völlig vergammelt. Naja, ich hatte nicht viel Zeit darüber nachzudenken, ich hab das einfach nur zur Kenntnis genommen. Ich war auch gewarnt, weil ich einen ähnlichen Effekt auch schon auf meinem MacBook Air hatte, wo ich auch nach dem Upgrade ähnliche Probleme hatte. Obwohl es mit Thunderbolt und so weiter und Gigabit Ethernet ja eigentlich problemlos auch gehen sollte. Aber da auch irgendwie nicht ging. Und dann kam ich halt schon so langsam auf dieses Gefühl, naja, wenn es auf dem Rechner nicht geht und auf einem Mac Pro nicht geht, dann geht es vielleicht generell unter 10-8 nicht. Nur, ich hatte halt auf beiden Maschinen einen Upgrade einer lange laufenden Installation gemacht. Und ich weiß nicht, was es ist. Irgendeine dieser Myriaden von Treibern, die man dann doch mal installiert und nicht richtig deinstalliert oder irgendwelche Verfettungen in diesem ganzen System als solchen, haben irgendwie ein Subsystem aus der Spur gebracht, für das dieses Stunt relevant ist. Also der Netzwerkstack im Wesentlichen, weil der wird an der Stelle benutzt. Das ist ja nur ein virtueller Soundtreiber. Bei dem Yamaha-Teil hat das Ding ja in dem Modul eine eigene Ethernet-Steckdose, also Ethernet-Buchse. Da ist ein Xilinx-Stein dran und da läuft halt ein kompletter Netzwerkstack selber drauf. Die haben da einfach Realtime-IP und deswegen schaffen die da halt auch so super absurde Basislatenzzeiten von 250 ds. Also eine Viertelmillisekunde. Mikrosekunden, genau. Also eine Viertelmillisekunde hat das Ding Basislatenz, also was nicht zu unterschreiten ist. Bei 1 Gigabit, bei 10 Gigabit sieht das wieder anders aus. Und auf dem Mac habe ich diese Hardware nicht. Es gibt zwei jetzt mittlerweile, diese PCI-Card, da hatte ich ja schon ein paar mal erwähnt, ich habe sie mir bisher noch nicht gekauft, weil ich wollte das hier überhaupt alles erstmal heile haben und hier geht es halt durch den ganzen iOS-Stack und deswegen hast du mindestens 6 Millisekunden Basislatenz. Also die musst du mindestens dazurechnen oder 10 oder waren es 4, irgendwie sowas. Und so richtig schnell rein raus, latenzfrei, geht halt nicht, will man aber eigentlich haben und geht halt eigentlich auch mit diesem AVB-Kram. Nochmal zur Erklärung, Dante ist halt so die erste Implementierung von dem, was AVB ist und dieser Standard scheint jetzt nur so weit durch zu sein, dass Apple sagt, ok, dann bauen wir das ein. Ist das irgendwie klar? Also alles, was jetzt noch kommt, sind OS-Updates und vielleicht mal noch eine Firmware oder so, pflegen so wie bei WLAN, wenn sie sich so halbwegs sicher sind mit dem neuen Standard und jetzt bauen sie das einfach schon mal ins OS rein, weil es standardisiert, haben wir mal implementiert, ist geil.
Es gibt einen Screenshot jetzt, glaube ich.
Von was denn?
Von diesem Setting.
Ich habe auch hier die IO-AVB-Family Cacks gefunden. Die Kernel-Extension, die dazugehört.
Na, mach mal einen Hexdump auf und guck mal rein, was da drin steht.
Bin dabei, bin dabei.
Das wäre mal ganz interessant. Und wenn es halt irgendeinen Weg gibt, wie man Audio-Devices aufmachen könnte, das wäre natürlich der Brüller.
Übrigens, an denjenigen, der dir den Screenshot geschickt hat, da ist ein Wort, was tödlich ist. Da steht halb duplex. Das ist irgendwie braun.
Dein Internet ist kaputt.
Das ist braun. Aber egal.
Was heißt denn dieses EAV eigentlich nochmal?
Erste Allgemeine Verunsicherung.
Schade, du hast mir vor.
Aber in dem Zusammenhang. Und found.
Interessant ist, dass da Modus steht. Ist dieses Interface denn für nichts anderes mehr zu gebrauchen? Ich würde es ja sonst sagen, Optionen oder Feature. Oder blende mal die virtuellen Audio-Devices ein oder aus. Aber Modus klingt immer so ein bisschen nach, ich schalte jetzt hier was um. Vielleicht kann man das dann um. Aber das werden wir dann alles sehen.
Es sieht auch so aus, dass wenn das Ding... Schwierig zu sagen. Also eigentlich ist genau die Coexistenz mit dem normalen Netz eines der Kernfeatures von dem ganzen AVB-Kram. Dass du eben keine dedizierten Leitungen brauchst. Ich hab hier einfach nur eine Kabelinfrastruktur und da läuft halt Audio drüber und auch alles andere, was ich hier so klicke.
Du musst es nur nochmal an deinem Switch ein bisschen priorisieren, aber das machen wir noch.
Ja gut, aber seitdem ich den Switch habe, sind ja auch diese ganzen Ausfälle nicht wiedergekommen. Also, klopf auf Holz. Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass das der Grund war für die ganzen Ausfälle hier. Der war einfach überfordert mit diesem Power-Netzwerk. Dann habe ich gesagt, okay, alles klar, ich habe jetzt keinen Bock, ich muss das unbedingt zum Laufen kriegen. Ich will auf 10.9 und wenn ich noch nicht mal auf 10.8 komme, ich werde wahnsinnig, weil bei 10.9 jetzt einfach auch wieder so Dinge drin sind, die will ich hier benutzen. Dann habe ich gesagt, okay, dann mache ich halt The Full Monty und habe einfach auf der nackten Platte angefangen und irgendwie erst mal so ein ganz frisches 10.8 darauf gebraten, gleich vom Start weg im letzten Patchlevel und dann...
Dann hat er auch den Quack ausprobiert und siehe da, es britzelte nicht mehr.
Exactly.
Ich habe es installiert. Das war so das erste, was ich so installiert habe, nachdem alles andere irgendwie wichtig war und siehe da. Keine Probleme. Das ist sozusagen alles.
Ich glaube es erst, wenn es auf 10.8 ist.
Wenn mein Eyecatcher das morgen runterladen konnte, dann glaube ich, dass er das jetzt.
Deswegen haben wir keine Show-Notes. Die Show-Notes laufen noch nicht auf 10.8.
Wo ist eigentlich die Anzeige unserer Hörerzahl? Könnte sein, dass die Null ist und wir merken es gar nicht. Es gibt ja Leute im Chat, die noch was erzählen.
Das kann sein, weil auch diese Preview-Grafiken hier, die sind irgendwie alle not found.
Man sieht die Podcast-Infrastruktur zerbröselt. Wir können ja mal die Xenium-Up einfach mal starten. Und gucken, die zeigen ja da was an.
Nee, wir haben keine. Es gibt da ein Protokoll, aber das hat sich irgendwann mal geändert.
Doch, hier sind die Hörer. 400 Stück. Dein Browser ist kaputt. Ich sehe die Grafiken.
Ach so, jetzt weiß ich, was das Problem ist.
Lass meinen Resolver benutzen.
Nein, das Problem ist, dass der auf IPv6 dazugreift. Entschuldigung, über HTTPS dazugreift. Und dann klappt das mit den Bildern nicht. Wegen Bodennebelzertifikate. Wenn ich über HTTPS mache, geht's. Alles klar.
Übrigens, diese komische Eurein. IOAVBfamily.kext ist schon in der Version 2.0.0.alpha. Also keine Ahnung, vielleicht gibt's die unter 10.8.0 auch schon.
Kann man mal gucken.
System Library Extensions.
Jetzt sind sie doch bei dir auch. Jetzt wurde den Pfad eh schon da.
Kann ich mal gucken.
Wie heißt das Teil? Groß, klein, IA, IOAVB.
Fängt alles groß an.
Ja, die gibt's ja auch schon. Kann so was Besonderes nicht sein.
Kann so was Besonderes nicht sein.
Beziehungsweise, sie haben es halt einfach schon mal, ja, weiß ich auch nicht, was ist da dabei so denken.
Ob sie sich überhaupt was bei denken.
Oder ob das überhaupt was bedeutet. Man weiß es nicht. Man weiß es nicht. Weiß ja gar ja, was sie da mitmachen. Anyway, wenn das irgendwie funktioniert, dann ist irgendwie alles toll. So, da hab ich Cleans toll gemacht und alles ist super. Aber es ist auch sehr interessant zu sehen, was einem dabei hilft, so einen Cleans toll zu machen und was nicht. Also welche Programme machen es einem zum Beispiel einfach, Settings zu übertragen und bei welchen ist das irgendwie wirklich so ein Wildwuchs. Man kann sagen, generell ist es eigentlich bei den allermeisten schlecht. Na, wo stehen die Daten in deinem Up.net-Client? Mit welchen Accounts du so eingeloggt bist und was so deine Settings zu sind. Wo stehen die?
Normalerweise in Preferences.
Leute, die Zeiten sind wirklich schon lange vorbei, dass das alles in einer Datei steht.
Und die ganzen Sachen, die sicherheitsrelevant sind, sind im Schlüsselbund.
Hast du denn deinen User-Account überragen?
Und es gibt noch Application-Support.
Es gibt Application-Support, das ist schonmal ein richtiger Klassiker. Also da drin ist dann entweder eine Datei oder ein Ordner oder manchmal auch beides, wo du nicht weißt, was jetzt von der früheren oder von der älteren Version kommt. Ok, man kann sich aber denken, nehme ich mal alles, aber das ist ja genau dieser Craft, den ich nicht haben will. Ich will nur das haben, was wirklich nötig ist, aber ich will halt auch meine Settings...
In Application Support macht man keine Settings rein, da macht man höchstens Daten.
Ja, du Mann, die reine Lehre.
Steht irgendwo, ja.
Die Praxis ist anders.
Nein, Moment, es gibt halt unter Coco, es nennen sich NS User Defaults, alles was du da reinschreibst, da kannst du halt sagen, bool for key oder string for key oder weiß ich nicht was und das landet alles in den Preferences. Und wenn du im Application Support Folder reinschreiben willst, dann musst du das selber machen, dann musst du da Dateien aufmachen und reinschreiben.
Ja, aber es gibt diesen Ordner und seine Struktur ist irgendwie unklar. Ein bisschen aufgeräumter und anders aber auch vor allem ist es halt mit App Store Apps. Da liegt der ganze Kram wiederum in Library Containers. Und dann hast du da noch ein Programm.
Nee, nicht ganz. In Sandboxed Applications liegt es unter Library Containers und App Store Apps müssen Sandboxed sein. Aber es gibt natürlich auch nicht App Store Apps, die Sandboxed sind, einige wenig.
Ich sage ja nicht, dass das nicht alles irgendwie auch nachvollziehbar ist.
Aber das sind die gleichen Folder. Da findest du auch dein Application Support Folder und da findest du auch dein Preferences Folder und das ist genau das gleiche. Nur, dass es halt alles in einem Container drin ist.
Ja, aber wenn ich jetzt manuell, ich mache eine neue Installation und alles was ich habe ist da das Backup, was da so rumliegt, wo ich irgendwie ein Fallsystem rum navigieren kann und die Scheiße wieder zurück.
Was du eigentlich haben möchtest ist, dass du eine Software, die du neu installierst, die dich höflicherweise fragt, ob die irgendwie schon mal da war, ob du nicht noch irgendwo eine alte Time Machine Backup rumzulegen hast, von der sie gerne die letzten Settings importieren können, sollen, dürfen, müssten.
Jetzt übertreibst du sie.
Jetzt übertreibst du sie aber wirklich.
Aber das ist das, was ich in Tims Gesicht gerade ablese. Du installierst eine neue Software, die dich genauso wie wenn du ein neues Mac OS installierst, fragt es dich auch, hast du noch irgendeinen alten Schrott, den du noch übernehmen willst? Und du möchtest jetzt, wenn du eine neue App installierst, die dich auch fragt, ja, ich werde jetzt mal neu installiert, aber hast du vielleicht noch ein altes Ding von mir, wo du jetzt noch Daten übernehmen möchtest?
Ja, aber dann muss der User in der Lage sein, diese Software an die richtige Stelle zu führen, wo er dann überhaupt erst mal anfängt zu suchen, ohne gleich alles durchsuchen zu müssen. Also, ich finde...
Aber ich bin davon, dass, wie gesagt, diese neuen Dinger kommen ja alles Handbox, die dürfen selbst bei bestem Willen gar nicht dahingreifen, um den Entdeck aufzulegen.
Aber nur die aus dem App Store, aber du hast ja auch noch andere.
Also, ich finde, wenn ein Betriebssystem in der Lage ist, dem Programm zu sagen, ich fahre jetzt hier gleich mal runter, mach mal das Richtige, dann könnte es auch vorbeikommen und sagen, ich werde hier gleich mal deinstalliert. Schreib mal bitte hier in einem definierten Format für mich alle deine Settings, serialisier das mal in die Reihen.
Die meisten Neuinstalationen funktionieren so, dass man vorher das Ding richtig runterfährt. Die allermeisten Neuinstalationen machst du, weil dir irgendwas kaputt gegangen ist.
Aber das sind irgendwie Maschinen, die müssen in der Lage sein, sich selber zu beschreiben, sonst sind es ja einfach Loonies. Ich finde, das kann man an moderne Computersysteme, kann man diese Anforderungen langsamer stellen.
Du solltest einfach dein ganz fucking Zeug in die iCloud laden, dann passt das schon alles.
Wieso soll ich das machen? Wie soll ich meinem Computer sagen, du sollst...
Nein, du sollst dem das einfach nur erlauben. Dann würde nämlich Apple das alles einfach an die iCloud schreiben, schön das Backup machen in Formeet oder in Juta und dann wär deine Welt rosa. So denkt sich Apple das ja. Die wollen das ja so haben. Alle deine Settings, alle deine Daten, einfach alles in die iCloud, dann kannst du den direkt hundertmal am Tag neu installieren und hast immer noch alle deine Daten, alle deine Settings, alles supertoll. So stellt sich Apple das ja vor. Aber wir doofen, paranoiden Deutschen haben ja keinen Bock da drauf.
Achso.
Wir wollen das ja alles immer selber speichern und dann beschützen und Platten verschlüsseln und so.
Ich will das ja auch selber speichern, aber man muss es ja nicht unbedingt in die iCloud schreiben, man kann es ja auch irgendwo anders hinschreiben. Man kann es zum Beispiel in einen Migration Passport schreiben.
In einen kleinen USB-Dongel, den man rausziehen kann und in deinem nächsten Disk.
Also ich hab ja im Arc meine ganzen Settings und wenn ich jetzt Clean Install machen müsste, und das müsste ich auch bald mal, weil das ist ja auch alles so zugegangen. Ich hab ja seit drei Releases keinen Clean Install gemacht. Es steht wieder an. Da werde ich mich dann wahrscheinlich aus dem Arc bedienen und da habe ich meine User Library komplett drin mit Application Support, Präferenz und dem ganzen anderen Schüssel.
Also wenn ich ganz tief auf meinem Motherboard rumschnüffel, riecht das auch noch nach Tiger.
Also ganz ehrlich, wenn du Application Support und die Präferenz hast und noch die Keys aus der Keychain, dann müsstest du eigentlich bei 99 Prozent der Programme gut dabei sein.
Na ja, da ist natürlich trotzdem immer noch einiges anderes.
Application Support ist insofern ein Problem, dass du eigentlich wenn du keine dokumentorientierte App hast, all die Daten, die zu deiner App gehören, dorthin speicherst.
Ja, aber das ist alles blanke Theorie, weil am Ende weißt du nicht, welche Daten sollst du übernehmen und welche nicht. Weil du kannst die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du irgendeinen Setting nur zur Hälfte oder vielleicht zu 90 Prozent übernimmst, weil du irgendeine Scheiß-Datei, irgendein Kack-Folder in irgendeinem Subfolder übersehen hast. Da gibt es ja auch noch andere abenteuerliche Orte.
Also diese Punktverzeichnisse im Home-Verzeichnis sind ja auch nicht zu toppen an ihrer Eglichkeit. Also ich hätte ja am liebsten einen Skript, was eigentlich alle Punktverzeichnisse im Home regelmäßig ausleeren.
Angefangen mit Punkt SSH.
Genau, und Programme, die damit nicht klar kommen, die kommen weg.
Und Punkt Wim und Punkt SSH.
Ja, Punkt Wim zum Beispiel. Und Punkt X und Punkt weiß ich nicht, was alles ist.
Das ist jede Menge Punkt. Kannste glauben. Ich bin ja auch noch so ein alter Unix MP, der immer noch einen Terminal umstaut hat.
Hier gibt es irgendwie was, Accounts habe ich hier. Das sind so die Ordner in meinem Library-Folger. Accounts, Address Book Plugins. Okay, weiß man, muss man auch installieren. Application Skripts. Weiß ich auch nicht, muss man das jetzt irgendwie mitnehmen? Wo ist das jetzt? Da ist com.apple.mail, ein Lehrer-Ordner, keine Ahnung, wo ist das jetzt?
Da kannst du so Skript-Plugins auch für einen Finder. Ich sehe jetzt gerade vor mir, was da auf mich zukommt.
Das ist mehrere Tage Arbeit.
Kalenders.
Aber vielleicht ist es doch manchmal gar nicht schlecht.
Bist du jetzt im Library selber oder was?
Ja, also ich nehme grundsätzlich die ganze User-Library so ein extra Folder mit und kopiere mir dann immer so bei jeder App, die ich dann wieder installiere, den Scheiß rüber, den ich brauche.
Da gibt es jede Menge direkt in Library, was da nicht hingehört. Also so ARQ hat da ein Verzeichnis, Arduino.
Facebook. HeliX. Was haben die da bitte zu suchen? Nix. Vor allem, warum wird das Programm nicht automatisch vom OS gelöscht, wenn es da ein Ordner ist?
So, das ist die Facebook Integration wahrscheinlich von deinem OS, die sich da abspeichert.
Oh, stimmt.
Es gibt nämlich auch einen Twitter.
Abgründe.
Okay, alles klar, ich nehm alles zurück. Na ja, wie auch immer. Keychain übernehmen ist auch so eine Sache. Das heißt nämlich dann auch immer wieder anders. Was liegt bei euch in Keychains? Was liegen da für Dateien?
Die schönsten Dateien dieser Erde.
Die man sich als Nerd überhaupt gewünschen kann.
Was liegt in deinem Chains-Directory? Frau Merkels Kette.
Irgendwelche Punkte, Folder, Login und Metadata-Keychain.
Ne Metadata-Keychain hab ich allerdings auch. Und es gibt hier noch Microsoft Intermediate Certificates. Na super.
Kannst du noch mal kurz sagen, was bei dir liegt?
Zwei nullbeitige Dot-Files mit komischen Zahlen und Buchstaben-Kombinationen. Dann eine Login-Keychain und eine Metadata-Keychain.
Eine Login-Keychain und eine Metadata-Keychain. Genau, das ist schon relativ modern. In meiner alten Installation, die müsste ich noch mal ganz kurz hervordenken, war es nämlich anders.
Ich hatte irgendwann mal Keychains kopiert und so weiter. Da hat man natürlich mehr Zeug. Und ich habe noch nie eine One Password-Keychain, eine relativ alte.
Die wird nämlich schon ewig nicht mehr benutzt.
Ja, aber ehe wir uns jetzt Ewigkeiten in der Keychain verlieren, erzähl doch mal die Geschichte deines Clean-Installs weiter. Sonst sind wir hier wahrscheinlich noch um Mitternacht mit dieser Geschichte.
Was heißt Geschichte? Ich hab's getan, es war erfolgreich. Manches war einfach. Es ist schon interessant zu sehen, wie schnell man doch im Prinzip so einen Mac auch wieder komplett von Null hochbekommt. Bis dann am Ende diese ganzen Feinheiten sind. Da merkt man überhaupt erstmal, was man für Defaults normalerweise schon vor ewigen Zeiten mal geändert hat und überhaupt nicht weiß, dass alle anderen damit nicht arbeiten. Also sowas wie Scrollbar-Verhalten zum Beispiel. Wenn du jetzt frisch installierst, wie würdest du deinen Scrollbar einstellen? So wie er im Default ist? Ernsthaft?
Ich hab den auch im Default.
Der Default ist doch...
Der Default ist, du siehst ihn nicht. Du schaust auf Fenster und weißt nicht, ob sie länger sind als sie sind.
Ja, jetzt wo du es sagst, ich kann es verändern.
Also ich hab das Ding immer auf immer zeigen. Ich kann es nicht ertragen, wenn ich nicht meinen Scrollball... General Settings.
Ich hab immer einen 2D-Doc zum Beispiel.
Da muss man aber doch so einen geheimen Kiel.
Das ist jetzt wirklich mal ein interessanter Punkt. Es gibt hier zwei Settings in general. Vom...
Du hast ja Appearance auf Blue und nicht auf Grafit. Das ist ja... Das taucht so an so wenigen Stellen auf, aber für mich ist das immer noch so dieses Pro-Setting. Alles so ein bisschen reduzierter und nicht so megabunde früher, weil das Grafit ja ein... Also dieses war ja an vielen Stellen so überall, wo diese Aqua-Buttons waren und so weiter. Ganz krass und das habe ich zum Beispiel immer auf Grafit gestellt, schon seit eh und je und...
Ich finde das gerade für das Highlighting von, wenn man so über die User-Interface-Elemente tappt, weil ich benutze mein UI...
Das kannst du auch gut sehen.
Na ja, da kann man sich genauso drauf trainieren, aber ich finde das schon gut, dass das nochmal eine andere Farbe ist. Dass es einfach so hervorsteht, gerade wenn man so Textfelder markiert hat und so. Wie auch immer. Also das ist genau was ich meine. Highlight-Color, was habt ihr für eine Highlight-Color?
Standard.
Da habe ich auch Baby-Blue-Standard, ja.
Wirklich? Das mache ich zum Beispiel immer auf Gold.
Du wirst auch das goldene iPhone kaufen.
Champagner, Champagner. Aber wahrscheinlich wird diese Farbe dann auch auf Champagner umbenannt.
Ich gucke mal eben unter Mavericks, wie die Farbe ist.
Sidebar-Icon-Size habe ich noch auf Large und ich merke gerade, ich kann es nicht er tragen. Ich mache jetzt...
Medium.
Mindestens Medium oder mache ich Small? Ich mache Small.
Was ist denn die Sidebar-Icon-Size?
Na, die Größe der Sidebar-Icons im Sidebar. Was denn sonst?
Ich habe es auf Medium.
Ich mache jetzt... Nach einem Finder oder wo?
Ja, weil ich sehe da immer, wo ist denn das Teil, wo ist denn das Teil, und dann siehst du unten irgendwie 5 km entfernt von deinem Fensterrand. So, und jetzt kommt es aber überhaupt. Show Scrollbars. Also es gibt drei Settings. Automatically, wenn man so auftaucht, wenn man die Maus bewegt.
Nee, Automatically based on mouse or mouse. Bedeutet, wenn du eine Maus anstöpselst, siehst du sie immer. Wenn du sie nicht angestöpselt hast, dann siehst du sie nicht immer. Soll's geben, hab ich auch gehört.
Immer wieder davon. Also ich hab das Ding auf Always gestellt.
Ja, aber das ist, was mich da nervt. Ich hab ein schwarzes Terminal und wenn ich da auf Always klick, dann macht er mir einen weißen Scrollbar dahin.
Das stimmt.
Und das ist, glaub ich, der Grund, warum ich es nicht auf Always hab. Wenn du es nämlich auf When Scrolling stellst, dann ist der so translucent. Also es fügt sich viel besser ein.
Jetzt wo du es sagst.
Stell das mal kurz auf When Scrolling, weil dann sieht er halt total...
Achso, da ist er immer noch zu sehen.
Nee, nur wenn er scrollt, aber der ist halt so translucent und nicht so hardcore weiß.
Translucent.
Achso, du musst was zum Scrollen haben, verstehe. Gibt's heut nicht.
Gibt halt kein Eis. Habt ihr nicht bestellt? Na ja, ich kann nicht immer irgendwie euch alles von den Lippen ablesen.
Ja, aber Eis weißt du doch.
Ja, nee, mal auch dann nicht und dann sind sich die Herren schon zu dick. Also man weiß es nicht.
Also mir...
Ich hätte jetzt fast was Gemeines gesagt.
Okay, alles klar. Es sieht weniger scheiße aus.
Also wenn der dauerhaft so wäre bei Always, dann würde ich ihn nehmen.
Das ist ja ein Bug. Aber grundsätzlich möchte ich das gerne sehen einfach.
Genau, das ist ja beim Safari sehe ich auch gerade so. Oh Gott, wie hässlich.
So und dann click in the scrollbar too, jump to the next page, so wie das früher war, bei Mac OS. Oder jump to the spot that's clicked. Entschuldigung, ich hab das einmal alles auf Englisch eingestellt. Wie habt ihr das?
Oben.
Standard, jump to the next page.
Das find ich so behindert.
Da kannst du ganz unten reingehen und kannst dann schön Seite für Seite...
Ja, da kann ich auch page up, page down klicken.
Drücken.
Doch, FN, Fall hoch, Fall runter. Nee, ich hab auch jump to scrollbar. Ich glaub auch. Ja, liebe Hörer, so werdet ihr jetzt... Also wie gesagt, heute gehen wir ins Detail. Wir fangen jetzt beim Clean-Install an. Wir fahren jetzt die erste Systemeinstellung an. Kannst du nochmal general aufmachen?
Das ist lustig. Turn-off text smoothing for font sizes gibt es nicht mehr unter Mavericks. Diese Zeile ist weg. Das ist ja auch völlig albern.
Aber die haben auch das ganze Fontsystem anders gemacht.
Was eigentlich albern ist, ist, dass dieses Text-Smoothing für Fonts kleiner als ist nicht nur auf dem Bildschirm, sondern auch wenn du den Scheiß ausdruckst. Das heißt, wenn du wirklich Fonts benutzt, die kleiner sind, dann kriegst du ein Pixel-Font auf dem Drucker.
Nein.
Doch?
Oder ist das dieses LCD-Font?
Nein, das ist dieses Display-PDF.
Ich meine, kann man das ausschalten hier?
Das sieht ja fast besser aus ohne.
Das ist nur, wenn ich dieses Use-LCD-Fonts von Smoothing When Available sozusagen nur, dann gilt das, ne? Das ist richtig sehr. Guck mal, das da unten wird auch Disabled. Da kann ich nichts mehr ändern. Nee, doch nicht. Der Text wird doch hier von Schwarz auf Grau. Dann kann ich trotzdem nur den Kontroll... Oh man, Apple, ey. General Settings habt ihr nicht offen.
Aber es gibt ja jetzt den neuen Bug-Reporter. Der ist viel toller. Da kannst du jetzt ganz schön Bugs reporten. So, jetzt hab ich das auch erledigt.
Entschuldigung, ich...
Ich hechte jetzt hier nach jedem Themenwechsel. Entschuldigung. Meine Befürchtung ist, dass du jetzt jeder dieser drei Dutzend Panel durchgehst.
Natürlich.
Was habt ihr denn für Einstellungen bei Yamaha, USB, MIDI?
Sag mal, Roddy, der neue Apple Bug-Reporter, was ist denn da gerade so gut?
Der sieht jetzt aus wie das alte iCloud-Mail. Also wir hatten ja letztes Jahr, letztes Mal darüber gesprochen, dass bei Beta iCloud-Mail, dass das jetzt so im iOS 7-Look daherkommt. Und das alte iCloud-Mail, das hatte halt den traditionellen Look und dieser Bug-Reporter, der sieht halt jetzt so aus wie das noch aktuelle iCloud-Mail. Also so mehrspaltig.
Der ist einfach so...
Ich hatte ein bisschen noch nicht ein Einstieg mal aufgekriegt, oder dass er mir rechts und links mit Error um die Ohren geflogen ist. Ich hatte das ja schon mal komplett, da ich hier so ein paar Sachen im Netzwerkstack entdeckt habe, auch neulich eine relativ peinliche Nummer. Eine richtig peinliche Nummer, wo man nämlich ein Apple-Gerät durchaus dabei erwischen kann, das das IP-Pakete mit kaputter Check-Sum rausschickt, was schon richtig peinlich ist. Und zwar für IPv4-Pakete mit kaputter Check-Sum in 2013. Aber dann haben wir gedacht, klickst du das Ding mal wieder an, vielleicht möchte jemand in Apple mal was davon hören und dann wieder so, ja, und kann ich, und darf nicht, und kaputt, und peng, und wir leiten sie jetzt zu Microsoft weiter, oder keine Ahnung. Also war jedenfalls ziemlich kaputt.
Also das ist halt so ein dreiteiliges Ding, da hast du ganz links, hast du irgendwie so Klassen wie Open, Hidden, Closed, Archived, Drafts, du kannst jetzt Sachen als Drafts speichern, gab es vorher auch noch nicht. Dann sortiert er das irgendwie noch so Art Filter, Developer Tools, Hardware, iOS, SDK, iPhone, SDK, iPhone SDK?
Egal, sie gesagt, ich muss ja überhaupt erst mal rein und dann kann ich ja mal gucken, ob sich da jemand dafür interessiert.
Und dann hast du so eine mittlere Zeile, die so aussieht wie diese wie diese wie diese Mail- Spalte irgendwie auf dem iPad oder auf dem iPhone bis iOS 6 und dann hast du, wenn du das anklickst, halt wie so eine Art Mail halt auf der rechten Seite halt diesen Bug Report, wo du dann noch irgendwie neue Informationen dazu tun kannst und so.
Diese Nachrichten aus dem Apple-Land irgendwie.
Also im Prinzip tut das ja nicht viel Neues. Außer, dass du jetzt wie gesagt Drafts speichern kannst.
Und keinen Augenkrebs kriegst.
Und dass du... Ja, das ist aber also das ist schon ein großes Feature. Ich hab so ein bisschen das Gefühl, sie haben jetzt das, was sie unter iCloud bald nicht mehr benutzen, weil es ja dann den iOS-Look gibt, haben sie jetzt zu dem Bug Reporter gerettet. Das wird jetzt wahrscheinlich die nächsten zwölf Jahre aktuell sein. Und wird dann entsprechend diesen Vintage-Look haben. Vorher hat das halt diesen Pinstripe. Ich hab so Bubbles, die ganz oben drauf sitzen, Vintage-Look gehabt. Ja, keine Ahnung. Also, ich finde es aber auf jeden Fall gut. Vor allen Dingen, ich habe das Gefühl, das ist jetzt aufgeräumt und man findet auch was wieder. Gibt auch eine Suchfunktion und so ein Scheiß.
Wie gesagt, probier es nochmal und danach kreime ich Apple mal. Und da habe ich nämlich auch festgestellt, für alle Leute gleich nochmal als Tipp, für alle Leute, die versuchen, fernzugucken mit ihrem Mac und das in einer Multicast-Umgebung tun, be aware, da ist was braun.
Mein allererster Buck Report ist vom Dezember 2002. Überhaupt. Ja, aber ich wusste nichts davon.
Vielleicht hat Apple 2002 mal ihren Buck Report ins Internet gestellt überhaupt.
Vielleicht sollten wir nicht so viel über Apple reden. Vielleicht reden wir mal über...
Können wir das nicht den Kollegen von Mobile Max überlassen?
Machen wir kurz dieses... Mit dem DNS nochmal.
Ich dachte, wir machen noch kurz die Sektion Android. Und dann können wir uns voll in die Wand legen, hier mit Telekommunikation Galore.
Also zum Thema Android. Das neue Android...
Heißt Trommelwirbel...
Heißt Trommelwirbel KitKat. So, und jetzt...
Nach dem KitKat-Club in Berlin.
Version 4.4. Und jetzt bitte euch alle mal einzugeben, kitkat.com.
Aber wer hat denn das noch nicht gesehen?
Bittest du sie jetzt D-Dossen?
Er scheint es noch nicht gesehen zu haben.
Clemens hat es noch nicht gesehen. Das fand ich doch sehr nett. Ja, es ist erstmal ein bisschen rot. Und dann gibt es diese absurde Werbung von KitKat. Du musst jetzt da... Jetzt kann man da eine Weile scrollen und...
KitKat 4.4.
Es ist total bekloppt.
Okay, nachdem wir dich jetzt auf dem Bildschirm haben, wenn du schon kein Eis hast, hast du zumindest ein Schokolade hier.
Darüber habe ich ehrlich gesagt auch gerade eben...
Klauen wir einfach was von Holgis Geschenken jetzt hier mal.
Was?
Schoki.
Ich gucke gleich nochmal, weil ich glaube, ich habe nichts. Oder ich müsste einen etwas längeren Weg antreten.
Nee, deinen Kindern wollen wir dich auch nicht klauen.
Cloud, mobile, was in aller Welt.
Warum gibt es eigentlich nur Coal Pizza und Coal Inner und Coal Tadala und kein Coal Chocolate?
Es gibt so auch Food-Versender, die bringen dir auch gerne noch die Schoki dazu. Ich hab das ehrlich gesagt auch noch nicht gesehen und irgendwie erscheint mir das cool.
Ist das jetzt irgendwas Neues?
Das steht ein Android-Ding drauf. Da ist ein Android-Figur drauf.
Ja, die haben jetzt halt sich da mit Nestle einen fetten Deal halt gemacht und haben irgendwie Android Kit-Kat-Release da halt mit rein geheiratet.
Ich glaube, das ist dann auch schon... Android Kit-Kat.
Also es ist halt so, da wird halt keiner verklagt oder so, sondern die haben da...
Nicht so wie Microsoft und Metro, sondern irgendwie, ja, komm, wir machen noch was.
Google hat wahrscheinlich einfach gesagt, pass mal auf, wir schicken euren 300 Nasen bei Nestle in der Schweiz, schicken wir einfach mal jeder so ein scheiß Telefon und dafür haltet ihr die Schnauze oder so.
Was kommt dann als nächstes? Android 4.5 Flutschfinger?
Brauner Bär.
Apple-Contact mit iOS, 8-Cornetto.
Ed von Schleck.
Ed von Schleck. Ja und jetzt erwähnt noch mehr von dem Zeug, von dem Tim alles nix da hat. Ja wie gesagt, sonst NSFW-Post plündern.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob es sonst irgendwelche News zu Android gibt, aber dieses komische Markencross über irgendwas hängen.
Aber immerhin, das wird genau dieselben Pappnasen wie ich, die von gesagt haben, warte mal, das kann man doch nicht machen, die zuhnen sich doch gegenseitig den Arsch ab. Aber genau da haben sie sozusagen vorher gesehen, haben einfach gesagt, Silbert, drehen da mal irgendwie nur das 10 Nummer draus, ist auch okay. Jetzt wird sie mir nicht irgendwelche Lakritze anbieten oder so oder?
Ich nehm welche.
Spitzer macht Spitzer.
Spitzer macht Spitzer. Also ich hab, das ist mir mal von so einem Lakritz-Freak zugeschickt worden.
Lakritz-Freak klingt gut.
Hier sind Freaks auf beiden Seiten. Das sind irgendwie Anis, bio-organische Anis, Bollchen, das auch. Und das hier ist irgendwie noch...
Anis-Bollchen.
Hast du wirklich sehr schön die Tonung gewählt. Grünen-Ball, wie sagst du?
Okay, wenn hätte ich gedacht, das ist so ein lustiges Lied.
Na dann lass sie mich mal probieren hier.
Das ist Lakritz.
Pure Drop mit Ketchup. Sonder doof. Ich versuch kein Holländisch auszusprechen, das gibt mir Ärger.
Oh, enthält Lakritz.
Danach schmeck ich das Bier nicht mehr, oder?
Das ist schon eine Delikatesse, finde ich.
Ohne Hinzufügung von Zucker.
Ja, nichts für Freunde der gedeckten Geschmäcker, aber wie gedeckt man den Geschmack? Also ist schon ordentlich auf der Knospel.
Naja, ist ein Performant, also hat Umdrehungen.
Ich stehe gar nicht auf Lakritz.
Jetzt bringe dienst.de Das musst du mal probieren.
Das ist schon ganz anders als normale Lakritze. Ich will jetzt meinen Biergenuss nicht gefährden.
Bringe dienst.de, gucken was hier so geht an der Lakritze, Pastillen, Minze. Was ist denn die Postleitzahl? Jetzt gucke ich, ob es hier unten fucking Bringe dienst.de gibt, der nicht nur Inder hat oder Pizza.
Was, du willst jetzt Schoki bestellen oder was?
Scheiß drauf, du kannst bei Joey's, kannst du glaube ich hegen, dass ab einem Mindestbestellwert schicken lassen. Gut, Android News abgehakt.
Weiß nicht, mehr gibt es da nicht zu erzählen. Ist denn irgendwas neu, außer dass es KitKat heißt?
Ja, die Versionsnummer. Keine Ahnung, ich habe sonst nichts drüber gehört.
Jetzt erzählen sie nochmal die ganze Geschichte mit dem ganzen Süßkram.
Das sind alles Süßkrams.
Mit Android KitKat möchten wir allen eine hervorragende Android-Erfahrung bieten. Meldet sie, geben sie uns Daten.
Ja, überzeugt mich das nicht. Eine hervorragende Android-Erfahrung.
Ist jetzt vielleicht nicht so der vom Stuhlhauer, aber ist auf jeden Fall schon mal, okay. Also, wenn es da wirklich so ein Knusper-Keks gibt in Android-Form.
Ja, aber was ist denn jetzt bitte das Neue?
Es gibt jetzt diesen Keks in Android-Form.
Look for specially branded KitKart Bars in the store near you. Sie verkaufen jetzt sozusagen auch diesen Android-Roboter als Schoko-Waffe.
Och, das fände ich auch mal ganz schnuffig.
Nee, ist immer noch eckig.
Neue, süße Verlockungen. Ja, aber was ist denn nun bitte das Neue?
Ja gut, also es scheint noch keine Details zu geben.
Also man weiß jetzt, wie es schmeckt, aber man weiß nicht, was drin ist oder was. Das ist ja auch mal was.
Naja, wusstest du doch vorher auch nicht.
Ich hatte jetzt neulich schon mich geoutet, dass mir jetzt auch so ein Ding dazugelegt hatte, weil es nämlich billig war und Dual-SIM konnte. Was? Nee, ein Android-Phone. Ach. Ja, ist halt so ganz gut für, wenn man so irgendwie in der Weltgeschichte rumturnt. Und ich bin aber... Es gibt so ein paar grundsätzliche Sachen, die ich echt irgendwie kriege immer die Hasskapp auf. Du kannst dieses Ding nicht anfassen, ohne dass es irgendwie losgeht, irgendwas macht. Du nimmst es aus der Tasche und bist mitten schon im Emergency-Dialer. Ja, vom Prinzip hast du schon fast das SEK am Telefon, die in jeder, eine Sekunde später durch dein Fenster springen wollt, weil es immer irgendwie irgendwas macht. Das total empfindlichte Ding geht dauernd an und man vertippt sich dauernd drauf. Also diese berühmte Tippgenauigkeit oder Präzision des Touchpads merkst du wirklich deutlich den Unterschied.
Ich bin ja froh, dass es überhaupt angeht. Wenn ich mal hier dieses Teil vom Strom nehme und mal zwei Tage so rumliege, unbenutzt, dann hat sich das einfach entladen.
Aber wie gesagt, ich hab so ein, zwei Applikationen drauf, die es leider nicht gibt für das iPhone und damit spiele ich hier noch ganz gerne mal rum. Ein schöner Open-Street-Map, eine wirklich sehr, sehr schöne Open-Street-Map-Applikation, die heißt OSM-AND, kann ich ja mal ein bisschen pluggen. Gibt es als free und auch als paid und so. Und das macht dann auch ganz nett Spaß. Was ich übrigens nicht verstehe, gibt es hier irgendwelche Android-Entwickler unter uns oder Leute, die marginal eine Ahnung davon haben? Nein, ne?
Wie unter uns, unter uns und führen.
Ja, hier, oder irgendjemand, der das mal angefasst hat. Also eine Sache, die mir zum Beispiel extrem aufgefallen ist, das verstehe ich echt nicht. Der Ding hat ja auch so ein GPS-Teilchen drin und macht auch so ein bisschen Assisted GPS und so was. Es braucht A, braucht es ewig, bis es mal irgendwie einen Log hat. Mit oder ohne SIM-Karte oder Wi-Fi ist scheißegal. Es braucht ewig. Und du verlässt die Applikation nur für eine Sekunde, um mal irgendwas zu gucken, weil es irgendwie Pling gemacht hat. Du guckst, ob du jetzt eine neue Mail hast, gehst in die Applikation zurück und die sagt, ja, warte mal, ich werf mal meinen GPS an, ich hab schon null von zehn Satelliten. Und du denkst so, äh, was? Du hattest doch vor zwei Sekunden noch, wusstest du doch noch, wo du warst. Oder du schaltest zum Beispiel von Google Maps, was jetzt mühsam deine Location ermittelt hat, schaltest es um auf eine andere Applikation, die die Position haben will, und dann fängt das Scheißteil wieder von vorne an.
Wie das macht nicht das OS?
Ich mach den Eindruck, als würde jeder, es macht den nochmal, ich entwickele dafür nicht, aber deswegen frage ich, es macht den Eindruck, als würde jede Applikation, die mit Location zu tun hat, selber mit dem GPS-Steinchen sprechen. Und sobald sie diese Applikation verlässt, macht die den noch aus. Was auf der anderen Seite auch Sinn macht, weil der Ding ist ja stromverbrauchsmäßig teuer. Aber wenn du umschweißt von einer ab auf die nächste, dann fängt der wieder von vorne an, mit Satelliten acquiring und so. Und du denkst so, äh? Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Ich kann dir das aber live vorführen. Vielleicht gibt es ja hier Leute, die das in den Kommentaren oder dem Chat bestiegen können.
Oder Android-Speaching, da gibt es immer Kommentare.
Oder Leute, die einfach sagen, das musst du sein, du bist bloß doof, dann musst du da und da den Haken setzen oder so. Aber das hat mich zu etwas, finde ich, ein bisschen sehr verwirrend. Ich dachte immer, mein Gott, das soll jetzt die Konkurrenz sein. Wäre ja mal gut, wenn es endlich mal eine ordentliche Konkurrenz gibt, die Apple mal ein bisschen das Wasser erreicht. Aber so nicht, Freunde, so nicht.
Nee, so einfach ist es nicht.
Aber okay, jetzt schalten sie bitte zurück auf das Themenfenster.
Das Themenfenster. Na, das Themenfenster sagt, ich will nicht mehr angeguckt werden.
Das stand jetzt KitKat. Und eine Uhr.
Genau, und jetzt so eine richtig neue Telefone gibt es ja jetzt von Google nicht. Ich meine, die haben ja dieses komische Nexus Hass nicht gesehen von Motorola. Vorgestellt, gibt es das schon? Das ist auch immer alles so merkwürdig.
Wir müssen Max zurückholen. Der hat sich noch so ein bisschen damit beschäftigt.
Max sitzt jetzt wahrscheinlich schon und spielt mit seiner Smartwatch Galaxy Gear, die jetzt neu auf der IFA vorgestellt wird.
Hallo, ich war im Wald.
Max hat geheiratet. Das hat andere Sachen zu tun. Der sitzt jetzt wahrscheinlich gerade nicht mit seinem Smartwatch Galaxy Gear rum. Ich hab das nur so gesagt.
Da hat er halt viel Android rum probiert.
Ich verstehe.
Ja, er hat es angefasst, benutzt und manchmal auch gebocht.
Der war der einzige, der hier Android aufgeschlossen war.
Das ist Max, wenn man ihn mal braucht. Heißt der jetzt wirklich von Weber? Webel. Webel, oder ist der wirklich? Ist jetzt nicht bloß so ein Quack bei Twitter rein. Der heißt jetzt so. Das hat er ja angedroht, dass er den Namen seiner Frau annimmt. Jetzt ist er von.
Das muss man schon ganz anders...
Über ihn ist er.
Der Maximilian.
Hat jetzt sozusagen in den Hochadel reingeheiratet. So kann man es auch machen. Manche machen es mit erfolgreichen Apps. Manche heiraten sich einfach hoch.
Max, gratuliere.
Aber er schreibt ja auch noch coole Apps. Also ich meine von daher, der Typ ist einfach perfekt.
Aber schon vergeben, Tim.
Alles Gute hier aus dem Studio.
Winke-Winke.
Genau, Winke-Winke.
Aus dem Freak-Zentrum. Wir stehen dir bei. Und wer skippst die iWatch? Die ist ja hübsch.
Auf der International Freak Ausstellung.
Ist das Ihr Ernst?
Ja, ich glaube, das ist Ihr Ernst.
In diesem Billo-Look da.
Also ich werde ja bei Samsung...
Das zeigt auch noch Regenwetter an.
Das ist halt ein ganz schönes Schiff auf. Wenn du das von der Seite guckst, das sieht aus wie...
Drum. Ja, oh Mann.
Und wenn du den Typ dazu anguckst, wahrscheinlich auch die Pranke von so einem 200kg-Gewichtheber.
Also...
Hier unser total verspieltes Telefon und hier unsere Uhr. Die kann sogar die Uhrzeit anzeigen.
Ich habe bei Samsung so das Gefühl, dass sie inzwischen sogar auf Gerüchte von Apple-Produkten reagieren und schnell noch ihr eigenes rausbringen. Auf die Watch, auf dieses komische Fingerprint-Sensor-Dingens da. Hatten sie doch auch... Oh, jetzt zeigt sie auch noch die...
Eine 1,9-Megapixel-Kamera.
1,9 Megapixel ist ja irgendwie nichts.
Oder? Bluetooth Disconnected, oh Mann.
Zumindest würde Apple nie so ein Pressefoto machen, wo Disconnected steht.
Vielleicht machen wir das auf die Spiegel. Und dann so ein Plastik-Armbändchen.
Das sind wahrscheinlich die IFA-Fotos von so, wir waren schon mal einen Tag vorher da.
Na gut, in Berlin hat es heute...
Die haben halt alle Fehler. Wie sieht denn das aus?
Das ist alles.
Und zwei Kontakte, die durchgehen, wahrscheinlich irgendwie um deinen Puls zu messen oder die Leitfähigkeit deiner Haut oder sowas.
Ich sag's dir, die neue Quarz-Uhr-Generation kommt.
Ja, wer soll das tragen? Guckt uns doch mal an. Hier sind irgendwie acht Arme und keine einzige fucking Uhr dran.
Ja, aber ist ja geil, ja. Vielleicht demnächst so die neue Handytasche ist jetzt einfach die Smartwatch.
Ich glaube, ich hab eher so ein bisschen die Desperation, dass sie jetzt sagen, ach, viel kann man jetzt mit diesem scheiß Telefon nicht mehr machen. Jetzt noch mal größer, noch mal schneller, das muss ja nicht mal was Neues kommen.
Wir tragen ja die Uhr deshalb nicht, weil allein dieser Informationsgewinn Uhrzeit reicht uns nicht, noch das Ding dran zu haben.
Ja gut, bei mir liegt es ein bisschen daran, dass das Armband kaputt ist von der Uhr seit fast 20 Jahren. Und ich nie dazu gekommen bin, es reparieren zu lassen.
Ja, aber hätte mein Telefon nicht die Fähigkeit, die Uhrzeit anzuzeigen, ich glaube das Bedürfnis, die Uhrzeit irgendwie dabei zu haben, habe ich schon. Weil ist dir aufgefallen, dass die Zahl der öffentlichen...
Aber die Telefone sind gerade noch nicht auf der Liste aussterbender Arten.
Nein.
Also was soll jetzt noch mal mit so einer Plastik oder so kommen?
Ich will auf was anderes hinaus. Irgendwoher musst du deine Zeit nehmen. Du hast sowieso dein Telefon dabei. Dein Telefon ist dabei, ist in der Lage, diese Uhrzeit anzuzeigen. Deswegen ist der Nutzen einer Armbanduhr eigentlich nur Schmuck. Und vielleicht ein bisschen Convenience, dass du nicht jedes Mal deinen Scheißteil aus der Hosentasche ziehen musst. Nur um zu wissen, wie spät es ist, weil du das machst du auch häufig am Tag. Wie spät ist denn so? Katschack, da hat man schon so richtig den Zieh-Moment. Und wenn jetzt allerdings dieses Ding um den Arm, was sich ja über Jahrhunderte bewährt hat, oder wie lange gibt es Urnen?
Jahrhunderte ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben.
Wann gibt es Abendband-Uren?
Alles ist 100 sein, ist schon okay.
Taschen-Uren, Taschen-Uren ist fast jetzt auch, sich so ein Ding einfach umzuhängen und Schmuck und so weiter, war ja das, nee, also das hat doch was mit Mode und Hip-Hop und so weiter. Aber es ist egal, nicht in die Geschichte der Uhr gehen, der Arme.
Wenn aber jetzt dieses Ding, von dem manche Leute schon bereit waren, es zu tragen, weil es die Uhrzeit anzeigt und wichtig ist, auch noch andere wichtige Dinge tut, die uns künftig halt so vielleicht wichtig sind.
Wie dir die Mondphase anzeigen.
Na, es gibt so bestimmte Funktionen von meinem Telefon, da muss ich nicht unbedingt jetzt immer, da würde es mir durchaus auch ausreichen, auf sowas zu schauen.
Wie viele Notifications du auf Twitter hast und so.
Notifications sind nicht so eine gute Anwendung dafür, aber alles, was so ein bisschen Dashboard-Charakter hat. So das Wetter.
Wie oft guckst du nach dem Wetter?
Häufig.
So häufig wie oft eine Uhrzeit?
Nein.
Zu manchen Uhrzeiten gucke ich mehr. Was musst du den Kindern anziehen? Wie wird der Tag heute? Das ist schon tägliche Info.
Ja, das mache ich aber eigentlich auch fast täglich morgens.
Ja, täglich morgens, einmal. Aber nicht den ganzen Tag, wie du auf deinen Urdo guckst.
Ja, ich schaue schon mehrere. Je nachdem, wenn es ein schöner Tag ist, und der ist halt einfach schön und bleibt auch schön, und man sieht ihm auch an, dass er schön bleibt, dann will man sich den Tag nicht von der kaputten Wetter abvermiesen lassen. Mehr Wolken, weniger Wolken.
Wenn es ein Device gibt, was nur den Regenradar anzeigt, aber das auch gut, würde ich mir um das Handgelenk binden, so fern es umpasst.
Genau, Regenradar. Insbesondere in diesen... Es gibt auch in Amerika die Updates, die es bei uns nicht gibt, die das so richtig auf die Minute vorhersagt für deinen Standort, wann es da anfängt zu regnen. Ich hab vergessen, wie das Teil heißt. Gibt es leider immer noch nicht für Europa.
Weil dann die Daten nicht rankommen.
Wir hatten das schon mal besprochen, diese Weather-Ups oder so. Ich hatte das schon mehrfach.
Ich wollte jetzt aber eher auf die Nützlichkeit von so einem Ding. Also wann ändert sich dieser Acceptance-Faktor? Natürlich tragen die Leute jetzt sowas noch nicht. Aber sie sind ja auch bereit, etwas zu tragen, was sie vorher nicht getragen haben. So wie sie vor 20 Jahren bereit waren, anzufangen, Telefone mit sich herumzutragen, was sie ja so vorher auch nicht getan haben.
Guck ihn an, er trägt sogar Bänder von Veranstaltungen, die längst vorbei sind.
Ja, und einige von den Künstlichen Veranstaltungen.
Wenn das mal outdated ist, die Information, die da drauf ist.
Ja, es hat andere Gründe. Damit versuche ich, jugendlich rüberzukommen. Ich geh auch noch auf Festivals, weißt du?
Man geht schon voll Hacker-Festivals.
Was ist Correct IPv6 konfiguriert auf Wiese? Ich mach mal Abschlussplädoyer. Also das Ding sieht scheiße aus. Das wird nix. Ist auch nur so ein Smartphone-Ergänzung, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Das ist nicht wirklich jetzt ein eigenständiges GSM-funkendes Teil, oder? Das hat kein 3G.
Würde ich aber auch gar nicht wollen, mal ganz ehrlich. Also jetzt mal abgesehen davon, dass ich daran zweifel, wie gut. Klickt mal nochmal zurück bitte.
Da stand mal drunter, in dem Plastik. Klickt mal nochmal zurück. Nochmal.
Und so paar Peppels.
Damit du ihnen doch Dingsen da anschließen kannst.
Ganz ehrlich, wenn das Teil eine gute, weiß ich nicht, Bluetooth oder sonst was Verbindung zum Telefon hält und entsprechend Daten austauscht, dann brauch ich da keinen eigenen GSM-Stein drin. Der würde dann auch nur unnütz Akku fressen.
Und möglichst bitte rumschreit, wenn er sich von seinem Telefon entfernt. Wenn man entweder sein Telefon verliert oder es vergisst oder es einem gerade geklaut wird.
Ja, oder das Telefon schreit, wenn das andere Ding weg ist, damit man es wiederfindet.
Die schreien halt einfach beide, wenn sie getrennt werden.
Also alle Apps, die auf dem Telefon eher so Dashbot-Style was Permanentes anzeigen und diese Information ist gut, und sie sind in der Lage, das auch auf so einem kleinen Display zu machen. Sag mal mal, Apple würde sowas rausbringen und sie hätten quasi so das iPhone 4 320x480 Nee, was war die Auflösung? 320x480 Ja, sowas quasi als Retina, also Hälfte vom iPhone 4, also Viertel der Fläche. Ja, dein iPhone 4?
4S bitte, so viel Zeit muss sein.
So, und das mal geviertelt.
Halt ich für immer noch relativ groß, aber ja, wir kommen so in die...
Ist dann aber nicht 16 zu 9, sondern 4 zu 3. Also hast du Fernseher-Format?
Ja, so diese iPod-Nano-Faktion.
Andere Variante wäre jetzt nicht iPhone 4, sondern vielleicht sogar iPhone 5 ein Viertel. Also hätten wir 16 zu 9.
Das ist aber zu groß fürs Handgelenk.
Na weiß ich gar nicht, ich habe es schon mal nachgemest.
Also ich glaube, dann ist eher so halt iPod-Nano.
Also das sind 5 cm. 5 cm ist der Bildschirm hoch oder breit. Das wären also so 2,5 x 4,5. Die hälfte jetzt. 4,5 x 2,5. Naja, also 4,5 ist hier die Breite der Bändchen und 2,5 ist auch nicht so viel auf meinem Arm. Wenn man das jetzt relativ ohne viel Timm-Bimm drumherum macht.
So Landscape oder was?
Sehe auf jeden Fall geil aus.
Also ich bin mit dem Uhr- am Handgelenk-Thema echt durch. Hätte ich früher mal bräunig beim Tippen hier überall.
Dashboard, aber Handgelenk. Für Sportler ist das geil.
Aber die kennen sich auch nicht so einen fetten Klumpen an den Armen.
Na klar.
Irgendwie für diese Park-Jogger-Typen.
Die hauen sich das ganze iPhone derzeit an den Armen. Die laufen mit dem ganzen iPhone am Arm rum.
Oder diese übergroßen Android-Telefone, was so behindert ist.
Das sieht richtig aus.
Joggen Sie eigentlich auch mit dem iPad? Nur mit dem Microsoft Surface, aber nur mit dem ursprünglichen.
Das Pro.
Nein, das richtige Surface, das Ur-Surface. Dieser Tisch, dieser Küchentisch.
Das ist kein Küchentisch, das ist ein Koffietisch.
Joggen für Möbelpacker.
Und wie gesagt, für Tänzer ohne Hinterboden.
Die Leute laufen jetzt auch schon mit dem Nano rum. Der hat ja auch in etwa so eine Bildschirm, sogar noch eine größere Bildschirmfläche. Also, keine Ahnung. Vielleicht bring ich doch nur ein Armband raus, wo man ein Nano reinstecken kann. Und der wird dann als Interface für den Dings benutzt. Eigentlich haben sie das ja alles schon. Wie auch immer. Also, wir finden dieses Urteil jetzt nicht sonderlich interessant, oder was?
Das Spiegelding ist natürlich schon urig, aber...
Pedometer und sowas.
Ja, ist klar, das sehe ich. Was?
Pedometer? Pedofilometer?
Nein.
Die Spiegelding spielt auch noch sklar.
Hässliche Fotos mit schlechter Farbgebung.
Spannend. Nix mehr los in der IT-Szene hier.
Ansonsten hat sich mal wehmäßig auf jeden Fall noch nicht so viel getan. Da ist Android auf jeden Fall noch der totale Marktführer.
Ja, aber das ist doch auch eine alte Statistik.
Wie hier?
Ja, seit 2012 steht direkt über...
2013 ist ja auch noch nicht so ganz vorbei, oder?
Dieses Jahr alles total anders? Das ist eine Sommerlochmeldung.
Sommerlochmeldung.
Wir waren doch gerade bei der IFA. Wollen wir mit dem Thema weitermachen? You don't care?
Dann mach doch was wie...
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie sich dein Thema zu dem Thema verhält.
Das leite ich denn über. Leite mich mal über hier. Worauf Tim hinaus will, ist... Und da ich jetzt eh schon angefeindet werde dafür, dass ich hier das Wort Fritzbox auf jeden Mund nehme, nehme ich heute noch mal extra. Die Firma AVM hat einen neuen Router mal wieder auf den Markt geschmissen. Den hab ich auch schon mal in den Fingern gehabt.
Der überraschenderweise Fritzbox heißt. Lass mich mal abdenken.
Aber der heißt 7490. Witzigerweise ist, er sieht auf den Bildern, wenn man mal guckt, sieht er genauso aus wie die alten Dinger. Er ist aber in der Tat ein Müh größer. Ich würde sagen, das ist 15% größer, wenn man sie nebeneinander legt. Aber die haben das ganze Design einfach sozusagen in ihr Photoshop gezogen und haben gesagt, mach mal 115% raus und dann haben sie das wieder ausgedruckt.
Unglaublich.
Sieht genauso aus, die Boxen haben natürlich noch die selbe Größe wie vorher, ist klar. Aber ansonsten, das wär ein bisschen peinlich gewesen.
Ritz Box Bloat.
Naja, ein neues Gigabit Internet macht 1,15 Gigabit.
Der spannende Teil daran ist hauptsächlich, wie gesagt, das Ding ist innen drin schneller. Etliche haben auch nochmal neu...
Was ist denn da überhaupt für ein Stein drin?
Ganz ehrlich gesagt, hab ich nicht aufgemacht. Aber vielleicht mach ich das einfach mal. Ich kann es dir nicht sagen. Sie haben jetzt da was gewechselt. Das ist eine andere Plattform. AVM experimentiert ja schon seit einiger Zeit auch mit der Hardware-Beschleunigung. Das haben sie schon in der 7390 gemacht.
Hardware-Beschleunigung, wovon?
Für normales Packet-Transfer, so zwischen Chichellen hin und rein und raus.
Also wieder so Switches machen.
Oder auch Router machen halt, dass sie den einfachen Sachen wie ein IP-Paket im selben TCP-Strom, den ich schon seit 2 Stunden kenne, einfach links und rechts das in Hardware machen. Sie haben ein neues DSL-Steinchen reingemacht. Hab aber bisher nur festgestellt, dass es da noch Sachen gibt, die er noch nicht kann, was eine 7390 schon kann. Aber das wird sich sicherlich geben. In dem Zusammenhang kann man vielleicht erwähnen, dass AVM auch eine neue Labor-Release rausgegeben hat von ihrer Software. Und man sieht es auch hier, wenn du bei Highlights auf einen Blick guckst, mit Vectoring-Unterstützung. Das heißt, es gibt jetzt VDSL schon mit Vectoring-Support für die 7390, denn ein altes VDSL-Modell, alt. Aber die bisherige Flaggschiff und die 7490 machen halt immer schon Vectoring. Mips-Prozessoren. Diese ganze DSL-Käfer ist ja wie Alde, was man heute so hat. Das ist einfach nur ein High-End-DSP, wo du halt den ganzen Quack hinten in Software machst. Per Software-Upgrade kann man also bei der 7390 und bei der 7490 Vectoring nachrüsten, wenn denn die Telekom, wie ihr so gerade eben kürzlich von der EU versprochen und von der Regelungsbehörde abgenickt, die Telekom jetzt anfangen darf, oder andere eben auch, wenn sie da Bock drauf haben, mal in Deutschland ein bisschen mit Vectoring zu spielen.
Ach, das ist von heute die Version?
Das ist ein neues Labor, nee, das war schon das Labor von vor 14 Tagen, oder das hab ich schon noch, bevor ich da in Schweden war.
Aber es gibt gerade heute wieder eine neue?
Ja, die Labor-Dinger kommen so alle 14 Tage ungefähr. Da sind auch ein paar andere Spielchen dabei, da könnte man sich jetzt eine Weile drüber unterhalten, muss man aber nicht. Das ist ganz nett, die Labor-Version, wer damit spielen mag, kann das durchaus mal machen. Die sind auch stabil genug. Die sind also jetzt nicht so, dass wir die jetzt kreuz und quer kaputt machen. Also wer ein Gerät hat, es gibt die Labor-Version nicht für alle Fritzbox-Arten, aber wer so eine hat, da kann man doch erstmal ein Labor drauf machen. Die bringen regelmäßig auch immer wieder neue Feature, auch jahrelang noch. Das finde ich übrigens auch sehr nett.
Dass sie jetzt nicht bloß Backfixes nachschmeißen, sondern dass sie echt noch richtig Zeug damit reinmachen.
Unter anderem auch das Anfang des Jahres mal erwähnte Lisp, wo jetzt nur viele Leute ziemlich geil drauf sind. Ich habe ja auch sehr viel Feedback dazu bekommen und auch Leute, die da was spielen wollten mit. Es gibt ein kleines Problem bei Lisp inzwischen. Im Rahmen seiner Standardisierung ist es auch Leuten in die Hände gefallen, die das jetzt gerade erstmal so ein bisschen lähmen.
Kannst du vielleicht noch mal kurz umreißen für Leute, die jetzt in der Diskussion nicht drin sind, was Lisp genau tut?
Ne, das kann ich nicht kurz umreißen. Ich kann aber kurz umreißen, wofür ich das anfangs mal beworben hatte, weil die Idee da mal drinsteckt, nämlich dass man mehrere Verbindungen, die man hat, bündeln kann. Das ist nur ein Teilaspekt von Lisp. Aber das ist eine Sache, die sehr, sehr viele Leute interessiert. Zumindest wenn man so nach Kommentaren und Tweets gehen kann, dass es einfach genügend arme Schweine gibt in Deutschland, die bloß sehr, sehr lahme DSL-Anschlüsse haben und sich dann sagen, fuck it, ich kauf mir einfach mehrere davon. Weil dreimal 6 Megabit macht auch 18 Megabit. Und dass da aber immer noch Lösungen für gesucht werden, wie man das dann auch vernünftig nutzt. Und ich bin auch so ein bisschen in Kontakt mit dieser Standardisierungstruppe und mit dem Betatrupp da von diesen List-Leuten, hab die jetzt mal vor ein paar Wochen richtig schwer angemalt, weil die jetzt nämlich anfangen oder Leute anfangen, das so zu implementieren, dass sie halt eben genau diese Feature nicht mehr vernünftig haben. Oder mehrere Datenpfade richtig auszunutzen. Ganz konkret, ich kann es mal in zwei Sätzen sagen, was die machen. Die Idee ist, wenn du jetzt mehrere gleichwertige Datenpfade hast und du möchtest jetzt gerne einen Faltransfer darum haben, nimm mal, du hast jetzt drei DSL-Anschlüsse A6-Megabit und möchtest jetzt trotzdem gerne ein Download mit 18 Megabit machen, dann musst du irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass dein Datenverkehr regelmäßig über diese drei Dinger verteilt wird, gleichmäßig. Und genau das tun derzeitig aktuelle Implementationen aus irgendwelchen fiesen dummen Performancegründen nicht. Sie sahen sich nämlich, wir haben hier eine Beziehung zwischen einem Server und einem Client, sorgen wir mal dafür, dass es immer nur über eins von diesen drei Dingern geht.
Die verteilen nicht die Traffic, sondern die verteilen nur die Verbindung.
Du könntest dreimal Downloads laufen lassen, die dann in Summe 18 Megabit geben, aber eben nicht einen, der dir 18 Megabit gibt. Wo wir jetzt all die armen Leute, die eben dieses Problem haben, jetzt komplett in die Röhre gucken. Ich hab die da auch schwer für angemalt und hab auch Unterstützung gekriegt, aber auch andere Leute, die wieder sagen, ja, dann können wir jetzt wieder nicht in unser Hardware beschleunigen, ne, und all so ein Scheiß. Ich bin gerade so ein bisschen genervt von dieser Lisp-Nummer, weil die das gerade kaputt machen. Es ist eine der Hauptideen, die man dort hat. Oder die hier interessant sind, für die lokale Szene zu müssen, also die Internet-Bandbreiten geschädigten hier. Ja, aber wie gesagt, nichtsdestotrotz, AVM spielt auch mit in der Lisp-Truppe. Die machen das derzeit, allerdings, da sie in einer Kiste, in einer Fritz-Box ja auch nur eine DSL-Leitung derzeit reinstecken kannst, machen die das hauptsächlich dafür, so für so eine Art intelligentes Multi-Point-VPN. Also du hast eine Firma mit 20 Filialen oder sowas und möchtest da was Vernünftiges mit machen, dafür ist das immer noch gut. Und auch, um zum Beispiel V4 oder V6 zu machen, also so Pseudo-VPN-Geschichten mit V4, V6 und so, da kann man eine ganze Menge mit machen. Die sind auch sehr aktiv da eigentlich, die Lisp-Leute, also die AVM-Leute bei Lisp. Deswegen, ja, keine Ahnung.
Ah, aber es gibt auch irgendwie ein VPN-Einrichtungstour jetzt?
Ja, auf der Kiste drauf. Du musstest bisher, wenn du VPNs einrichtest auf einer Fritz-Box, musstest du ja immer eine sehr, sehr hohe Motivation. Eigentlich hat sich AVM so gedacht, dass du eine sehr, sehr schmuddelige Windows-Applikation runterlädst. AVM ist ein ganz fieser Windows-Shop, muss man mal dazu sagen. Die haben echt irgendwie einen Hass auf Apple. Obwohl sie eine Abteilung haben, die jetzt hier so iPhone-Apps macht oder so was. Aber die haben sie wahrscheinlich im anderen Gebäude oder im Keller oder so was angesiedelt, weiß ich nicht. Es macht manchmal so ein bisschen den Eindruck.
Genau, das habe ich jetzt gezeigt.
Inzwischen haben sie aber erkannt, dass es eben Leute gibt, die kein Bock haben, eine Windows-App runterzuladen, nur um ihren Router zu konfigurieren. Es diverse Leute, die dir Zip-Trunking anmieten. Jetzt weniger für Privatleute, aber gibt's von Zipgate, gibt's von Plattetale, von... Was auch immer dir der Provider über den Trunk rüber ruht. Das kann ein Set von einzelnen Nummern sein, das können durchwahlfähige Rufnummern sein, das kann Albumöche sein.
Das wäre mal geil, mal wieder eine richtig schöne Durchwahl zu haben.
Kannste haben. Für dich und dann noch für dich. Und dann möchtest du vielleicht noch einen Durchwahl für Tim haben? Meinst du, bei deiner hohen Mitarbeiteranzahl hier wäre es mal nötig, dass der mal einzelne Durchwahl hat oder wie?
Nee, ich brauche hier tatsächlich mal ein flexibleres Schema, dass ich so eine Nummer habe, wie während einer Sendung klingelt das Telefon, während einer Sendung klingelt das Telefon nicht. Also verschiedene Prioritätslevel und irgendwie diese Nummer, bla, anrufbar.
Kein Problem, kann ich dir mal offline gerne in drei Minuten erzählen, das ist relativ easy. Gibt es auch günstige Hersteller, Anbieter für die Zeugs, mit einem Schnick und einem Schnack. Das funktioniert auch sehr gut. Ich hab in letzter Zeit viele Fritzboxen mit SIP-Kreuz und Quervernetzt.
Da kann man verschiedene SIP-Klines irgendwie ranhängen zum Testen und so. Das ist halt immer dieses Problem, wenn man nur eine Nummer hat und dann für die nächste Nummer so ihre E-Mail-Adresse schon... Gibt es jetzt nicht kostenlos, musst du zahlen...
Da gibt es jede Menge Möglichkeiten, an Rufnummern noch ranzukommen und damit zu spielen.
Aber was ist jetzt der eigentliche Vorteil von dieser 7490 Fritzbox, die ist jetzt nur schneller, aber die kann auch irgendwie besseres WLAN?
Ja, sie hat einen AC-WLAN, 802.fac.
Also das, was jetzt auch die neuen Airs zum Beispiel haben.
Und was die neuen Airport-Extremes haben, diese kleinen Minitower und so was. Brieft das fast? Ja, nein, ja, nein. Also für Leute, die nur eine Fritzbox zu Hause haben und damit nur ins Internet gehen, selbst mit VDSL und selbst mit Vectoring, bringt dir das eigentlich kaum was, weil du willst jetzt mit einem WLAN, mit einem Gigabit durch deine Wohnung funken, wenn das am Ende des Tages doch bloß mit 50 oder 16 Megabit aus deinem Haus rausroppelt. Das ist albern. Es macht für die Leute Sinn, die irgendwie nass betreiben zu Hause, die also irgendwie einen Storage da haben, wo sie jetzt ihre Backups auch drauf fahren oder sowas, da kann man das ausspielen. Deswegen hat die auch, übrigens auch für die 7390, eben auch 4 Gigabit Ports.
Aber der Teil ist jetzt nicht neu, sondern nur der.
Also da macht das ein bisschen Sinn, das zu tun. Es gibt noch einen anderen Grund, warum man AC haben will. Mit AC hat man... Das ist jetzt nicht bloß, wir senden jetzt Bits schneller, oder wir machen das jetzt irgendwie auf 5 Gigahertz oder sonst irgendwas, sondern da sind auch andere Techniken drin.
Dieses Beamforming auch?
Genau, zum Beispiel. Die sozusagen eine höhere Reichweite versprechen, wovon auch normale Geräte was abkriegen. Hatten wir nicht Beamforming schon mal gesprochen?
Das kann sein, als wenn wir die Extrems gesprochen haben. Aber ich frage mich, wie die das in diesem Gehäuse machen. Haben die wirklich diese Antennen an diesen grumpelten Haiflischlossen drin? Die sind so überfällig.
Ja, das ist wirklich überfällig. Ich habe eine 7490 noch nicht aufgemacht, aber ich kann es gerne mal machen. Du wolltest ja eh die LTE-Fritzbox haben, dann bringe ich dir die mal mit und dann schrauben wir mal die 7490 auf. Aber eigentlich müssten die so üblich sein, aber es sind so drei Antennen. Sonst macht das nämlich keinen Spaß und das würde jetzt keinen Sinn machen, weil das Ding wo es zwei Haiflischlossen hat. Oder sie haben die dritte Antenne in einer anderen Polarität flach hingelegt. Das macht aber eigentlich nur Sinn, bei drei und mehr Antennen damit zu spielen. Aber ich muss sie mal aufmachen. Ansonsten ist das Ding schneller und höher weiter. Sie haben jetzt USB 3.0, fuck yeah. Es ist dann spannend, wenn du das Ding als NAS benutzen kannst. Du kannst ja einfach eine Platte an das Ding dranstecken und dann ist das ein relativ akzeptabler SMB-File-Server. Da wird es dann schon wie eine ordentliche Platte dran tun. Dann macht es auch wieder Spaß mit dem Gigabit. Sobald du so etwas betreibst, entweder in der Kiste drin oder in Externet, dann macht es auch Sinn, innerhalb des Hauses mit ein paar Gigabit um sich zu schlagen. Ansonsten ist es Software-Funktionalität wie bei der 7390. Ja, die kommen noch. Gib ihnen mal noch ein bisschen Zeit. Sie haben das Licht schon gesehen, aber es ist wie gesagt ein Windows-Shop. Welches Licht ist es meistens? Sie haben schon erkannt, dass es auch durchaus Apple-User gibt, die ihr Zeug benutzen. Wenn man genauer hinschaut, wird man vielleicht feststellen, dass sogar ein Gutteil der Leute, die sich so eine teure Fritzbox kaufen, auch Apple-User sind.
Nicht, dass die Leute schockiert sind am Ende.
Weil der gemeine Windows-User ist ja auch eigentlich eher so ein Sparbrötchen. Und der nimmt dann halt eben statt einer teuren Fritzbox auch lieber mal den Netgehr-Router für 25 Euro aus dem Media-Markt.
Das hat mich immer schon am meisten gestört.
Ja, und jetzt kommen jetzt die Hate-Mail-Best-Arts-Compte. Natürlich sind nicht alle Windows-User Sparbrötchen, aber alle Sparbrötchen sind Windows-User.
Alle Windows-User sind Sparbrötchen.
Alle Freiwilligen.
Kommt doch her.
Jetzt die Überleitung. Es gibt noch ein paar andere Spielchen für die Leute, die gerne mal die eine Fritzbox haben, damit gerne spielen wollen. Für die Nerds jetzt mal. Manche wissen das schon, manche entdecken das, aber auch erst, wenn man es wirklich braucht. Die Fritzbox hat einen eingebauten Packet-Capture. Das ist für mich sehr nützlich, benutze ich andauernd. Das heißt, man kann über eine Seite, die es dort gibt, die ist nicht verlinkt auf der Oberfläche, sondern man muss sie direkt ansteuern, muss also auf seine Fritzbox gehen und dann oben slash HTML slash capture.html eingeben. Und dann kommt man dorthin, wo man eine Fritzbox, wo man sagen kann, schnüffelt doch mal hier auf dem WLAN rum oder zeigt mir doch mal, was jetzt alles über das DSL rausgeht und reingeht. Damit kann man eine ganze Menge Sachen sehr ordentlich debuggen. Sie haben auch inzwischen eine iPerf-Gegenstelle eingebaut. Das heißt, wer also jetzt die Performance messen möchte in seinem LAN oder in seinem WLAN oder sowas, kann das mit dem Capture sagen. capture.html jetzt da hinten dran. Nicht? Nicht Kaputcha? So, dann lock sich jetzt nochmal bitte ein.
Fritzbox-Paket-Mitschnitt.
So, und jetzt kannst du da schön, man kann sogar für die Leute, die das noch lesen können, wenn du weiter runter scrollst und einen ISDN-Anschluss hast, kannst du sogar auf dem D-Kanal rumdresen. Du kannst auf den USB-Anschlüssen dresen.
Das ist schon ganz cool.
Das Ding schreibt dann schöne PCAP-Files, die du dir in deinem Wire schreibst.
Man kann den ISDN-D-Kanal dresen?
Unten hast du einen ISDN-Anschluss dran?
Ähm, ja.
Und es hat sogar einen eingebauten Text-Decoder drin, kannst du die auch abspeichern und so. Du kannst den USB-Schnitt stellen, kannst du auch mitdresen.
Aber womit kann man den ISDN-D-Kanal gut visualisieren?
Theoretisch könnte man das auch mit dem Wireshark lesen. Der kann Q931 und Q921. Aber der Wireshark kann nicht bloß Ethernet, der Wireshark kann auch USB. Wenn du da oben einen USB-Trace machst und was dranhängst, kannst du auch eine Datei erzeugen, die du in den Wireshark reinlädst. Dann siehst du, was deine Fritz Box sich per USB mit einem Gerät unterhält. Das finde ich, wie gesagt, ich nutze das sehr, sehr häufig, um irgendwelche Probleme zu debuggen, weil ich habe längst aufgegeben, irgendwelchen Applikationen zu trauen, was sie in ihre eigenen Log-Files reinschreiben. Ja, cannot reach server. Und sowas willst du gar nicht so genau wissen manchmal. Dann gehe ich lieber mit dem Wireshark drauf und gucke mir jetzt an, was passiert jetzt eigentlich wirklich. Versucht sie überhaupt einen Connect oder ist sie bloß zu blöd, den Namen aufzulösen oder wie auch immer. Viele Applikationen sagen ja, nur noch ein Fehler ist aufgetreten. Ein teiligeres Dokument, es wurde möglicherweise gedruckt.
Und da ist halt so was eben ein Abbruch, hast du vergessen.
Meistens gibt es einen Unterschied, wenn man einem alten EWSD-ISDN noch dranhängt, versus einem simulierten... Die Kanal-mäßig? Ist alles anders?
Aber wenn du mal wirklich reinguckst, es werden viel mehr Informationen, viel genauer ermittelt. Es macht einen großen Unterschied, ob du an so einem NG-Anschluss von Alice oder sonst, in dem man dran hängst oder an einen Telekom-Anschluss.
Meinst du besser? Mehr, genauer?
Mehr genauer. Also ich geb dir mal ein Beispiel. Es gibt ja immer noch diese Leute, die Rufnummern fälschen. Insbesondere in welchen Düsseligen Hotlines, die dich anrufen und so ein Scheiß. Und da gibt es dieses nette Feature, dass man zum Beispiel oder ein ISDN kann, dass er mehrere Rufnummern übermitteln kann. Also ich habe hier heute einen Anruf bekommen von unserer Werbehotline. Die haben anrufen, angeblich von 089 1247 1143 71.
Also irgendwo Bayern.
Ja, aber in Wirklichkeit kam der Call von irgendeinem Callcenter in Mecklenburg-Vorkommern. Also irgendwo aus 038 34, keine Ahnung, wo das sein soll. Wenn du einen ordentlichen ISDN-Ausfluss hast, der dir das mitteilt, oder zum Beispiel einen VoIP-Anschluss von der Telekom, der kann das nämlich auch, weil der ist nämlich auch sauber implementiert, dann siehst du beide Nummern. Dann siehst du nämlich einmal die Nummer, die derjenige dir zeigen will, und einmal die Nummer, die er wirklich hat. Oder was auch sehr nett ist, ein Feature, was ich sehr sehr gerne benutze, ist Kolb. Die Connected Line Presentation. Geht so, du rufst an in einer Behörde die Zentrale, und die stellen dich dann durch auf eine Durchwahl.
Und du weißt nicht wohin.
Nee, das sagen sie dir nicht, aber die ISTN sagt mir das. Das heißt, du hast ja deine Durchwahl, ja. Dann siehst du hinterher, ah, ich bin eigentlich mit dem und dem verbunden gewesen. Also alle noch solche netten Features, die gibt es noch. Also wenn du eine saubere ISTN-Implementation hast, kann man da mit einer ganze Menge Spaß haben. Da könnten wir uns auch noch eine Weile darüber unterhalten, aber das kann man alles machen. Und wenn man damit spielen will, kann man da auch wie gesagt mal so ein Detrace unten anmachen, sich den D-Kanal angucken und dann zum Beispiel mal mit seinem Handy anrufen oder mit einer Rufweiterleitung anrufen. Und was weiß ich... Entschuldigung, das weiß ich nicht alles. Da gibt es eine ganze Menge Sachen, die man da noch sehen kann. Netterweise, wie gesagt, die Fritzbox macht das, weil da nämlich auch noch ein paar verkappte ISTN-Fetischisten rumsitzen, denen ich immer wieder gut zureden muss. Ja, das braucht man noch. Nein, ISTN ist noch nicht tot und so. Aber die... Ne, ernsthaft. Ich schreibe relativ häufig mal so Bugreports, wenn da was kaputt ist und dann höre ich als erstes immer ja, aber das ISTN hat doch eh keiner mehr. Und ich so, doch, halt mal noch ein bisschen durch, mach mal noch mal. Und dann knurr ich mal ein bisschen rum und dann drei Monate später fixe ich das net und doch, was ich net finde, aber es ist irgendwie so, ja. Also da gibt es noch ein bisschen was.
Ich hab so ein bisschen Angst, dass hier so meine alten ISTN-Kodex, die ich hier noch habe, dann irgendwie nicht funktionieren.
Ähm, vermutlich ja. Dass die nicht funktionieren? ISTN ist ja nicht bloß Signalisierung. Deine Codex basieren ja darauf, dass sie sich denken, oh, hier hab ich jetzt ein B-Kanal für mich, eine. Hier hab ich jetzt 64 Kilobit, die sind echt in Realtime meine. Meine ganz alleine.
Richtiges ISTN-Halb.
Das ist nicht mehr dann so. Also die Signalisierung, selbst wenn du jetzt ein gutes Ding dran hast, die Fritzbox kann ja auch als VoIP-Client agieren und wenn du dann zum Beispiel hinten ein ISTN-Gerät anschließt, die Fritzbox hat ja sowohl einen ISTN-Einschluss nach draußen, der sich sozusagen benimmt wie ein Client, zum Telefonnetz hin, als auch einen Einschluss nach innen, der sich benimmt wie ein Server oder wie eine Vermittlungsstelle. Und das ISTN, was sie da implementiert haben, ist auch relativ ordentlich. Aber das nützt ja nichts, wenn der B-Kanal nicht transparent durchgeht, sondern wenn der B-Kanal nur in einen lokalen Codec reinrauscht und der sich dann so sagt, bei deinem komischen 7,7 Kilohertz Audiosignal, was dein Codec da reinballert, der sich dann so sagt, so... Und es gibt keine Standard dafür. Es gibt keinen Standard dafür. Es gibt Leute, die haben sich daran probiert, es gibt auch Hersteller, die sowas machen, wo du dann proprietär zwischen den VoIP-Anlagen von demselben Hersteller diese B-Kanal-Simulation hast. Innovafone zum Beispiel macht sowas und ein paar andere. Aber es gibt keinen Standard dafür, der einfach sagt, ich nehme jetzt mal 160 Bits, die prüge ich per IP rüber und trotz die drüben wieder aus, synchron und so. Das gibt es leider nicht. Ja, ein weites Feld. Das wollte ich noch mal kurz erwähnen. Aber wirklich nur ganz kurz. Mein Gott, ihr habt euch hier über Farben unterhalten. Wer damit spielen will, gibt auch einen iPad-Server. Man kann zum Beispiel mal gucken, wer diese ganzen Spielchen mal eine Übersicht haben will, kann fritz.box.html.support.html mal eingeben. Da kommen noch viel mehr lustige Sachen raus, die man da abspeichern kann. Man kann sich denn da Mails zuschicken lassen mit Reports und dann wird es sich nicht erledigen. Oben, da, wo du das unterhast.
Such gerade mal meine...
irgendwo dachte ich, hätte ich das noch offen gemacht.
Da sagste fritz.box.html.support.html.
Aber wenn die jetzt alle meine URL kennen...
Da hast du ein Problem.
Ich hab das gerade auch in meiner fritz.box rum.
So kannst du also Supportdaten oder DSL-Diagnosen... Das hilft euch nicht. Macht das nicht zu Hause, Leute. Ihr könntet eh nicht lesen, was da rauskommt. DSL-Leitungstest, Paketmitschnitte, da hat man schon Durchsatzmesserungen. Es gibt ja so eine Art Open Source Software, die ganz gut rum ist, womit man so schön Bandbreiten messen kann. Für die Leute, die es ernst meiden, die jetzt nicht glauben, dass speedtest.net ihnen irgendwas sinnvoller anzeigt. Also die Leute, die darüber hinaus sind, die können damit mal ein bisschen experimentieren und dann mal ordentlich messen.
Cool, iPerf, ist das Command Line Proof?
Das ist Command Line Proof. Es gibt sogar iOS-Apps dafür, inzwischen für iPerf. Also all so Zeugs. Und dann gibt es auch noch Zugriff auf die Konsole der Fritzbox. Und dann kannst du da diesen Knopf da unten anmachen. Und dann kannst du gegen deine Fritzbox bitte jetzt nicht während der Sendung, weil so ein iPerf haut kräftig Pakete drauf. Es könnte sein, dass die dann... Ja, also damit kann man auch ein bisschen spielen, wer mag. Das war das.
Nimmt die denn so preislich? Weiß man schon, was das Teil kostet?
74,90. Kost 200 Quik oder sowas. Irgendwo stand das drin. Bei Olem oder bei Heise. Irgendwo stand das drin.
Gucken wir nochmal hier kurz in die heiligen Hallen. 74,90. Was lässt dir eigentlich glauben, dass es irgendwie cool ist, Geräte so zu benennen?
Nokia hat damit 10 Jahre lang Erfolg gehabt. Und Cisco.
Na, ich weiß nicht, ob das...
Na, besser als KitKat, Cupcake, Donut, Jelly Belly.
Man kann da dran was ablesen.
Gemüse nehmen oder so.
Man kann da diese Zahlen ablesen, ob das eine Telefonanlage drin hat oder nicht, ob das WLAN hat oder nicht.
Da gibt's ein Ausrufezeichen-Box.
Ja, das war zu der Zeit, als UCP noch kommen vor war. Weißt du noch, änderst du dich noch? Mail-Adressen nicht mit Ed-Zeichen drin, sondern mit Ausrufezeichen.
Darauf bezieht sich das?
Aber es kommt aus der selben Zeit. Diese ganze Fritz-Marke mit dieser komischen Maus da.
Wer das nachschlagen will, der sogenannte Bang Path. Da war meine E-Mail-Adresse noch irgendwie 50 Zeichen lang.
Jetzt hauen wir den Ball mal rüber zu Roddy. Es gibt nämlich eine Sache, die die Fritz-Box nicht macht, was hingegen aber die supergeilen Speed-Ports röcheln, Home-Router der Telekom machen. Nämlich Mail-Verkehr unterdrücken.
Ich hol kurz aus, und zwar, ähm, meine Schwiegereltern haben so einen üblichen Telekom-Anschluss.
Das sind User, deine User-Schwiegereltern.
Das sind real existierende User, die haben da so einen Anschluss. Mit so einer Box dran, und diese Box, die geriet dann so langsam in Hardware-Probleme.
Das war keine 724V, das war eine 723V.
Keine Ahnung, wie die Box hieß. Ich hab sie zu Hause noch am Schreibtisch zerlegt. Wenn man sie aufmacht, und dann kriegt sie ordentlich Luft, dann tut sie auch so eine Weile. Aber da wird auch an den falschen Stellen verdammt heiß.
Schon ein paar explodierte Echos drin gefunden?
Nee, aber leicht angehoben schon. Der Klassiker. Also, es war klar, da muss jetzt eine neue Box her. Dann haben die bei der Telekom angerufen. Da haben die gesagt, ja, kein Problem hier. Mietmodell, Blar, Box und so weiter. Das in der Post kommt zu ihnen.
Kurze Frage, haben Sie dabei gleich deine Schwiegereltern auch überfahren und Ihnen gleich gesagt, dass dieser tolle IP-Anschluss viel besser ist als alles andere? Weil ich kriege jetzt Reports aus meinem Umfeld, dass die Telekom aggressiv rumgeht und analog und ISTN-Bestandskunden anruft und Ihnen sagt, hier, nehmen Sie doch unser tolle Voice-over-IP-Produkt namens IP, den tollen IP-Anschluss. Und es ist alles so viel toller und viel bunter.
Kann sein, kann ich jetzt nichts zu sagen.
Okay, war nur eine Frage. Kleine Umfrage hier auch an die Leute.
So, und dann kam also diese neue Box an. Die haben das Ding da hingestellt und irgendwie in Betrieb genommen. Da war ich nicht dabei. Es hat auch soweit funktioniert, bis auf, dass sie keine Mails mehr verschicken konnten, aus ihrem Thunderbird heraus. Und zwar irgendwie von beiden Rechnern. Ja, okay, beides ist jetzt ein aules XP, aber wie auch immer, an dem Thunderbird und an dem XP hat sich ja nichts geändert.
Es hat sich ja nur die Box geändert. Die Schwiegereltern waren nicht, wie es sich gehört, ordentliche T-Online-Kunden, sondern bei welchen Provider?
Nee, die waren bei, ich glaube, die waren bei T-Online, also Telekom-Kunden.
Ja, nee, für das IP, sondern Mail.
Für das Mail, nee, das habe ich ihnen bei überspace.de oder uberspace.de eingerichtet, da die eigene Domain und E-Mail-Adresse und all diesen ganzen Kram. Und dann kam also Schwiegermama dann zu uns und hat bei uns ihr Windows-Teil aufgeklappt und siehe da, Thunderbird tat wieder, was es sollte. Empfangen war kein Problem, senden ging zu Hause nicht, bei uns ging es.
How embarrassing.
Und da lag natürlich die Vermutung, naja, es muss an der neuen Box liegen. Dann wollte es aber keiner wahrhaben.
Ich auch nicht.
Und du auch, genau, du auch nicht. Dir hab ich es auch erzählt, du wolltest es auch nicht wahrhaben.
Also was genau ging bei der Mail?
Mail versenden ging nicht. So, und dann bin ich da, dann bin ich da halt, irgendwann waren wir wieder dort, hab ich halt da die, die Oberfläche von diesem Teil da aufgemacht und sehe, da gibt es eine Option unter Internet, die heißt Liste der sicheren E-Mail-Server. Und da war so ein Haken dran. Liste der sicheren E-Mail-Server verwenden. Als Erklärung steht da die Einstellung auf dieser Liste der erlaubten E-Mail-Server. Dann ist da so eine lange Liste, da steht also vor allen Dingen T-Online mit irgendwas drin. Da steht aber dann halt auch ein Gmail steht drin, also ein Google Mail und das steht in web.de. Ein Uberspace steht natürlich nicht drin. Ich hätte ja gedacht, dass sie Pod 25 zumachen oder sowas, aber da in dem Video sieht man es, Liste der sicheren E-Mail-Server gab es da und dann habe ich diesen Haken weggemacht und siehe da, dann funktionierte natürlich alles. Ich war kurz davor, vielleicht noch den Uberspace da irgendwie in die Liste einzutragen, dann dachte ich mir, was ist das eigentlich für ein Blödsinn, mach doch die Scheiße einfach aus. Gute Frage, ich habe da jetzt keinen Screenshot zu gemacht, aber auf jeden Fall ist es nicht nur Port 25, sondern auch einige andere Ports. Du hast es dir mal genau angeguckt.
Wir hatten ja schon mal diese Diskussion darüber, welchen Port wir heute nehmen möchten, weil 25 ist so problematisch für den Verkehr von deinem Mail-Client zu deinem Mail-Server. Der gute alte 25 ist durch Spammer und anderen Quack dort so missbraucht, dass den viele Leute sperren. Manche ISPs sperren ihn sogar komplett. Du hast es häufiger in Hotels oder in öffentlichen WLANs, dass alles geht außer scheiß Port 25 und so. Ist auch nicht der Port, den man benutzen sollte für die Kommunikation zwischen Client und deinem eigenen Server, sondern 587. Wenn man dann nämlich mal so ein bisschen rumguckt, die Telekom ist natürlich auch von anderen Leuten angepowelt worden, was das soll. Und dann liest man solche Sachen wie Wir haben das Ganze bei uns nachgestellt und Sie haben Recht, der Port 587 wird blockiert. Dieser Port-System-Router für eine andere Funktion vorgesehen, da wir dort auch keine port-freie Schaltung anlegen konnten. Also allein dafür muss man schon sagen Was? Sie haben sich gedacht, auch 587 ist eine tolle Zahl, keine Ahnung, ob die jemand benutzt, ist mir auch scheißegal, wir benutzen den für was anderes. Steht jetzt mindestens so. Das ist der offizielle Statement der Telekom. Auch die Änderung des Ports im Postausgangsverbot auf 25 hat kein positives Ergebnis gezeigt. Sie haben einfach sozusagen komplett kaputt gemacht, was irgendwie mit E-Mail zu tun hat und nichts, was mit E-Mail, aber nichts mit T-Online-E-Mail und mit Google-Mail und keine Ahnung, GMX und web.de. Wer es jetzt wagt, einen anderen Server zu benutzen, als einen von diesen, der es auf jeden Fall verdammt.
Also ich hab die Liste nicht abgespeichert oder so, hab sie auch nur so schnell durchgescrollt. Aber es war auf jeden Fall, Google-Mail war dabei, web.de war dabei. Diese komische unheilige Allianz, die jetzt Mails verschlüsseln wollten, die waren da irgendwie komplett. GMX war auch drin, genau.
Die wollen nicht Mails verschlüsseln, die wollen die Übertragung von Mails endlich mal verschlüsseln.
Ja, das ist auch so eine Pein, da gehen wir jetzt nicht drauf an.
Ja, lass gut sein. Lass gut sein. Und unheilige Allianz reicht ja. Das ist ja schon ordentlich beschrieben.
Das klingt so, als wären sie jetzt sonderlich bedrohlich. Die sind einfach nur blöd.
Ja, aber die sind so blöd, dass es bedrohlich ist. Da waren wirklich echte Lasergehörner am Werk. Und das ist wie gesagt jetzt so das Flaggschiff. Das ist das, was die Telekom so verteilt.
Speedport W724V. So heißt dieses Ungerät.
Oder muss man auch noch für zu zahlen?
Soweit ich weiß, es ist ein Mietgerät.
Das ist ja ein Router.
So eine Frechheit.
Das ist ja ein WLAN-Router. Das ist ja immer noch was ganz Besonderes heutzutage.
WLAN-Router, DSL, Modem, Blag, Rahmen.
Hat sogar eine Web-Überfläche.
Da sind wir wieder bei der Frage, ob Geräte als Modem nutzen.
Das Schöne ist ja, dieses ganze Thema ist natürlich auch ganz schön hier, sodass man da irgendwas einstellen kann. Aber diese Cable-Deutschland-Experience, die ich ja noch habe, wenn Vodafone da voll zuschlägt, dann wird es wahrscheinlich alles richtig schlimm werden. Aber diese schwarze Kiste seit drei Jahren, da kommt so Ethernet raus, da ist einfach immer so IP da. Ich musste noch nie irgendwas machen. Ich hab halt einen Airport-Extreme dahinter, als WLAN hast du nicht gesehen, mach mal Internet verteilen.
Das kannst du auch im DSL haben. Wenn du zum Beispiel bei 1&1 einen Anschluss kriegst, dann kriegst du eine Box und dann kriegst du einen Freischaltcode. Das ist irgendwie so ein 12-, 14-, 16-stelliger Code, irgendwelche Zahlen, tralala. Und dann hängst du dir die dran, kriegst deine Bedienungsanleitung mit, die ist so groß, ungelogen. Also für die Zuhörer so A1-Größe oder so in der Richtung, so zum Ausfalten. Da steht genauer drin, was du machen willst. Und dann siehst du auch genau wie jemand, hier klickst du deinen Internet-Explorer an, und dann geht hier ein Fenster auf und dann musst du nur noch diesen 14-stelligen Code da eingeben und tada!
Aber bei dem Kabel-Deutschland-Ding musste ich das ja nicht mal machen.
Ja, das ist bei diesen ganzen Kabel-Dinger, die werden halt alle fernprovisiert. Auf der anderen Seite bist du aber jetzt natürlich auch völlig eingesperrt. Wenn du jetzt auf die Idee kommst, mit jemand anders zu telefonieren, wenn du es wagen würdest, eine Festnetz-Telefonie benutzen zu wollen, die nicht über Kabel-Deutschland geht, bist du ziemlich gefickt. Jedenfalls mit der Kiste.
Ja, benutze ich ja auch nicht.
Ja, ich benutze es, weil ich habe in meinem Land jetzt keinen Mobilfunk. A, und B, kenne ich und rede viel mit Leuten im Ausland. Auch dort Leute, die halt nicht notwendigerweise einen Skype haben oder sowas. Und wenn du Auslandstelefonie machen willst, bist du trotz all der tollen deutschen Flatrates, jeder scheiß Provider bietet dir inzwischen deine Festnetz-Flatrate an. Ist mit drinnen und mit Soße und Schaf und 100 Minuten für Mobilfunk, tralala. Aber wer, wer, du rufst ins Ausland an. Und doppel wer, du rufst im Ausland jemanden an, der ein Handy hat.
Aber ich spreche ja auch nur von dieser Internet-Experience und irgendwie sind diese ganzen Optionen und Traces alles gut und schön und irgendwie habe ich gerade so drüber nachgedacht, wann habe ich mich eigentlich das letzte Mal um mein Internet gekümmert. Das ist schon Jahre her, das läuft halt einfach so.
Die Trace-Geschichte brauche ich nicht immer in Internet-Anschluss zu gebuggen, sondern die Trace-Geschichte benutze ich dazu, meine Applikationen zu gebuggen.
Es ist halt irgendwie auch schön, im Prinzip, wenn man sich gar nicht drum kümmern muss.
Du brauchst sie nicht. Aber ich finde es halt schön, wenn sie da ist. Und das mag ich halt eben an diesen Kabel-Provider nicht. Die geben dir halt diese fertig konfigurierte Modem und da kommen in der Tat Bits raus und das geht auch irgendwie. Aber wehe, irgendwas passt dir daran nicht oder wehe, irgendwas geht daran nicht. Du hast keine Chance. Dann bist du einfach auf gedeihem Verderb, diesen Typ mal ausgeliefert.
Ich sag ja auch nur, dass, also mein Kabel Deutschland hat ja sowieso auch so seine Spezialitäten, sagen wir mal. Das ist jetzt ja auch nicht alles schön, aber so eigentlich so an sich, der Service und so, das funktioniert einfach seit drei Jahren. Ist schön, wenn es sowas halt auch mal gibt.
So, wo wir jetzt gerade beim Mail sind. Ich bin gerade so schön noch geladen. Ich weiß, ihr chillt gerade schon wieder so schön, aber das hab ich vorhin ja geschneidert. Ist gut, wir müssen über Mail reden. Wir müssen über Mail reden. Ich will hier kurz mal über ein Phänomen renten im Zusammenhang mit Mail, was übrigens auch auftreten würde bei dieser 724V. Was Apple Mail hat, was mich in den Wahnsinn treibt, weil ich jeder, wie jeder von uns, betreue mir ja nicht bloß unsere eigenen Systeme, sondern auch die von Friends and Family mit. Unter anderem auch mit einem nicht unerheblichen User-Anteil und Apple Mail hat die nette Angewohnheit, wenn es versucht, mit einem Server zu kommunizieren und der kann gerade mal nicht, der will gerade mal nicht. Dann behauptet Apple Mail steif und fest, dein Passwort ist falsch. Du kriegst dieses Pop-Up, ich konnte mich auf dem Server nicht anmelden, hier gib mal dein korrektes Passwort ein. Also jetzt sagt nicht dein Passwort ist falsch, aber sagt, ich konnte mich beim Server nicht anmelden, gib mal dein korrektes Passwort ein. Was macht der User? Was macht der User? Er gibt dort das korrekte Passwort ein. Das selbe Pop-Up kommt aber sofort wieder, sagt, nee, gib mal bitte das korrekte Passwort ein. In dem Moment kommt der User ins Zweifeln. Was habe ich hier falsch gemacht? Habe ich jetzt mein Passwort vergessen? Welches war es denn jetzt? Und dann probieren sie alle möglichen alten Passwörter aus, die natürlich alle nicht gehen. Dummerweise speichert sich Apple nicht das letzte funktionierende Passwort ab, sondern das letzte eingegebene Passwort. Das heißt, wenn dann irgendwann der Server mal wieder Bock hat oder dein Router mal wieder Bock hat, dich zu deinem Server durchzustellen, dann kommst du wirklich an und begegnest deinem Server wirklich mit dem falschen Passwort und dann ist die Welt am Ende.
Und lass mich raten, das passiert auch, wenn dich Gmail zum Beispiel ablehnt, weil seiner Meinung nach zu viele Rechner gleichzeitig auf denselben Account zugreifen. Wenn man zum Beispiel den Gmail-Account auf drei Macs und vielleicht noch ein paar iPhones konfiguriert hat und die sind jetzt alle mal online.
Oder wenn man den VPN an- und abschaltet. Das reicht auch schon. Das passiert mir sehr häufig. Also ich krieg häufiger E-Mail, lässt mich manchmal nicht rein, wenn ich mal kurzzeitig einen VPN benutzt habe. Weil, ja, Fluch und Segen halt von Apple. In dem Moment, wo der Apple-Netzwerk-Stack irgendwas Neues entdeckt, sagt er allen Applikationen Bescheid. Hallo, es gibt ein neues Internet. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt einen Full-Tunnel-VPN aufbaust, geht sofort dein Apple-Mail hin und sagt, oh geil, Internet über neue Verbindungen.
Gleich mal laden.
Gleich mal wieder aufmachen. Das heißt, er macht sozusagen alle neuen Verbindungen, alle Verbindungen, die er eben noch hatte, macht er sofort wieder neu auf. Und dann machst du das VPN wieder zu. Und dann macht das Apple-Mail schon wieder neue Verbindungen. Was geht hier eigentlich ab? Wobei witzigerweise so ist, dass Apple-Mail bei Gmail diesen Effekt mit diesem, gib mal hier dein richtiges Passwort ein, nicht zeitdicht. Aber es ist natürlich trotzdem sehr nervig, weil die User, obwohl sie gar nichts falsch gemacht haben, probieren Urmengehalte.
Ich hab das Problem vor allem mit Gmail.
Und er zeigt dir dann diese Frage mit, gib mal hier dein richtiges Passwort ein? Also bei mir geht er einfach nur offline.
Also ich meine das irgendwie zu kennen. Ich hab das dann auch stellenweise auch auf meinen iPhones. Aber ich kann mir auch gerade, da müsste ich auch nochmal so ein bisschen Clean & Store machen, was so dieses Mail-Setup seitdem iCloud irgendwie nicht mehr Mail-Accounts richtig sind.
Also wie gesagt, mein Hauptthema ist, Apple speichert gnadenlos das letzte Passwort ab. Ob du was eingegeben hast, egal ob das richtig oder falsch ist. Und das heißt, wenn ein normaler User, der nichts davon weiß...
Es gibt da meistens noch die Checkbox in der Keychain speichern.
Ja, aber ich weiß nicht, ob die an diesem speziellen Pop-Up nochmal wieder kommen. Die kommen beim Einrichten an oder sowas. Aber es ist egal. Der Effekt ist, dass der User komplett verwirrt ist. Er denkt, er hat was falsch gemacht, aber er hat gar nichts falsch gemacht. Der Server oder sein Router hatte gerade mal keinen Bock. Und damit hauen die sich regelmäßig immer die Einstellungen kaputt. Insbesondere ihr Passwort. Und dann ist es immer so, was ist mit meinem Mail? Und vor allem dann kriegen die diese Panikattacken. Oh, ich bin gehackt worden. Ich hab ja mein Passwort nicht geändert, mein altes Passwort geht nicht mehr. Ich bin mir aber sicher, dass ich das richtige Passwort eingegeben hab. Da sind Hacker auf meinem Account. Deswegen rufen mich dann solche User auch gerne mal nachts an, weil sie denken, jetzt passieren ganz schlimme Dinge.
Es stehen ja auch schlimme Dinge.
Wie gesagt, keine Ahnung. Kann man mal vielleicht reporten, wenn der Apple-Bug-Report mal wieder geht. Aber ich glaube, das wissen die auch. Und haben auch nicht so richtig Bock, da dran mal zu ändern.
Die stellen es einfach auf Duplicate und dann kriegst du wahrscheinlich einen Bug angezeigt, der ungefähr zwei Stellen weniger hat in der Nummer, als den, den du da erzeugt hast.
Das ist irgendwie... Das finde ich irgendwie echt fies.
Ich benutze ja seit auch bestimmt jetzt drei Jahren keinen Apple-Mail mehr.
Seit drei Jahren.
So, ich glaube dieses Postbox ist schon jetzt so mindestens so die Zeit am Start. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie Apple-Mail so ist.
Ja, ich war lange Zeit auch dagegen. Irgendwann hat es mich genervt. Ich habe ja auch, als sie mit Mac angefangen haben, mein erster Mac, da haben wir natürlich erstmal mehr ein Thunderbird drauf gespielt oder sowas, weil ich mit dem ganzen Apple-Quack nichts zu tun haben wollte. Was mich an den meisten dieser externen Dinge irritiert, und ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, dass er in Postbox das macht oder nicht macht, oder sowas, ist das die Integration mit den sonstigen Funktionen, insbesondere mit Adressbuch und solchen anderen Dingern. Lange Zeit echt für ein Quack war. Das kann jeder schon. Und zwar, die Integration muss relativ tief gehen heutzutage. Es geht nicht darum, dass du einen Namen zu einer E-Mail-Adresse machst und einen E-Mail-Adresse zu einer Name, sondern wenn man mit E-Mail-Verschlüsselung arbeitet, mit S-Mime oder sowas, möchte sie gerne auch das Zertifikat haben mit dem Public Key von dem Typen, mit dem du gerade kommunizierst.
Speichert auch die Zertifikate in der Keychain, glaube ich. Benutzt diesen Keychain-Dialog.
Das sind eigentlich alles Public APIs. Also wenn man will, dann kriegt man das hin.
Ja, aber ich rede gerade hier von so etwas wie Thunderbird. Die wird nicht extra für den Mac geschrieben. Ja, Thunderbird. Ich meine, Thunderbird kann das glaube ich inzwischen. Aber viele Software, die du hast, das ist irgendein toller Erfolg unter Windows und dann geht der Chef hin und sagt, hier ein Typ portiert das mal auf dem Mac und dann fangen die nicht an, das neu zu designen, sondern wird es so gemacht, dass es gerade geht und es gut. Da wäre er nicht die tollen Appies benutzt.
Also, das Postbox ist gerade so da auf einem Level, wo man es er tragen kann. Also es ist jetzt nicht das allerschönste Programm, aber es sieht schon mal deutlich besser aus als Thunderbird. Und fühlt sich, also so sieht das aus. Sieht halt schon aus wie so eine Mac-App. Und die Settings sind auch unter Apfelkomma. Und nicht irgendwie eine Einstellung in Konten oder so. Aber du siehst halt schon an den Icons, dass es jetzt hier nicht vielleicht der oberste Mac-Spirit ist. Aber so prinzipiell...
Wie sieht es denn aus mit Verschlüsselungen? Kann das S-Mime von Hause aus?
Ja, also zumindest die Server-Zertifikate und so, die kamen alle mit diesem Keychain-Dialog. Ob er jetzt S-Mime kann, da bestimmt auch. Also, ich benutze das halt. Habe ich ja auch schon tausendmal erzählt, weil ich so ein relativ elaboriertes Setup habe, weil ich vier Mail-Accounts in einen quasi reinfließen lasse und dann auf dem Server das Filter und in meiner Inbox sozusagen Subfolder habe für jede Mail-Adresse.
Das heißt, du hostest einmal durch einen Account durch, um dich hinterher wieder auseinanderzunehmen?
Naja, das Problem, was ich hatte, die waren halt bei allen unterschiedlichen Providern und bei Scheiß-Providern, bei Coolen-Providern, bei unzuverlässigen Nerd-Providern und ich dachte mir, ok, ich will jetzt meine Mail einmal gelöst haben und...
Du willst nicht mal 20 Eimer-Verbindungen aufmachen?
Ja, und nicht dauernd diesen Hassle und so weiter. Dann habe ich die einfach alle auf einen Account weiterleiten lassen und sortieren wir das jetzt sozusagen auf dem Server halt wieder auseinander, damit ich trotzdem noch weiß, über welche Adresse sie jetzt reingekommen sind. Und da kam Apple Mail halt auch nicht mit klar und Postbox war so der... weil die halt auch den Sun oder diesen... naja, die sprechen halt iMap ein bisschen mehr als Apple Mail.
Wobei Apple gar nicht schlecht ist.
Ja, hatten wir auch schon mal. Es ist besser geworden, aber...
Wenn man selber am Server bastelt, oder wenn man an einem rumbastelt und mal guckt, was so ein Client eigentlich da alles macht, da ist Apple schon gar nicht schlecht.
Ich könnte es eigentlich mal wieder ausprobieren, ob es jetzt vielleicht so mein Setup da auch funktioniert, aber das läuft jetzt halt auch seit drei Jahren einfach mal so.
Beim nächsten Clean Install.
Genau, beim nächsten Clean Install wird alles anders.
Weil das von den Hörern mehrfach gewünscht wurde, sollten wir vielleicht an der Stelle mal ganz kurz sagen, wie macht ihr Mail? Also, naja, wir hatten ja diese ganze Prism-Debatte und überhaupt nichts ist irgendwie mehr heilig und besonders unheilig ist es, wenn man ohnehin beim großen Anbieter ist und da...
Ein eigener Mail-Server, FreeBSD, Crypto-Jail, Postfix, DoveCut, Xim, DoveCut, MySQL, FreeBSD, naja, halt Jail auf gekryptetes File-System.
Ich mach fast dasselbe und dann Mac OS X, aber ich benutze Xim statt Postfix.
Also du holst tatsächlich deine Mail auf Mac OS X Server oder OS X Server.
Mini mit einer SSD und DoveCut und so ist sagenhaft schnell.
Ich bin nicht zufrieden, wie groß ist so der Administrationsaufwand bei Mail? Ich meine, ist der nicht irgendwie enorm?
Das initiale Setup ist halt, wenn man es das erste Mal macht.
Wenn man es das erste Mal macht, aber es macht dir dann auch Spaß. Aber ich hab jetzt mein Setup schon seit vielen, vielen Jahren. Also meine Domänen, meinen eigenen Mail-Sauer betreibe ich jetzt seit 20 Jahren. Und mit wechselnder Infrastruktur.
Aber ist die Zeit, wo man Sendmail, CF anfassen muss?
Natürlich hab ich die mit Freuden miterlebt und gemacht und getan.
Aber was muss man denn jetzt anfassen?
Wer was mal schnell machen will, oder Exim zum Beispiel.
Und gibt es da irgendwie mittlerweile GUI-Software für? Gibt es irgendwie Postfix Setup?
Ja, es gibt eine GUI-Software dafür, die dir deinen Postfix und deinen Dovecatch einrichtet. Ist sogar relativ billig, kostet nicht mal 20 Euro und heißt Mac OS X Server. Mac OS X Server ist Open-Source-Software, bis der Arzt kommt. Und zwar ist ein Dovecatch als Mail-Server. Relativ gut konfigurierter Dovecatch sogar. Also verhältnismäßig gut konfigurierter Dovecatch. Mit Postfix und natürlich dem ganzen Spam-SSM und Amabes.
Du willst sagen, dass die GUI-Setup-Konfigurationsthese von OS X Server, die Apple beigelegt hat, ausreichend sind, um einen sinnvoll konfigurierten Mail-Server zu betreiben?
Fast.
Und was fehlt da noch?
Es gibt ein paar Sachen, die im Geschmack des Benutzers liegen. Zum Beispiel ein OS X Server steht unglaublich auf Greylisting. Das ist eine Geschichte, die ich in der Implementation, wie sie sie dort machen, nicht mag. Greylisting führt nämlich dazu, dass du gerade jemanden am Telefon hast und gerade jemanden neuen, ich schicke ihn das mal und du denkst so, Greylisting ist okay, man muss es aber richtig machen. Aber das sind Sachen, die du über die Shell konfigurierst. Du machst dein Terminal-Window auf und gehst von Hand rein in den Amavis und sagst, hier komm vergiss den Greylisting.
Ist es nicht so, dass wenn man diese Tools wieder aufmacht, dass sich alles komplett zermarmelt?
Es gibt ein paar Stellen, die darfst du explizit anfassen. Es gibt auch ein Command-Line-Tool, mit dem du diese Dinge anfassen kannst von Apple. Also sozusagen ein Configure-mal-den-Parameter-Tim- auf den Wert 42 Tool.
Darf ich mal kurz fragen? Hier unter Mavericks scheint man Greylisting komplett abschalten zu können. Und das ist standardmäßig abgeschaltet.
Okay, wie gesagt, ich habe jetzt nur so... XServa betreibe für mich keinen OSX-Server. Das liegt daran, dass meine ganze Mail-Konfiguration wie gesagt ziemlich alt ist und schon durch Solaris durchgewandert ist, durch verschiedene Versionen und Tra-La-La und so.
Für XServa betreibst du keinen, aber sagst du nicht gerade, dass du das...
Ich mache für Friends and Family zum Beispiel die mehrfach schon erwähnte Druckerei.
Aber wir haben Tim und doch gefragt, was wir für Mail machen.
Ja, aber das ist ja auch so. Also deine Mail. Meine eigene Mail-Domain mit Friends and Family drauf, mit 150 Usern. Und noch... Die läuft auf einem Mini, aber mit komplett handkonfiguriertem...
Auf OS X Server ist es aber Postfix.
Auf OS X Server, das was sie mitliefern, ist Postfix.
Das nutzt du dann auch, sozusagen.
Das mach ich. Auf den System, die ich für andere Leute installiere, diese Mini-Firmen oder auch so Selbständige, voll Selbständige, so Mini-Büros mit zwei Leuten, OS X Server.
Wenn sich die IP-Adresse von diesem Scheißteil mal ändert, hast du das mal?
Ja, ich hab welche installiert, die hängen hinter einem DSL-Anschluss, der Telekom, wo sich täglich die Adresse ändert.
Ein OS X Server hinter einem DSL-Anschluss?
Mit einem Mail-Server drauf.
Du meinst, Apple hat das mittlerweile hinbekommen mit diesem Server?
Nein, da muss aber Apple nichts für machen.
Ja, aber ich hab so mit dem OS X Server in den frühen Zeiten, was war das, 10, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Vollkommen für'n Arsch.
Du hast das dann noch ein bisschen fortgesetzt. Und es war einfach jedes Release eigentlich dieselbe Erkenntnis. Du musst eigentlich nur eine halbe Stunde irgendwie mit diesen Admin-Tools rumspielen. Und irgendwann ist das Ding so dermaßen im Graben gepackt, dass du den da einfach nicht mehr rauskriegst.
Auch schon alleine die initialen Settings, die waren da so in das System reingeboltet, dass wenn du dann halt mal die IP änderst und so.
Ich geh dazu, ich hab das früher mal ausprobiert, als es auch noch teuer war. Und hab das jetzt erst vor ein paar Jahren mal wieder rausgezogen, weil ich dachte, ich mach hier eine Installation, die ich auch mal im Admin übergeben kann, wenn ich mal jetzt vier Wochen nach Schweden fahre. Also so einen normalen User. Und du hast nach der Oberfläche gefragt, deswegen kam ich drauf, weil du hast halt eben so eine clicky-bunte Oberfläche, wo du User einrichten kannst. Da kommt es immer noch ganz andere zu. Du kriegst noch einen Java-Server gleich noch mit, den machen sie gleich mit drauf. Und deinen Time Machine Backup-Server und Tralala-Pepapo und das kannst du alles über eine schöne, bunte Oberfläche verwalten. Das ist für normale Anwendungen super toll. Außer wenn du jetzt so ein Mail-Geek bist wie ich, der jetzt hingeht und will da noch einen Lock und da noch eine Blacklist bitte und die Blacklist bitte nicht und da bitte eine andere Spam-Assassin-Einstellung und so weiter und so fort. Dann kannst du das auch gleich selber machen. Aber wenn du jetzt einfach nur ein Mailsystem haben willst, was einfach nur geht, jetzt vielleicht auch nicht für 50 Domains, sondern vielleicht nur für eine oder zwei Domains oder eine Domain mit drei Aliasen noch, dann funktioniert das.
Ja, ich hab auf dem Mailserver z.B. auch mehrere Domains und gleich noch ganz viele andere Trödel.
Ich mach Tralala und Experimente damit.
Ich hab mir den Server ja auch nur angeguckt, weil da jetzt der Xcode-Build-Server mit dabei ist, wo man halt für ein beliebiges Xcode-Projekt ein Build-Bot aufsetzen kann, und zwar das relativ unkompliziert.
Da hast du deinen eigenen Mailserver compiled?
Nein, nur Mac OS X Server für den Xcode-Build-Server.
Also, dass du mit deinen eigenen Projekten regelmäßig das Ding durchbauen lassen kannst, wenn du was ancheckst oder was.
War bis jetzt ein Rough Ride. Mal sehen, wie es sich entwickelt.
Und was machst du mit deiner Mail?
Ich benutze einen Mail-Provider, einen normalen. Also meine Haupt-Mail hab ich tatsächlich bei Apple, was mal Mobile-Me hieß und jetzt iCloud heißt.
Was ist echt deine Primary?
herod.me.com Stimmt, wir schreiben dir einen.
Für etwas offiziellere Sachen über berlin.de, was wahrscheinlich auch kein besonders guter Mailprovider ist.
berlin.de, unser Marketingportal. Ja, wo du dir irgendwie für ein extra Mail-Speicher dann nochmal 6,80 Euro überweisen musst oder irgendeinen Scheiß hatten.
Ja, im Jahr.
Wieviel kommst du auf die Idee bei berlin.de? All diese Mailprovider haben alle ein großes Problem.
Das ist noch aus einer Zeit, als es halt, da gab es noch kein GMX und kein...
berlin.de.
Das ist ewig alt.
Ja, doch stimmt, mein Vater hat das auch tatsächlich.
Die haben das schon ziemlich lange.
Wer ist denn das? Ach, Hansenet.
Und war auch alles pop 3, ewig lange. Die haben uns ewig gebraucht, um das auf IMAP umzustellen.
Gehört zu Telefonica und tralala. Da ist zumindest gehostet IP-mäßig. Keine Ahnung, wer das betreibt. Diese ganzen großen, diese ganzen, sagen wir mal, diese jedermann Mailprovider, also 1&1 und Strata und Tralala, Peterco, die haben alle dieses Problem.
Dann hab ich natürlich noch diverse andere Mail-Sachen.
Aber hast du eigene Domains?
Ja, ich hab halt für Chipmunk, hatte ich ja damals irgendwie eine Domain geklickt und da halt auch ein Mail-Dings eingesetzt, einen für Crash-Reports und einen für, weiß ich nicht, für Impressungen.
Du hast sozusagen keine eigene Domain für dich, für Primary, für Mail?
Eigen, auf dem Server ist tatsächlich auch nur Mail, aber es sind mehrere Jails. Ein Local-Host-Jail für den MySQL-Day, ein Local-Host-Jail für den Spam-Day, das heißt, die sind nicht am Public-IP, die sind nur lokal erreichbar. Ein Jail für den Postfix und ein Jail für den Dove-Cut.
Er will jetzt wirklich wissen.
Ich wollte es mal so richtig wissen.
Der Spam-Day ist das eigeneste.
Der Spam-Day war halt auch so eine lange Zeit so das Exploit-Einfallstor.
Inter-Jail.
Und dann hat C-Punk, mit C-Punk hab ich im Club gesessen, haben dann so Mailserver geschraubt und der meinte ja, okay, wenn du hier total Isolation haben willst und diese ganze Mails-Software ist alles zusammengeglut mit Pearl und keine Ahnung, das schlummern tausend Sachen, wenn du nicht willst, dass irgendwie nur weil einer jetzt deinen Spam-Day hackt gleich dein MySQL und dein anderer auch gleich irgendwie da offen da liegen, dann kannst du dir dann einzelne Jails packen und dann reichst du dir alles mal.
Es gibt auch nur ein kleiner Unterschied. Ich hab früher mein Zeugs auch mit MySQL gemacht, jetzt seit einiger Zeit mit Postgres. Ich bin konvertiert von MySQL nach Postgres. Aber ja, ich jaile nicht so rum. Das gebe ich zu.
Ich glaube, ich würde es jetzt auch nicht nochmal so machen.
Ich hab die Dinger ordentlich installiert, auch mit dem alten Quack und was da nicht wirklich war, braucht läuft auch Chainchute und so weiter und so fort, aber ich jail die nicht einzeln. Aber ich will jetzt eh demnächst mal ein paar Sachen umstellen auf Virtual Machines. Und da werde ich dann auch ein bisschen weiter separieren nach meinen Zeugs. Aber übrigens, wo wir nur dabei sind, mehr ist nur die Hälfte der Miete Huckel und ich gehöre auch noch zu den Leuten, die selber Nameserver betreiben. Im Gegensatz zu anderen Leuten hier am Tisch.
Für die Leute, die sich die ganze Zeit wundern, was wir hier mit diesen Jails und diesen Knesten hier rein und was das mit Huckels Interknast auf sich hat. Also, Jail ist ein BSD und zwar, gibt es das bei FreeBSD und gibt es das auch bei NetBSD? Haben die dasselbe Jailsystem oder haben die nur ein ähnliches? Es gab ja über Jahre so verschiedene Trends zur Virtualisierung. Wie kann ich aus einem Computer mehrere Environments machen? Da gab es halt diesen Jail-Approach, der ist relativ OS-nah. Das heißt, das Betriebssystem selber organisiert eigentlich seine eigene Virtualisierung. Sprich Prozessen wird so ein eigenes System vorgegaukelt.
Das hat ein Change-Route-Environment, ein bisschen mehr Fancyness.
Genau, aber es ist sozusagen aus dieser Unix-Abstraktion, die es schon immer gab, so mit, naja du hast jetzt zumindest mal einen anderen Ort im Fallsystem, der für dich Rute ist, bis hin zu, wir isolieren das jetzt mal komplett. Und das haben sie irgendwie auch ausgebaut zu einem, darf ich das so sagen, relativ, als relativ sicher geltenden Isolationsmechanismus, der wird sicherlich seine Bugs gehabt haben, aber ich hab jetzt noch keine Dramen gehört. Und dann gibt es ja diese anderen Ansätze mit Virtualisierung durch halt irgendeine VM-Software. Genau, und dann geht das ja mittlerweile dann noch mit Xen und diesen ganzen anderen Sachen, wo verschiedene Hardware-Varianten gemacht werden.
Bei Linux gibt es ja auch dieses Change schon lange, und da gibt es jetzt seit Jahren, Monaten so ähnlich wie Butter FS oder so, das modert da die ganze Zeit als Thema rum, diese Linux-Containers oder so irgendwie heißt das. LTE, irgendwie sowas. Aber die BSDJs, die gibt es halt schon sehr, sehr, sehr lange und sind abgehangen. Und im Vergleich zu einer Virtualisierung hat man halt quasi immer noch Bare Metal in den einzelnen Jails. Man kann sogar auf BSD sagen oder FreeBSD, das Jail soll jetzt hier so eine Affinity zu bestimmten CPU-Cores haben. Also man könnte sozusagen sogar auch die Hardware-Resourcen so ein bisschen priorisieren oder verteilen auf die einzelnen Jails. Aber letztendlich, ich mag das halt lieber als Virtualisierung, weil bei der Virtualisierung so viel Overhead irgendwie drauf gebügelt wird. Und ich will immer nacktes Metall, wenn möglich. Und ich brauch meistens nicht zwischen den Jails irgendwie so die Performance-Prioritäten so regeln, weil die Kisten heutzutage, die haben 4-8 Cores, 32 Gigagramm, Terabyteweise Platten, so irgendwie. Ich hab nicht so eine Service, die irgendwie die ein Core da komplett saturieren und so weiter. Das heißt, Jails ist für mich halt das Coolere, weil ich dann irgendwie die ganze Hardware krieg und ich irgendwie tausend Abstraktionslayers dazwischen hab. Wenn man halt wissen will, was... Also letzten zum Beispiel, wir hatten für ein Spiel, das wir so geprototypt haben, haben wir erstmal auf Amazon gehostet, einfach nur, um mal schnell eine Kiste zu haben. Und dann haben wir halt später so bei Lease Web uns so eine richtige Maschine, gleiche Software und so diese Unterschiede zwischen diesem Virtualisierten und diesem so direkt auf dem Server.
Direkt auf dem Metall.
Und mit den Jails kann man heutzutage, also die hatten halt früher so ganz dode Limitierungen, du hattest irgendwie keinen Local Host, du konntest nur eine IP assignen und solche Geschichten. Mittlerweile ist das alles weg, man hat einen Local Host, man kann beliebig viele IPs, IPv6 verteilen und macht eigentlich voll Spaß. Und es gibt, falls jemand da draußen jetzt denkt, ok, ich mach mir jetzt mal eine VM mit FreeBSD. Um ein bisschen rumzuspielen mit den Jails, installiert den Port EasyJail, der nimmt euch sehr viel Arbeit ab. Da kann man halt auch dann, zum Beispiel FreeBSD mit ZFS ist halt dann richtig geil. Da kann man seinen Storage Pool haben, so einen Tank und dann kann man pro Jail ein eigenes Volumen in seinem ZFS Pool haben und die einzelnen Snapshotten und einzelne Compression Settings und was auch immer. Man hat einzelne File-Systeme.
Aus einem Pool raus.
Aus einem Pool raus pro Jail.
Ist doch von Erdgeiss, oder?
Genau. Und dann kannst du eben diese Snapshots, wenn du so einen Jail von einer Kiste auf die andere ziehen willst, kannst du halt...
Easy Jail ist EZ Jail. Also E-Z-J-A-I-L. Falls jemand da gerade, der uns überhaupt noch folgen kann, mal wissen will, was da ist.
Das ist aber natürlich eher der Uhrzeitgeschulde.
Ja, ich will das jetzt auch erwähnen, weil wir haben ja wahrscheinlich irgendwie keine Show Notes diesmal hier live. Deswegen hoffe ich, dass mich das nachgetragen hat. Keine Ahnung, hat sich irgendwie keiner gefreundet. Wir sind wahrscheinlich total unpopulär jetzt mittlerweile, weil irgendwie neue Namen alle laufen werden.
Aber jetzt reden wir wieder von ZFS.
Ich hab die gelesen.
Ja, aber heute nicht. Im Chat wurde diverse Male der Link zum Show Note schreiben gepostet, aber es hat sich keiner angefunden.
Wir sind halt auch ein Nischen-Podcast, weil die Affinität zu Android haben wir ja mitbekommen. Und Android ist einfach mal Marktführer. Android ist einfach...
Vor allem, der hört sich schon über vier Stunden unter der Labe an.
Ja, aber wenn der irgendwie kein Android benutzt, dann geht es da halt raus.
Deswegen treibe ich jetzt hier nochmal kurz voran, weil ich wollte gerade nochmal darauf hinweisen, weil ich ja auch letztes Mal thematisiert wurde, was ich auftragsmäßig dort beim Pizza-Araba in den Tisch gebissen habe, wie du gesagt hast. Nein, das war ja zum Thema DNS. Du hast gefragt, Pizza-Araba, das liegt damit zusammen, dass mir, ich bereise Schweden sehr viel und sehr gerne, mir ist dort bisher noch kein Italiener Italiener untergekommen. Die Leute, die dort Pizza machen, sind in der Regel Araber. Man würde jetzt auch denken, so Türken, weil da gibt es sowas wie Kebab-Pizza. Aber da hat in dem selben Laden auch Gyros-Pizza, was die Türke nie tun würde. Ja, würde ein Araber aber auch nicht machen, weil Gyros ja Schweinefleisch ist.
Aber das ist wahrscheinlich einfach Kulinarik-Mimikre.
Wie gesagt, Kebab-Pizza ist mir sehr lecker. Wer mal nach Schweden fährt, ist ein Kebab-Pizza.
Macht den Affen weg!
Da gibt es von Max Gold einen schönen Text über Gastronomie-Mimikre.
Ich weiß nicht, wie der heißt, aber ihr werdet ihn schon finden, wenn ihr wollt.
Aber jetzt machen wir noch den kurzen Abwasch zum DNS-Amplification.
Nein, den machen wir nicht. Aber ich finde es schon mal sehr schön, dass es noch Leute gibt, die DNS selber machen. Und nicht irgendwo auf dem Post. Und jetzt ist es nämlich die Überleitung.
Ich hab noch nicht gesagt, wie ich Mail mache.
Und ich cares, und du cares.
Ich bin auch wichtig.
Wer will das wissen?
Ich höre.
Ich will es auch wissen.
Wie machst du denn Mail?
Nicht selber. Aber ich bin jetzt nicht bei so einem komischen Mail. Und ehrlich gesagt, das könnte ich auch nicht über mich bringen. Also so meine Mail jetzt bei GMX oder Gmail haben. Also Google Mail ist insofern noch halbwegs interessant gewesen, weil sie ja auch dieses, wie nennen die das? Eine der schlechtesten Bezeichnungen überhaupt. Google Apps. Oder hieß das nicht so? Nein, nein. Also wo du quasi deine Domain betreiben kannst und dafür dann Mail und so weiter konfigurieren kannst. Das war mal kostenlos und ich hab keine Ahnung.
Und technisch auch recht gut.
Ja, das war nicht total scheiße und du kannst da E-Mail-Accounts einrichten und so. Also es war halt so ein bisschen so ein User-Interface für your own Domain. Aber irgendwie, das gibt es zwar auch.
Aber seitdem Google bei der NSA hosted?
Ja, keine Ahnung. Ich meine, das ist sicherlich kein Dienst, mit dem sie besonders viel Geld gemacht haben. Ich meine, der war irgendwie kostenlos und kaum einer dürfte den so benutzt haben. Das ist halt so ein bisschen für Small Companies, der Bootstrap für, hier kannst du dann halt so deine Firma mal hosten, da hast du den Domain, da machst du Mail-Accounts und wir bauen einfach die ganzen Basisdienste, für die eben sonst so eine Lösung bauen müsstest, wie ihr das eben jetzt zum Beispiel gemacht habt. Wenn man eben nicht ganz woanders hingeht. Und da ist so Gmail so ein bisschen der Mix aus beiden gewesen. Du hast so deine Hoheit. Ich meine, du willst ja nicht meinfahrradladen.de machen. Ich meine, wird's mal gemacht, aber gut. Ich meine, wenn man jetzt auf irgendeinem Dorfkneip irgendwo in so einem Caf ist, dann mag das ja stadthaft sein, aber wenn du heutzutage halbwegs seriös im Internet auftreten willst, dann brauchst du einfach mal deine eigene fucking Domain. So, und unser eins, die wir ja hier so in die falsche Zeit geboren wurden. Haben halt irgendwie gleich so eine Myriade von Domains. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele Domains ich habe. Es sind viele. Bestimmt irgendwie so 20 oder so.
Ja, bin ich auch so.
Kommt ja einiges zusammen hier mit dem Podcast auch noch. Und was man dann immer noch so registriert.
Ich glaube, ich habe nur knapp über einen halben Dutzend. Da bin ich mir nicht sicher.
So, aber ich will halt Mail unter Kontrolle haben. Und das ist natürlich ein bisschen schwierig. Also gehe ich zu einem Host an meines Vertrauens. Host an meines Vertrauens heißt jetzt nicht... Da ist jetzt alles total mega sicher. Und wenn da irgendwie einer von der NSA über den Garten schaut, wird geschossen. Sondern seriöse ansprechbare Admins, die nicht komplett weltfremd sind, wissen, was sie tun, sind in der Lage, dieses allgemeine Spam-Desaster in den Griff zu kriegen. Und machen jetzt auch nichts total falsch. Und können auf Zuruf jede beliebige Konfiguration herstellen.
Hotlines, wo man Schibulett sagen kann und man kriegt jemand ans Rohr, der weiß, was er tut.
Genau, in meinem Fall sogar ohne Schibulett. Das ist irgendwie ganz cool. Ich schreib denen halt ne Mail und dann ist die Sache halt irgendwie klar.
Ich will nur ganz kurz eine Sache noch zu Gmail sagen. Es gibt noch einen anderen Vorteil, den Gmail hatte oder immer noch hat, ist, sie haben als einer der wenigen großen, bekannten Mail-Provider ein ordentliches Postfach-Limit. Die meisten anderen, also diese web.de oder 1&1-Dinger von Strato oder sowas, wo du ja auch deine eigenen Domains hosten kannst, da kannst du dir auch Mail-Space kaufen, aber eine einzelne Mailbox ist bei denen nicht größer als 2 GB. Und du kannst dir auch ums Verrecken nichts dazu kaufen. Und wenn du so wie jemand wie ich seit 20 Jahren iMap benutzt und deinen ganzen Zoda hättest, also bist du vollkommen am Rad. Also 2 GB, hallo, wir haben 2013 mal Zoldat, geht mit eurer scheißen 32-Bit-Applikation dahinten weg. Diese Spacken gibt es auch noch. Da war Gmail auch einer der ersten, die, weiß nicht ob ihr euch noch erinnert, wer da mal so einen Account hat, wenn man sich eingeloggt hat, gab es oben so eine Zahl, die per JavaScript hochgezählt hat, während du eingeloggt bist, wie groß jetzt deine Mailbox wird. Nach dem Motto, während du deine Mailbox nutzt und sie sozusagen füllst, wird sie immer größer und immer größer und immer größer. Ich weiß nicht, die Zahl ist jetzt nicht mehr da, ich wollte nämlich gerade mal gucken, wo sie jetzt steht, aber das war mal durchaus ein Feature.
Das war ja mal so eine Ansage mit 1 Gigabyte für deine Mail. Das war ja vollkommen unvorstellbar. Ja, dann zählte es noch hoch und jetzt kam ja Flicker mit 1 Terabyte für deine Fotos.
Bestimmt.
Okay, aber du bist jetzt bei einem netten Provider mit eingebauten Schiebeln.
Genau, ich bin bei einem netten Provider und ich finde diese Art Provider gut. Deswegen, auch wenn die jetzt nicht an so mega High-Performance-Standorten, wo sie mit 30 Subprovidern verbunden sind. Ich bin bei bytecam.net. Das ist ein kleiner Provider in Brandenburg. Ich kenne die Leute. In der Stadt Brandenburg. In der Stadt Brandenburg. Und das ist alles super nett. Du kriegst halbwegs korrekte Ateminterfaces für allen Scheiß. Du hörst nicht unbedingt immer so das allerletzte Ajax-Schrei. Aber es ist einfach solide und funktioniert und tut, was es soll. Und ist jetzt nicht so eine totale Blasphemie wie so ein 1&1-Portal, wo du wirklich überhaupt nicht mehr klarkommst. Und wenn da jetzt wirklich ein komplexeres Problem ist, dann hast du halt einfach Leute, mit denen du reden kannst. Also real humans on the telephone, you can talk to.
Die auch deine Daten noch finden auf dem Cyber.
Ja, wo du auch nicht immer wieder alles komplett erklären musst und deine Sicherheitssätze runterbeten musst.
Have you tried to get off and on again?
Ja, die einen auch halbwegs ernst nehmen. Gut, ich meine, es mag jetzt im Verhältnis zu mir noch ein bisschen was anderes sein als für andere Leute, aber grundsätzlich geht es halt in diese Richtung. Da gibt es andere Provider auch noch. Ich könnte sie jetzt nicht alle runterbeten, aber ich mag diese, ich weiß gar nicht, ob die vom Aussterben bedroht sind, aber so richtig leicht ist es auch nicht unbedingt, weil es sehr schwierig ist bei so einer großen Konkurrenz jetzt auch mit den ganzen Cloud-Diensten und so. Ich frage jetzt immer, wofür braucht man jetzt eigentlich wirklich noch einen Provider?
Genau dafür, was du sagst.
Genau, und was auch cool ist, da ist ja auch so eine MySQL-Datenbank-Infrastruktur, da kann man hingehen und sich mal eben eine Datenbank klicken. Und dann hat man eine Datenbank und dann kann man über ein anderes Interface sich mal eben einen WordPress installieren oder auch irgendeine andere von X100 CMSen, die da halt so voll konfiguriert sind. Du machst einen Klick, klick, klick, dann hast du deinen WordPress und deine Datenbank und fertig. Und dann ist das irgendwie da.
Das ist im Übrigen wirklich der Grund, warum diese kleinen Provider nicht nur eine Existenzberechtigung haben, sondern auch warum es sie überhaupt noch gibt. Weil ich hatte gerade gestern, musste ich mal so ein bisschen Consulting machen und da schwangen wieder große Namen durch die Gegend, so wie Verizon, das war früher mal UUnet und so, also die ganz, die großen und die dicken und so was. Da ging es aber um Leitung und Bits und Kapazität. Und wie gesagt, hallo, wir haben 2013, das hat heute jeder. Weil die letzte Meile mieten sich eh an von der Telekom und ansonsten hat jeder seine Gigabit, das ist jetzt kein Thema mehr. Worin sich die Provider unterscheiden, hauptsächlich gerade auch so für kleine Unternehmen, mittelständische Unternehmen oder Privatleute ist, dass da halt eben gerne jemanden haben, der noch einen Service hat. Und da riechen halt eben, wie du aus tausenden von Foren lesen kannst, da riechen sie halt alle die ganz großen Billigklicker riechen alle aus dem Mund. Ob das Hetzener 1&1 oder Strat oder sowas.
Einer der größeren ist hier Domain Factory, der noch sehr nett ist und auch beim Support eigentlich immer...
Jetzt nur für Domains?
Ne, die machen auch Hosting und Mail und so und die haben auch hier...
Der ist zu teuer.
Wie auch immer, bis jetzt ist es so.
Hosting made in Germany.
Ja, die haben gute Preise.
Moment, du machst jetzt Mail da. Aber du hast jetzt nicht selber konfiguriert, sondern hast dir einen Mailzauber zusammengeklickt.
Ich nutze von denen vollständig betriebene Domain und sage halt nur einmal an, bitte für diese meiner Domain, bitte auch jetzt hier Mx-Records und jetzt auch die Mail. Dann habe ich da halt Accounts und kann an der Stelle mir selber meine User-Mail-Accounts und Adressen und so weiter einrichten, Mailing-Listen einrichten. Und dann habe ich halt die.
Aber ich muss auch bei denen über klickgibung.de nicht durch... Genau.... vi.etc.nmd.com.
Nmd.conf ist vorbei jetzt erst mal. Habe ich mal gemacht, aber... Nicht für meine eigenen Sachen für die Uni damals.
Um da nochmal kurz den Bogen wieder rüberzuziehen, weil das vorhin kurz anklang, so Mac OS X Server, DSL-Anschluss und so weiter und so fort. Eins dieser Themen, die da noch unten steht, nämlich dünn DNS, hat Roddy draufgesetzt. Um zu verhindern, dass er jetzt mit dem Kopf auf die Tastatur knallt, würde ich jetzt den Ball mal darüber spielen und sagen...
Dürfen wir aber auch nicht mehr zu lange machen.
Sag doch mal, was war jetzt dein DNS-Demonstrat?
Das Ding war, dass dieser übliche dünn DNS-Betreiber, Dünn DNS-Org heißen die, glaube ich. Die haben irgendwann vor einem halben Jahr oder so umgestellt, es gibt eigentlich keine Free Accounts mehr. Und jetzt mal abgesehen davon, dass ich das irgendwie relativ unschön fand, wie sie das gemacht haben, so nach der Art, ja, dein Account läuft zwar weiter, aber du kriegst halt jeden Monat eine Mail und dann musst du den Link anklicken, damit sie dir den Link zumachen.
Deine Domain of Ewig, was sie dir mal versprochen haben oder sowas.
Ist halt die Frage, gibt es da alternative Anbieter?
Ja, es gibt alternative Anbieter. Es gibt auch alternative Technologien. Es gibt auch alternative Technologien. Ich mache das auch sehr viel und zwar ich mach's selbst. Das geht nämlich dann, wenn du deinen eigenen Nameserver betreibst, kannst du da relativ, eigentlich technisch gesehen einfach, man muss halt mal rausfinden, wie es geht, kannst du ja selber so implementieren. Also wenn du gerne dünne DNS-Einträge haben möchtest, noch ein Nöcher, mit V4 und V6-Support und sogar noch DNS-Sack signiert, dann sprich mich nochmal nach der Sendung an. Aber ansonsten, die anderen Provider kann man zum Beispiel sehen, wenn man zum Beispiel mal so ein Haus- und Hofrouter aufmacht. Natürlich nicht. Tim, mach mal bitte kurz deine Fritzbox nochmal auf.
Also ich hab ja da so eine Fritzbox, die Geschichte kennt jetzt wahrscheinlich auch inzwischen jeder. Die steht ja hinter dem Sekretär, der da vorgestellt wurde und voll geräumt wurde.
Der Unverrückbare.
Ja, und das Ding darf nicht kaputt gehen. Da ist halt jetzt dieses dünne DNS-Org eingetragen.
Du weißt aber schon, dass du den auch über das Netz konfigurieren kannst. Du musst da nicht über einen Konsolenkabel dran.
Ja, ich weiß, dass ich ihn über das Netz konfigurieren kann. Der darf halt nicht kaputt gehen.
Geh mal bitte auf den DNS. Ein bisschen rechts von deiner Maus gerade. Geh mal da, wo Nutzer definiert steht. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Nein, nur einmal diese Unterklappen. Da hast du noch andere Leute, die dir das anbieten. Kommerzielle oder nicht kommerzielle. Und wie gesagt...
Gibst du da jemanden, den du da empfehlen würdest?
Von denen? Nein, ich mach's aus gutem Grund selbst. Aber, ähm, weil wie gesagt, klar, für die simple Anwendung, ich möchte meine V4-Adresse auf einen Namen mappen. Oder einen Namen, den ich habe, auf eine V4-Adresse mappen, das können die alle. Aber wie gesagt, aus dem Alter bin ich raus. Ich möchte gerne mehr.
Benutzen die denn alle im Prinzip dasselbe Protokoll, was dünn den S-Org benutzt hat?
Mehr oder weniger. Also es gibt eigentlich nur zwei Varianten, wie man das machen kann. Und zwar einmal das, was dünn DNS mal eingeführt hat, nämlich einfach per HTTPS-Request, mit so einem All, wo du dann deinen ganzen Schrott einfach reinschreibst und natürlich dann noch ein Username und Passwort mitgibst, in Basic Authentication oder wie auch immer, und dann speichern die das irgendwie ab. Es gibt aber auch noch, das ist das, was die da alle machen. Und das ist auch das, was meine Simulation, die du da gerade da drin hast, von diesem dünn DNS-Interface da auch macht. Und es gibt auch einen offiziellen IETF-Standard dafür, wie man das machen kann. Der ist witzigerweise gerade mal ausgerechnet von der Firma Microsoft seit Jahren implementiert. Das machen nämlich PC's einfach von sich aus, ohne dass du irgendwas tust. Nämlich sogenannte Dynamic Updates. Du kannst, wenn du Nameserver hast, erlaubst dort mit verschiedenen Security Credentials oder Netzbeschränkungen oder Kryptosignaturen, kannst du einem laufenden Nameserver in Betrieb seine Zone ändern.
Und was ist das mit der technologisch führenden Unternehmen Apple? Machen die das auch?
Ne, die PC's machen eigentlich nur folgendes. Und ich weiß das deswegen, weil, wie ich schon ein paarmal erwähnt habe, gehören mir ja noch Netzbereiche, die so RFC 1918-Adressen sehr ähnlich sehen. Also zum Beispiel die offizielle RFC 1918, diese Private-Adresse 168, Punkt irgendwas. Und mir gehört zum Beispiel 192.68, Punkt irgendwas.
War das halt die Zufall?
Zufall, 200 Zufall. Ich hatte die Netze lange bevor es RFC 1918 gab. Aber der Witz ist der, wenn ich jetzt gucke, wenn ich da Nameservice für anmache, also Reverse-Mapping dafür anmache, werde ich von Hunderttausenden Rechnern auf dieser Welt totgetrümmert mit ihrem Hallo, ich bin ein Windows-PC, ich habe jetzt die Adresse 192.68.042 und ich möchte gerne meinen Namen anmelden, der heißt dummpc.irg.firm.com Und du denkst so, ey... Also, machen PCs, wenn sie per DRCP eine Adresse zugeteilt kriegen und einen Namen vor allen Dingen auch, dann gucken sie uns nach, gibt es hier DNS, gibt es auch Reverse-Mapping für meine Adresse, dann melde ich mich doch gleich mal bei meinem Nameserver an.
Warum habt ihr eigentlich falsche Adressen?
Weil die Leute zu doof sind, 192.68 zu tippen, sondern 192.68 tippen. Naja, irgendein Admin gibt das mal ein in seinem DRCP-Server. Das ist nicht der User, das ist der Admin. Das ist der Admin, der die Konfiguration von ihrem Netz vergeigt hat. Diese Netz kann ich eigentlich gar nicht benutzen. Die liegen da so rum, gelegentlich, wenn ich mal Spaß habe, ein bisschen Statistiken drauf zu machen, dann mach ich die mal an. Also rout ich die mal und guck mal, was da so ankommt. Aber das ist echt lustig. Wie gesagt, ein PC versucht sich, wenn er per DRCP eine Adresse zugeteilt gekriegt hat und entsprechende Domain-Informationen, versucht er sich bei seinem Nameserver anzumelden, zu sagen, ich hab jetzt folgende Adresse. Was eigentlich eine relativ nette Idee ist, aber wie gesagt, in solchen Fällen schief geht. Aber die benutzen genau diesen Dynamic Update Mechanismus.
Ja, ja, irgendwie das 10 minus 8 Minuten jetzt noch maximal. Der Thema ist eigentlich auch zu spannend und zu wichtig, um dich jetzt noch mal schnell durchzuhächeln.
Vielleicht nehmen wir irgendwann noch mal einen nüchternen Zustand mit.
Ja, durchaus.
Aber wie sagt man, das kann man machen? Das kann man schon seit einiger Zeit, ne?
Ja, ich bin auch echt dumm.
Also ich kann mal sagen, wenn du da einen Schmerz hast, Roddy, wir sprechen darüber. Ich kann dir auch deine Domains damit unter Umständen auch...
Momentan ist es nur mein Heimanschluss.
Also diese letzten Themen, die wir da noch haben, die sehen so aus, als ob wir noch mal eine Stunde dranhängen.
Jaja, genau, und hier auch noch mal DNS mit dem, wie hostet man seine Resolver und so. Das machen wir nächstes Mal. Schreib mal gleich auf die nächste Sendungsliste.
Aber nur wenn es Show Notes gibt von dieser Sendung, bevor es keine Show Notes gibt, machen wir nicht weiter, dann streiken wir. Podcast, The Big Podcast Strike.
Ich streike schon, wenn es hier nächstes Mal kein Eis gibt.
Und du meinst, es interessiert jemand, wenn es schon noch nicht mal Show Notes gibt?
Ja, wahrscheinlich sind wir einfach unbedeutend geworden. Irgendjemand hat uns abgehängt, wir sind nicht mehr in den Chart.
Die Leute hören alle Mobile Max.
Das hört uns wahrscheinlich keiner mehr zu, sonst wird einfach nur noch auf irgendwelche Festplatten geschrieben und keiner hört.
Was soll denn deine Daumen hoch zahlen?
Also ein letztes Ding hab ich noch hier.
Einen hab ich noch, einen hab ich noch.
One more thing.
Was ich schon vorhin erwähnte, als Abschluss ist das glaube ich sehr schön. Ich hab doch tatsächlich Kalenderspam, irgendwie in dem Freak Show Kalender. Mindestens G of Finance. Ja, das ist hier ein guter Tag.
Westafrikanische Winterzeit.
Ja, das ist um eure Notiz zu bringen. Blablabla, schicken sie mir ihr Geld und bla. Also ich hab jetzt Spam.
Der gute alte Nigeria-Spam.
Der gute alte Nigeria-Spam hat es in meinen Google-Shared-Kalender geschafft. Und ich frage mich jetzt ernsthaft, wie? Weil ich hab an meinen Mail-Klienz...
Per Mail hast du einen Kalender-Eintrag bekommen für per Mail?
Ja, aber ich hab alle meine...
Den hat jemand einsortiert.
Ja, aber ich hab alle meine Mail-Programme so konfiguriert, dass sie nicht automatisch...
Ja, vielleicht hat man irgendwie aus Versehen, hast dein iPad nicht gelockt, dein Kind hat da drauf rumgetouched und bang.
Wer ist denn da dein Kalenderserver?
Google?
Kann nicht sein, dass dein Gmail schlau war, weil wurde nämlich an eine Gmail-Adresse adressiert. Kann nicht sein, dass Gmail schlau war und jetzt hingegangen ist, dass mal ein Spam durchgerutscht ist bei Google. Und die auch gleich gesagt haben, oh, ein Kalender-Ding, das kann man ja gleich mal in deinen tollen Google-Kalender mit reinmachen.
Ach so, der schickt das direkt an den Kalender. U, B, pra-la-la, diese komische Geschichte.
Ja, das ginge auch. Aber den müsst ihr jetzt raten. Das geht auch. Aber dafür ist ja dieser lange String da. Das sollte eigentlich nicht passieren. Wobei, Google hat schon immer ein großes Problem gehabt. Google versucht, so viel wie möglich Mail zuzustellen und möglichst wenig Ärger zu haben. Das heißt, die hatten es lange Zeit so, obwohl du bloß einen Account hast, wie tim.pritloff.gmail.com, konnte man auch tim.protliff schicken. Und dann hat sich Google gedacht, das klingt ja fast so wie Tim Pritloff und ich hab keine Ahnung, wo das Match-Arte-Trick bei Tim in die Box. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie das immer noch so machen, aber damit halten sich die Ärger von der Hotline fern und du willst halt keine Mails queuen. Das kann durchaus sein. Normalerweise, so Nigeria-Scheiß findet Google eigentlich schon seit Jahren.
Ich hab diese Mail... Also ich denke, dass ich diese Mail nicht direkt erhalten habe über meine normalen Mail-Accounts. Also nicht, dass ich jetzt glaube, dass sie auf jeden Fall unbedingt im Spam-Filter gelandet sein muss, aber irgendwie hab ich gerade so das Gefühl, dass die mehr so einen direkt zu Google-Kalender-Methode hier verwenden. Also vielleicht hab ich auch total unrecht, aber ich wüsste einfach nicht, wo das jetzt einschlagen sollte, dass es ausgerechnet im Freak Show-Kalender auftaucht.
Du wirst ja nicht direkt adressiert, das wird gestreut.
Also wenn schon, dann in meinem Default-Kalender. Also wenn ich wirklich jetzt über meine Mail automatisch das eingetragen bekomme, dann müsste es mein Default-Kalender sein, aber das ist halt der Ankündigungskalender der Freak Show da draußen. Und das taucht jetzt bei allen Leuten auf und guckt.
Aber es gibt halt einen Account für diesen Freak Show-Kalender, wenn du da runterklappst.
Ja, das ist ja das, was ich gerade vorgelesen habe und das ist halt irgendwie so eine obskure...
Wenn man da was hinschreibt...
Ja, aber wo kann man denn diese Informationen her haben?
Das können die doch nicht durchrutieren.
Das können die nicht durchrutieren, deswegen ist es ja so lang und so verworren.
Heute. Heute Freak Show-Kalender. Contact now for your ATM-Card. Jetzt werden wir wieder alle sagen, ich rede ja wie ein Inder. Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, wie Nigriane reden. Sind ja eh alle nicht echt.
Mehr wie ein Jamaikaner. Das ist für dich so farb. So viel Westafrikanische Winterzeit.
So viel Winterzeit muss sein.
So viel Winterzeit muss sein. Auch Westafrikanisch.
Also ihr wisst auch nicht, wo das herkommt.
Aber in den Kommentaren wird sich sicherlich...
Vielleicht bist du da im Trendsetter.
Ich hab letztens hier im 300 Herz Podcast einer so ein geiles Kommentar geschrieben. Das war das schönste Kommentar, was ich bisher bekommen hab, weil...
Das war das schönste Kommentar.
Das war der, dessen, wessen Kommentar. Dem Kommentar. Der E-Mail. Da haben wir irgendwie so über Kabelklang und Längen und Impedanzen so philosophiert und uns natürlich vertan, wie man das im Podcast macht. Und dann hat der... So schlimm wär jetzt nicht, aber... Dann hat der werte Herr Kommentator das mal ganz korrekt aufgeschlüsselt und hat dann noch dazu Links zu Elektronik-Bastel-Anleitungen und wie man bestimmte Probleme wie löst. Das war so die Nerd-Antwort-TM. So ist das eigentlich. Und hier...
Gibt noch Leute, die Kommentare schreiben, die keine Trolle sind. Das ist gut zu wissen.
Das war wirklich... Da hab ich mich sehr gefreut, dass auch mit unserem Gitarren-Quatsch-Cast wir den ein oder anderen Nerd zur Höchstleistung befähigt haben.
Ungeahnte Nerd-Lös... Höchstleistung. Ich werd jetzt mal hier diesen komischen Kalenderevent mal irgendwie... Wie kann man den ja, ich will den gerne erstmal speichern, der ist so schön.
Ich schieb ihn doch in einen Kalender, den du Spam nennst. Jetzt fängt's an.
Der lässt dich irgendwie gar nicht verschieben gerade.
Das kann man ja auch nach der Sendung noch machen.
Spam-Kalender, oh Mann, oh Mann, oh Mann.
Lass uns einen... Planung privat ist natürlich auch gut.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das schlau war, weil der Organizer ist jemand anders. Und wenn du jetzt an dem... Obwohl, wenn du änderst nicht die Zeit, das könnte durchaus sein, dass wenn du an diesem Termin rumdickelst, dass der dann wieder eine Mail kriegt. Was natürlich echt scheiße ist. Das willst du auf gar keinen Fall.
Nee, das ist alles total gaga.
Delete.
Ich sag aber Mail-Event, dann ist hier eine Kopie irgendwie. Die kann ich gleich auf dem Desktop ziehen. So, und jetzt wird das gelöscht und contact now for your ATM-Card, fuck you. Gut, dann haben wir das ja dann überlebt. Gerade noch so, wa? Gerade noch so. Ja, dann wollen wir Schluss machen?
Leute, ein letzter Aufruf. Benutzt E-Mail Full Names. Und wer nicht versteht, weil ich damit meine Auflösung in der nächsten Folge... Das ist jetzt der Cliffhanger. Benutzt E-Mail Full Names, I mean it.
Ja, E-Mail Full Names, wir merken uns das.
Gerade die Leute, bei denen ich gestern war, bitte. Die hören nämlich auch zu.
Hattest du nicht noch einen anderen Song?
Das ist jetzt erstmal das Outro.
Wir machen jetzt aber hier erstmal Schluss, damit wir es auch selber irgendwie wissen und verabschieden uns. Das war die 117. Freak Show.